Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
You feel
Heat. Heat.
An oasis in the desert as radiant as the
sundisk. This is the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Las Vegas.
My name is Kasanova and alongside my
phenomenal team of experts on coverage,
we're here to guide you through this
mirage of complex plays, incredible
bluffs, and unforgettable top decks as
our parched competitors wade through the
vast desert, looking for their chance to
win their best of or become the best of
all.
While our card game may be different
than those played in the casinos on the
strip, there is one core rule that
remains. You have to know when to hold
and when to fold. The Riftbound regional
qualifier in Las Vegas begins now.
Hello and welcome everyone to Las Vegas
here for this Riftbound regional
qualify. My name is Pat Time and I am
very very pleased to announce I'm
alongside Ursa for this weekend. This is
going to be incredible.
>> I am so excited to see what we get to
see this weekend. Las Vegas has been so
much fun and the players are excited.
Yeah, we were here kind of yesterday
just looking around, shooting some
content and uh kind of scoping out what
people were playing in the preq and
already a lot of exciting things here.
>> Yeah, even in the preq there was so many
cool different decks. I got to see a Lux
versus Yaso at one point which I did not
expect.
>> No, I didn't. But as far as what we have
in store for you this weekend, let's
take a look at the schedule because the
days are going to look pretty similar.
It is eight rounds each day effectively.
Today on Saturday, eight rounds of Swiss
where 18 points or more will let you
advance to day two, which gives you the
best chance of course on championship
Sunday where five rounds of Swiss will
cut to top eight where a single
elimination bracket will happen. We will
crown another regional qualifier
champion. Bologn was awesome last week.
Very excited to see what happens here
for the first North American regional
qualifier in 2026.
>> Yeah, there's so many awesome players
playing this weekend. It's going to be
so much fun to see what they bring and
what ends up in our top eight tomorrow.
And of course, players are playing for,
you know, some decent prizes we can say
here just for the regional qualifier.
Not only is top 64 going to qualify you
for the actual regional itself, but here
are the prizes as well. The champion
will win the Blade of the Ruin King
promo and play that is exclusive to the
winner of this event or winners of their
RQs in general. Top eight gets a promo
blade of the ruin king and a bit of
cash. Then top 32 is going to get cash
as well as everyone that participates is
going to get a participation promo bone
shiver. Lots of awesome stuff on offer
here.
>> Yeah, so many cool things. I really love
the new Blade of the Ruin King art that
the champion gets and I'm so excited to
see if somebody could actually play it
in a deck in the future.
>> Yeah. Or if more than one person in the
world can win it.
>> That is true
>> cuz the winner of Alonia is here as
well. I'm sure we'll talk a lot about
Allan as the weekend goes on. But uh
there's a lot of cool stuff that players
are playing for. But something we've
talked about a lot in Rift Weekends is
of course the best of prize game.
Kasanova is going to give us a look at
what's on offer for those best of
prizes.
There's not only the trophy, the
playmat, the title of champion on the
line at this event, but also for all 28
legends, a best of metallic card for the
player who places the highest on each
one. And if you haven't had a chance to
see these in person, they are in this
case right next to the merch wall. And
they are gorgeous. Individual metallic
detailing on every single one.
completely unique backgrounds for each
of these legends and they are very
limited in quantity as they will rotate
out over time. So, if this is your
opportunity to play your favorite
legend, this is your chance to actually
win a medal.
I think we'll be talking about best
surprising a lot as the weekend goes.
Today, if you got to win one, which
legend would you grab?
>> Oh my gosh, which one would I win? Ah, I
am currently in love with the Azir list.
So, I think I would want to win uh Azir
the king himself. What about you?
>> Uh I've been playing a lot of Aurelia. I
love Yaso. So, either of those I think
would be happy. But it's incredible to
see how much the community has showed
out just to win best of rising. Yes, in
some cases the winner of the tournament
is also going to win the best of for
that legend. But just the battle and the
race for the best of is been such a fun
thing to track throughout Riftbound's
history so far. Yeah, I feel like the
community really comes together, like
the groups come together to make a
really fun list and try to, you know,
win the best of as a group, which is
just so cool.
>> Yeah, of course. So, if you're
interested in Riftbound, maybe you're
watching this for the first time, you
think, hang on a second, this looks kind
of fun. Well, don't worry, there's
plenty more Riffound events coming up.
Let's have a look at the road map now
for Riftbound because there is a lot
going. We started at the end of last
year in Houston. That was the first ever
regional qualifier in North America. We
we had Bolognia a literally a week ago
as a bunch of players from that
tournament have flown in for Las Vegas
which is here February 27th through 1st
this weekend. But there's more to come.
There is a lot of Riftbound on offer
here as plenty of events probably coming
to a city near you. Little is coming up
in France. Atlanta back in NA Unleashed.
The third set is going to come out in
May. That seems so soon my hometown of
Sydney right before my birthday I might
add. If anyone is thinking about needing
an extra commentator for that event. Uh
Sydney is going to be running an RQ
there in Australia. Canada is going to
have Vancouver blessed with an RQ. Utre
and then Hartford. And there's uh even
more I have to tell you that is not all
the roofbound events. We couldn't fit
them on the screen. Vendetta is going to
release in July. That's set for
Barcelona an incredible city. They're
going to have an RQ in August. Singapore
getting event in September. Radiance
will release in October. And LA is going
to host in September. So that is an
unbelievable amount of RQ events leading
into what is going to be eventually the
game's first ever original, which hasn't
even happened yet. But already the
regional qualifiers have so many people
showing up.
>> Yeah, there's been so I mean so much
great gameplay we've already seen.
There's so much more to come and just
within the first six months most of this
year there's going to be so many
different regionals that different
players can attend and get to meet
everyone.
>> It's wild to think that we are at event
three.
>> Yeah. Already it's insane.
>> Yeah. And I already feel like you'd
expect maybe three things start ramping
up. Maybe not that many people. There
are a lot of people here in Vegas. This
bolognia I feel like was maybe even
bigger as far as number of attendees go
based on what we saw and of course
Houston of course kick things off. So a
lot to look forward to if you love
competitive Riftbound and maybe want to
try your hand at a tournament. Uh you
honestly should should get out here and
try and play if if you can cuz there are
some really cool things happening here
uh in organized play for Riftbound.
>> Yeah, I love attending regionals. Like
you meet so many cool different people.
Everyone's so excited and you all really
just have like a love for the game that
you share together that makes it just so
much fun.
>> So we talked a lot about Riftbound.
Doing Riftbound? Let's have a look. We
have a feature match coming up. We can
have a look at some deck list and see
what we have in store for our first
round of F. Oh my goodness. We have
Rumble on stream to kick things off.
Brianna Hatfield going to be piling this
legend. I did not expect to see this to
kick off our tournament.
>> Yeah, Rumble is such an interesting deck
and it's not one that you see too often.
I'm really excited to see how she really
pulls this off. Rumble is so cool and
it's the introduction really of these
different mech uh mech cards. There's so
many different in here that work well
together. And I'm also going to keep an
eye on this sideboard card, the
Minotaur, because there's a lot of
purple decks that are going to be trying
to push things back to base, and he just
stops it completely.
>> A lot of really interesting one-ups just
in the main deck. You see Bell's breath
man, an angle shot that's basically
anti-draven in the main. Uh, smoke
screen is a oneup is pretty nice cuz
your opponent has to kind of respect
your tricks. Even a Brin here, which we
do see an extra one in the sideboard.
Maybe just hedging against probably the
Ezreal we might see over the course of
the weekend.
>> Yeah, a Brin here. cool both against
Ezreal, against Ireelia, Draven as well.
It just stops any type of interaction
that your opponent could have during
your turn, which is really nice that you
know what to expect.
>> Well, this is one. Let's have a look at
the other cuz there's of course an
opponent here for Silverfuse. Oh, sorry.
That was the Rumble deck here. I don't
think we have Rumble Mirror, although I
will be very happy if we do. But we can
have a look at the other deck list here
as well. Silverfuse, of course, uh
someone I've actually worked with on
Legendary Terror a long time ago as
well. So really cool to see her
competing here. Playing Rumble of All
Legends is really nice. Those
battlefields also, by the way, are
sticking out.
>> Um, yeah, I think these choices are so
cool. Like Grow of the God Willow is so
much fun. I think it's one of my
favorite battlefields actually of set
one. It's so strong in this game to hold
on a battlefield. When you conquer, you
already get one point. Holding gives you
a second, and your unit has survived.
And now, not only do you get to save
your unit, you also get card draw off
it, which during set one could win you
the game sometimes.
>> Makes a lot of sense in Rumble cuz you
do kind of want to you just want to put
might on battlefields and hold them as
long as you can. Rumble Legends gives
you shield, so it makes you better at
holding. Uh often the Rumble decks play
Rumble Scrapper, the blue one. I don't
know if I saw that in the deck list cuz
the red rumble hotaded is the most
common champion choice by far as the
chosen champion, but you do get
advantage of holding on some of your
cards as well. So, makes sense to want
battlefields that you can really stick
to. Bom's Lair. Even Paper Tree was a
battlefield I did not expect to see, but
again, rewarding you for holding and if
your opponent holds, kind of punishing
them in a little way as well.
>> Yeah, for sure. It'll be really cool to
see if she can use that to gain her win
in this round one and set her up for,
you know, a good gameplay throughout
today.
>> Let's have a look at her opponent.
Rumble on one side of the feature match.
Who's on the other? Oh, yeah. We've
obviously expected Jinx. Yeah, I mean I
wouldn't expect it too much if I'm being
completely honest, but Jinx is such a
cool card. Also so many cool arts with
the arcane version of Jinx and Red
Purple is a really nice color. I'm
really excited to see what we have here.
Uh
>> anything sticking out to you cuz this is
looking like a shell we're probably
going to see a lot of this weekend.
>> Yeah, I think we are going to see
similar decks uh especially with Draven
that we'll see later today. But I love
seeing Edge of Night. It's a gear. is a
one that you can attach to one of your
units, but most interestingly it's its
hidden effect. So you can hide it and
play it for almost permanent might later
in the game.
>> Yeah, a lot of really good hidden cards
in the format. So I do like it as a
one-off cuz it's something else your
opponent has to think about. This
obviously is kind of the miracle shell
that I alluded to. Three seals, three
Rases, Alas, right, some fizzes, and
three Ezreals. That's kind of the core
you're going to see among all the other
good fury and chaos cards you can have.
Interesting to note for me at least.
Battlefield's looking very standard, but
in the chosen champion zone, purple
jinx, not one you'd see from the typical
Jinx list maybe back in Origins where
the discarding and the aggression was
way more important, but this one's just
maybe a bit more bit bigger, which
again, both these decks in different
ways are going to try and put a lot of
might onto the battlefield.
>> Yeah, I think it's a great choice.
There's a lot of big might characters
here in the set two and a lot of
different decks that they're going to
have to deal with. I think one really,
really interesting thing though, it's
all purple. That's insane for 12 uh I
mean all 12 runes to be purple. And so
obviously the deck is going to mirror
that as well. You do have to recycle
cards in Riftband which is different
from a lot of different games where
we're going to place uh the chosen
recycled card to the bottom of a
specific deck. Um but it will make sure
that this deck always has purples to
recycle.
>> Well, I think we've yapped enough. I
know what the people want. I've been
casting for a while at least in other
games. So, let's get down to the feature
match and have ourselves round number
one of this regional qualify here in Las
Vegas. It is Brianna Hatfield versus
John Bergland. Rumble versus Jinx. And
Paper Tree is going to be the first
Battlefield for game one versus Zorn
Warren. Zorn Warren very standard. Paper
Tree. I'm going to be honest, I don't
think I expected to see this at all this
weekend.
>> Yeah, I definitely did not think I would
see it, but I think John's list is set
up for Zan Warren. Uh I think I believe
I saw the scrap heap in his list. So
very standard with the game one. One of
his plans to be here is going to be to
make sure he finds his true drop being
traveling merchant. Um and I mean it's
important for both of them, but Zon
Warren is going to allow him to discard
a lot of cards which is going to play
into his chosen champion of that Jinx.
Um and then also the traveling merchant
will give double that effect.
>> Yeah, I think one of the things you can
think about when when you look at these
purple decks and we talk about miracle
shells, what we're really talking about
are decks that want to churn through
their deck as fast as possible. The goal
is to draw a lot of cards, get through
your deck, cycle through it, and then
get to a point where you start recycling
cards and put them into your deck, and
then all of a sudden, the only cards you
are drawing are the good cards,
>> and that will make for a fantastic game
for you if you can do it. So, fingers
crossed we see that come down here. They
are just doing their mulligans, it looks
like. Uh, or maybe they already have.
Um, but in this game, it's actually kind
of a unique mulligan where you get to
choose two of your four original cards
and then put them at the bottom of your
deck. Then you get to draw the next two.
So, you don't actually shuffle
afterwards. And no matter what, you
would have seen the next two cards in
that exact order.
>> Very much appreciate the lack of
shuffling as it is going to be Rumble
starting off first. Plundering Porro
going to be the first unit deployed to
base here. And Jung going to go second
here on Jinx. Going to channel through
runes. As you astutely pointed out, only
purple in this deck, so only cares about
purple power. All of the fury cards are
ones that don't cost power. And a
merchant on turn one. Pretty nice.
>> Yeah, very, very nice start. Uh, I think
Brand is also happy with theirs
Plundering Porro brings out one of the
new card uh new mechanics in set two,
which is gold. If this Plundering Po can
conquer either of these battlefields,
he'll be able to generate one gold.
>> Yeah, that gold of course basically
acting as an additional power. It's kind
of like a seal that you only get to use
once, but very powerful when you're
trying to pay power costs, especially if
you're trying to play multiple spells a
turn. And Rumble, a lot of those mechs
have some pretty hefty power costs. You
think about a card like Singularity,
very powerful card in mind. That is two
blue power you need to power that one.
So, going to be good to get the gold
early here.
>> Yeah, that'll be really nice.
Singularity is so strong. Love to see it
as soon as turn three, though. I guess
Jinx is probably running some lower
might units uh like this Traveling
Merchant. We'll have to see what comes
out here from the rumble.
>> Yeah, the curving is really nice here as
well cuz obviously you have a two. Going
to go to the warrants here for Brianna
and just go ahead and conquer, get a
point, a first one of the event. Always
nice to get on the board first and then
draw a discard. Make a gold on conquer
there for the Plundering Porro. One of
the nice things about Rumble is that
this is a four energy uh champion that
you can put in your champion zone as
Rumble that doesn't cost you any power.
So, it's really easy to curve turn one,
turn two.
>> Yeah, that's so nice. and getting these
nice little units out that don't have
power allow you to get all your runes
set up and have more for those following
turns. Uh
>> I'm I'm interested if we will see a
different card in hand or if we're
actually just going to play it directly
from the champ in zone, but it looks
like Gem Jammer is going to be our turn
two unit here.
>> Jim Jammer. I'm double checking. Is Gem
Jammer a mech? Because I've been looking
at the mechs. It is. It is a mech. Wow,
when you play me, give a unit ganking
this turn. Shout out production. Uh
valuing the extra two drop and the mech
here. Maybe holding up a spell here
also.
>> Yeah, Jim Jimmer is so nice with that uh
ganking that we mentioned. I am
interested to see if traveling merchant
will successfully get into this
battlefield with two runes up. Uh red
and red and blue have some options to
stopping this traveling merchant from
taking that point. But Jon does get
their point and we're we're even now.
>> Yeah, feels good. Again, I kind of like
this going to the warrants, denying Jinx
a potential draw. Again, trying to get
through the deck quickly. So, every
little draw discard does count. Merchant
obviously triggers on move. So, has that
before anything else happens. But,
Ezreal, a card you're going to get sick
of hearing me say, I think over the
course of this weekend,
>> three energy, very powerful passive
text, but the the one that feels good is
the first part. When you play me,
discard one, draw two.
>> Yeah, I will say we drew a card that we
wish we had already had in hand. Ezreal
is discarding like you mentioned in
drawing two, but you really want to
start with that seal for Ezreal or be
able to discard the scrap heap with
Ezreal. And we drew into it. We can
still play it later. When you discard
scrap heap, you're allowed to draw an
extra card. So, we're going to be
looking at that Zon Warren or movement
from that traveling merchant to get that
extra draw from.
>> Again, makes a lot of sense. Just trying
to get through the cards, get the deck
as thin as you can, and then start
really just vomiting might onto the
board. honestly is a lot of what the
battering ram style stuff does.
>> See although very important to again
like being able to play lots of spells
as you get later into the game. Some
list we may find over the weekend have
things like Nocturn which can benefit
from finding off the power when you see
them on the top of your deck. But for
now it is a classic of origins falling
star pointing at the two units on the
board and said I would like these gone.
And it looks like hard bargain going to
be the card to answer this.
>> Ouch. We do have multiple runes up
though. So, while Raina almost could
have been stopped there, she knew to
hold that uh hold those runes and was
able to play that hard bargain cost,
meaning Jon's board is completely wiped.
What are they what are they going to do
here going into their next turn
potentially?
>> Yeah, get a bit of a discount as well
thanks to the gold plundering power
generated. Gem Jammer now going to get
on the paper tree. That's three points
to one. Has to feel pretty good for the
start of this game. And again,
Battlefield wipes out Ezreal. Again,
that passive tax is extremely good for
this deck. So, taking that Ezreal off
the field doesn't seem like the most
threatening unit. Doesn't have that much
might as a three drop, but you
definitely want to get it off the board
if you can.
>> Yeah, this deck is all about not only,
you know, discarding and setting up that
deck in the order that you want, but
also discounting, as you mentioned, the
battering ram, trying to bring it in as
low cost as possible. We're going to be
looking for that rosa that gets
discounted based on how many cards are
in your discard pile and Ezreal just
plays into that discounting additional
cost which can be like the repeat on
hard bargain or accelerate cost as well.
>> Yeah, we talk about gold kind of being a
thing to discount power on on Rumble
side. That is effectively the same for
Ezreal tech, right? Reducing some of the
power burden there as well,
>> especially if you're playing powerful
repeat effect. So, so far so good. Five
points now for the Rumble player here in
game one. Off to the races. But I have
to say you do need to get an early start
here. I think as Rumble, I don't think
you can match the late game that this
Jinx deck can get to.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see. I We do have a
couple I think bigger units that you can
be playing in Rumble like uh Ferris
4Runner. I'm not sure if I saw it in
their list or not, but Ferris 4Runner
with six might is really nice as well.
>> I would guess for blind looking at any
Rumble deck that is registered this
weekend. So maybe not in hand right now,
but have to imagine that's available.
Looks like seven runes right now and no
gold as both units do retreat back to
base here again. Valuing uh taking those
battlefields later, not wanting to hold
with the battering ram now on the board.
It was basically the play there for John
just plopping down a uh five might unit
which is good but a lot worse when it
costs five and going to be matched by a
five drop of her own as that is rumble
scrapper. Very good when you can hold
makes a mech in base.
>> Yeah, we love the blue rumble. that is
the other choice that she could use in
future games for the chosen champion
spot. Uh but yeah, nice to see come in
and we'll have to see if we can see a
hold next turn, but also plus one might
to all mechs. So just a just a buff
across the board.
>> And of course, don't forget Rumble's
legend ability gives all your mechs
assault. So on offense, which they're
currently queued up for thanks to being
all in the base, uh it's effectively
plus two on offense with Rumble Scrapper
being on the board. So, Mega Death
Rocket's going to shoot that one in the
face and uh going to deal five to a five
might unit.
>> Ooh, we have one
>> stone. Ooh, retreat.
>> That's a nice one. Retreat not only
saves your unit potentially, but also
helps generate runes, which we can use
in these future turns.
>> Yep. Kind of makes up for the power cost
that Brianna just had to pay. Uh did
have to use one mind power there in
order to get the scrapper out. So, nice
to see kind of a not a discount
necessarily, but you know, a rebate, I
guess we can call it. and battering
going to make their way to the warrants
for the first time actually for Jinx
which is going to be successful again I
think being on the play and taking that
battlefield first really dissuaded Jinx
from wanting to take it so finally
getting a draw discard which again I
can't emphasize enough how much this
deck just wants to get through their
deck so slowing that down as early as
possible felt like a really good opening
here but I see a fizz see a stack deck I
think I see a fight or flight in the
hands here for five cards to go and
three more runes after this play which
is going to be stack deck
>> yeah stack deck will bring us uh it
looks like we're at three runes We have
some options still after the stack deck.
We do luckily get to look at the top
three cards of our deck. We get to
choose the best card from those three
and the other two will go to the bottom
of Jon's deck, getting them somewhat in
the order that he wants it, but also to
procure a good card for his hand in his
upcoming turn.
>> Yeah, just the kind of card that gives
you a lot of selection, which is very
powerful in just about any card game.
This was, I think,
>> think the most expensive uncommon in
Origins. This is a card that was highly
sought after as uh I see Jon fishing
through the trash, which I know what's
going on because I can see John's hand.
But I think Pria probably knows that a
Fizz is maybe on the horizon here as
well. Wonder what the recycle's going to
be. Look, two drop instead. Is that
Merchant? No, it's Battering Ram. A
little bit of a discount there thanks to
playing the stack deck and the seal that
turn.
>> Yeah, it's really nice to get it get to
play it for less. But yeah, we'll have
to keep an eye on Fizz. When you play
Fizz, you are allowed to play one of
those spells from our discard pile. Uh,
and so depending what it is, it could be
a really strong turn coming up. One rune
is left up for Jon, which is the the
magic number for purple is we're looking
at two runes, there's so many options in
these purple decks that when you're at
two runes, Brienne would have a lot more
things to think about when they either
go into Zan Warren or Paper Tree. But
ouch, a singularity coming down and
wiping the board again. Not a deck I
really think of in terms of just playing
efficient removal. But this these other
domains that Rumble is in Falling Star,
Singularity, these are all star from
Origins as far as removal goes. So
again, John trying to establish might
with these relatively big units for
their cost, especially when Battering
gets a discount. And
>> Brian just saying, "Nope, I'm going to
take point number six and a gold and
probably Gem Jam is going to move over
to Paper Tree as well." And as you kind
of alluded to, I think without a hidden
card, especially very hard for Jinx to
represent much of anything, especially
as we could see, even if Brianna doesn't
know it's only purple runes, you have a
pretty strong suspicion at this point
cuz you're not going to get a hex rate
in this spot either.
>> Yeah, 100%. So even though she has red,
maybe we don't have to worry about some
of those red uh red spells that could
remove.
So Rihanna has that that plus or buff in
their deck actually having those removal
spells.
>> Yeah. just gives you an idea of like
what could my opponent have, right? A
lot of options get narrowed down. As we
can see, has to get out of kind of a
sticky situation. A hold is going to win
here. I will remind the audience,
Brianna is at seven points right now on
Rumble. So, a hold is good enough. Of
course, a double conquer on the
following turn would be good enough as
well. Not that many runes left up here.
Just three on the Rumble side. So, not a
lot of potential protection on offer,
but you only have to hold one of these
to win. And uh you're looking pretty
good uh in general given how ahead on
the race you So, it's going to be Jinx
>> when discard, get bigger, get ready,
which is going to be pretty good in this
spot.
>> Yeah, this is going to be so nice.
Hopefully, Jon will be able to take at
least one sides, but he has to take
both. Uh, in Riftbound, that Wind Con is
not just hitting eight, but to hit
eight, you either have to conquer both
battlefields or have held or have had
control of the battlefield, both of them
same turn, or hold to eight. So while
maybe if there was a conqueror would be
as big a deal, he has to wipe both sides
here or he's going to lose his game.
>> Turn might be pretty good. Jinx is going
to get ready and get bigger. Ezreal
spell two for the turn. Battering ram
one of the draws off the top from this
Ezreal draw. So we can play a few more
spells. We can put a lot of might on the
battlefield nice and quickly. Instead
going to go ahead and start by
challenging the plundering power at the
warren. And that is also going to give
uh Jinx uh sorry ready Jinx again by
drawing and discarding after the
conquer. So lot of nice synergy here for
Jinx. Yeah, very very true. So, we'll
see that discard that ready and I'm
assum I'm I don't believe she has
gankings. We'll have to go back to the
battle the base, but I'm sure there's
going to be another option to discard
and get into paper tree.
>> I can tell you I see a boots of
swiftness in Jon's hand, but
unfortunately boots is a little too
expensive to play on this board. That
would be a way to give ganking in this
spot. As you can see, Jinx Rebel on your
screen when you discard one cards ready
me and give me plus one this turn. also
the ability to pick up uh super mega
death rocket from the trash but little
expensive to go here as what happened to
poor Jinx.
>> It looks like we are just going to
concede and go game two. I think the
other option if we had had one more rune
open which we didn't is to get that ride
that fight or flight back to base. It
would maintain the readiness and then be
able to go in. But we did just miss by
one rune. So sad. But it's something to
keep our eye on. If maybe we'd even just
been able to get the seal a turn earlier
when we had to spend one to play as,
we'd have had that rune to be able to
fight or flight back and go into paper.
>> Great catch there. It was just a hold.
Not a two might unit I didn't expect to
win by holding in our first game, but
that is what happens. Rumble going to
take the first one here. One zero up now
for Brianna. We'll see if Jinx can get
the wheels turning in game number two as
we switch battlefields. Vomar's layer on
the other side and Minefield the two
selected here. Yeah, Vioma is such a
great choice in my opinion uh for
Brianna. She's going to be going against
so many purple decks today and many of
these purple decks are relying on that
same card we mentioned earlier, fight or
flight or different movement spells that
purple has to bring their units back to
base and vile just says you are not
allowed to move to base. So really
really nice against purple and Jinx is
not going to want to conquer at first.
>> Yes,
>> as a Yasway player makes me very sad.
Even in the in the instance we saw with
Jinx Rebel if it's ready can't move back
the regular way. have to find another
way. Maybe ganking over with the boots
of swiftness is going to be one of those
ways. But we'll shuffle up for game two.
Minefield of course on the other side.
Uh some of the same I think we can say
as far as zongworns go. Not exactly the
same. Don't get the draw with the
discard but do get to put some cards in
your trash which as you mentioned with
cards like Rasa with having access to
your graveyard with things like Fizz.
Get a lot of benefits from conquering
there and kind of again shuffling cards
between different zones which is really
what this deck is trying to do.
>> Exactly. So we'll have to see if they
can utilize it well. It's gonna be so
interesting. Hopefully Jon will be able
to get more cards than discile discard
uh be able to discount more of their
units that having to pay full price for
battling batting ram or having to pay
that uh recycle for Ezreal is just not
where you want to be. You
>> can kind of see some of the appeal
though for Rumble just even watching
that game. You're just very consistent,
right? You find your two drop, you have
a two into a very clean four. you're
constantly putting uh good numbers onto
the battlefield, applying pressure to
your opponent, and just saying, "Hey, I
know your deck is going to do something
very powerful if you're given enough
time." My goal is to just not give you
enough time.
>> It's a good game plan. I would say
that's a good game plan. So, if we can
do it again, it'll be great to see. I do
think sometimes like these miracle decks
come from behind, but Rumble's going to
try to stop it. And Rumble does have
extra might that assault you mentioned,
from the plus one, from the blue Rumble,
I believe it is. Um, so we'll have to
see how it really plays out and
>> if they'll be able to take game two as
well or maybe we'll see a game three.
That would be awesome between these two
decks.
>> I certainly would be. I have a feeling I
mixed up my Rumbles, which is okay. I
think Rumble Linen gives Shield and Red
Rumble gives assault. Yes, that is
correct.
>> Ah, my bad.
>> No, that's fine. That was
>> I led you down the wrong path and you
just went with me, which I appreciate
you following me blindly, but uh mild
mild correction there. It is rumble
legend giving shield. But again, if you
have them both, and again, it is your
legend and your chosen champion, you
effectively just get plus one, which is
by the way the text on rumble scrapper.
So if you have all of them in play, if
you have the the full rumble, I suppose
as we say, the full mech army assembled,
you get plus two effectively whenever
you're on a battlefield, which is I
guess it's even if you're going to a
battlefield. Yeah, it's pretty good.
>> That's pretty good. Yeah, I I think
getting free plus might is fantastic in
this game. Uh we love we love might.
>> We do love might. Everyone loves some
good numbers as players are just having
a little yap and should be off to the
races in short order here
>> as Rumble up one zero early on here.
>> Mhm. I would love to see the scrapper
rumble be able to actually uh get one of
those three might mechs though. Maybe
that's my wish list for this game.
>> That's your wish list?
>> That's my wish list for this game.
>> It's a good one.
>> Um
>> to think of what I want to see. I want
to see a spell song do something fun. I
I think but that would require one to do
anything which I think is probably not
going to happen. And sorry medic. I'm
trying out here.
>> Oh no.
>> Yeah. The nice thing about Rumble
Scrapper is uh the passive tax of Max
getting plus one applies to the three
might token you make. So you basically
make fours whenever you hold as long as
that is in play. But we're back here on
the play now for John. Jinx is going to
play traveling merchant on turn one. And
all of a sudden feels a lot better for
the Jinx player.
>> Yeah, getting this I mean getting their
two drop so quickly going first. I think
Jinx is feeling pretty confident. Um,
but
obviously that could change quickly if
maybe we see Falling Star in a couple
turns, if we see that same board wipe
that Brianna was able to pull off last
game. But it does look like Bumblebot
Bubble Bubble Bot is going to be coming
down. I mixed up Rumble. Uh, coming down
here into the base. When you play it,
they you're able to ready another
friendly mech, which is really nice
later in game, but for now, there is no
other mech for her.
>> Yeah, just a great little card in
Rumble. good early here. You know,
pretty good rate at a three drop with
three might. But, uh, running something
big like a fourrunner, maybe breakneck
mech if you're playing. I don't know how
many rumble decks play the card. I'm
obsessed with that card cuz I want to
play terrible cards that cost too much
energy of stack deck. Going to be the
first spell put on the chain here.
>> Let's see. Uh,
>> did we get seal off of stack? That's a
nice card to get. Go ahead.
>> So, we are going to be able to recycle
the one that we had already exhausted.
Um, so really nice to bring that down
and it brings a couple options here. I
see called shot in hand, which is going
to be really nice to draw through our
cards. You get to look at it's kind of a
smaller stack deck and for cheaperish
uh where you get to look at two cards
and choose one. The other goes bottom of
your deck. And I also saw Ezreal which
can feed into Shotwell, but it looks
like Rebuke is going Oh, no. Rebuke is a
discard from Charlie Merchant. bad.
>> Yep. Going to move, draw, discard, and
now put some cards into the rubbish bin.
Four already. Again, if we're doing a
Ras account, that's looking pretty good
as far as discounting that unit goes
between that and Bing ram. These are the
big units you often see in these shell
uh the style of builds, I should say,
whether it's Jinx or Draven. But there's
Ezreal. Very nicely curved here using
that seal that was used earlier.
Discarding a backup Ezreal.
>> Oo.
>> And then drawing two cards, including
Arasa.
>> That is nice. cuz you were mentioning
that discard pile is going to be uh
beefing up here essentially going into
minefield. You get to potentially
discard I think it was the top two of
your deck. Uh so so many cards can end
up into your trash pile where Rosa is
really going to feed off of that.
>> Yeah, definitely the battlefield where
you benefit the most from that specific
angle of attack. Swan Warren's kind of a
good allrounder letting you again
discard and draw which is kind of where
you want to be from most of the effects
in your deck. I mean look at Ezreal.
runs is basically a mini version of that
effect that everybody wants access to
right now as it is going to be rumble
hotheaded and bubble butt to the
battlefield. Uh nice little sequencing
king thing here by Silverfuse just
playing the rumble first. So the assault
if it mattered was going to make bubble
butt a little stronger there and again
has shield now from the legend ability
as we do remember how to read all the
different rumbles in the game and going
to go ahead trash two cards from the
top. Bella's breath and one more retreat
as Buckus does want a look and we'll
pass it back here as again the plan has
been established. A point each but mechs
are being deployed to the battlefields.
That's all you want to do is Rumble.
>> Yeah, I think Rumble is playing out
their uh game plan pretty well here. Uh
we are going to be going back to Ezreal.
Not Ezreal, Jinx, but Ezreal is getting
ready. Uh we'll have to see what
happens, but I'd love to see that
contract come down and get some more
cards into Jinx's hand. And as we
mentioned, Ezreal discounts Excel uh
discounts additional cost. So the second
called shot,
>> it's free.
>> It certainly is, which is a very good
price for cold shot. Already cost zero
energy. So getting that power discount
is real nice as well. Super mega death
rocket coming back out once more to take
out Rumble. And there's that cold shot
you mentioned.
>> Yeah, there's COD shot. uh and the death
rocket, you know, starting to clear out
some of Silverfus's board, but we this
is leaving us at one rune, which does
mean we won't have during Silverfus'
turn the option for fight or flight or
different two cost cards.
>> Yeah, this really feels like a setup
turn, I think, on on Jinx's side.
>> Mhm. Ezreal going to get some discounts
again. Just pointing out that I can do
this again
and going to move Ezreal over. Try and
challenge the bubble. But that one has
shield.
>> Mhm.
>> I have no idea.
>> Let's
>> There's Blood Rush. So that's going to
make the difference here.
>> Yeah, that's going to bring Ezreal just
up to the amount it needs to be able to
kill Bubble Bot. But we have one rune
up. doesn't look like we are going to be
using it, but there are some options in
the blue deck with just one. I'm not
sure if it's in the deck, but there are
things like stupify or other things that
can help bring the might down of your
opponent's cards.
>> Yeah, looks like we passed all the way
to kind of resolving damage there. So,
those windows have passed. So, is just
going to say okay, Ezreal can get on the
battlefield. That's totally fine.
>> Second seal.
>> Here comes another seal. And Rocket's
going to come back here as well.
>> That's going to be so nice to get it
back in the hand.
Now that Silverfuse knows it's there,
it's a risk that she's going to have to
wait for every single turn.
>> Yeah, looks like that seal is actually
discarded cuz you do have to discard on
conquer uh discard a card, get your
rocket back is how super mega death
rocket works. I was like running the
text through my head just double
checking exactly when that happened. But
on conquer projects deciding that you
know what, these mech units are pretty
good when you're able to stack a bunch
of them. So now my goal is to just shoot
every single one of them with a giant
rocket so that you can't do that.
Sounds like a feasible game plan and
we're pulling it off here on project
side.
>> Very jinxcoded to just shoot everything
with a big gun. You win.
>> That is very jinx coded. I I think I
think uh League of Legends would be
happy with this.
>> Well, I will say as far as units that
are tough to super mega death rocket.
Ferris 4runner might be at the tippy top
of the list.
>> Yeah, Ferris 4Runner, you wouldn't think
too much of it. It's a six for six and
you're having to recycle one. But Jinx,
who's going to be trying to clear the
board, wipe it. Ferris Sportrunner says,
"No, killed me. I dare you. And I'm
going to make two more units. You have
to deal with."
>> Yeah, even even better with Rumble
because Rumble Hotic will buff those
mess again. They go bigger. The shield
they'll also get. If they rumble hot in
play, they'll get assault. If Scrap is
in play, they'll get plus one. Like
>> these mechs are like, it's already
annoying to have a six might unit and
then split into two three might units,
which is basically another six might
unit. But when those individual units
can also get buffed by might, which is
basically the only thing Rumble wants to
do, then those numbers get pretty big
pretty quickly as traveling merchant
going to reinforce this minefield.
Really trying to hold for some points
here. It is 3 to1 currently. Uh Jinx
ahead on points, but Rumble's kind of
gearing up for a pretty reasonable
assault here in this mid game as Rasa
comes crashing down onto the
battlefield.
>> Yeah, Project is really trying to hold.
I think we are up to Rosa is a six.
We're up to 11 might on the minefield. I
mean, maybe we're not too shy of that
with already six might in our base, but
Silverfuse is going to need
>> multiple more cards here to be able to
take that spot.
>> Yeah, I think either a removal spell, so
something like Singularity, maybe a
Falling Star, or you mentioned it
earlier, Bubble Bot in this section of
the game with another mech could be
quite nice. I see a second fullrunner in
hand.
>> I see a stupify, which I think was the
card you were alluding to earlier. see a
bunch of different threes, but none of
them are twos or sixes, which are the
removal spells I would otherwise be
looking for.
>> Yeah, both of those would be really
nice. I mean, Falling Star could take
out Fallinger um Traveling Merchant. Oh,
there is.
>> This looks a lot like Falling Star.
>> Oh,
>> as soon as your opponent recycles two
red runes, you're like, I'm in I'm in
danger.
>> That I mean, that's Traveling Merchant
and that's Ezreal that could be take um
taken out here. And then Rosa versus
Ferrunner. They're the same might.
>> Yeah. And unlike, you know, something
like Aurelia, which maybe has other uh
spells that can help uh fight the
falling star, you don't get that option
with hard bargain, at least when uh
Silverfuse leaves this many runes open.
>> Yeah, really, really smart play leaving
those up. You know, your opponent has
four runes, which is potentially four
more on this falling.
>> So, he took the Rasa out instead.
Actually decided to falling star that
unit twice. I mean, that is the bigger
might of the two, right? It was 11 split
between three units. So six on one side
is the bigger half, but we are going to
rebuke try and get this 4Runner back to
hand, which is a great place to put it
cuz it doesn't make me when that
happens.
>> Yeah, that is really nice. And by by uh
taking out the roster, we could have
potentially won the whole the whole
showdown as well.
>> Yeah, was six M to five was pretty
geared up to win. I mean, again, things
like fight or flight, things like Kuk,
you're really only looking at getting
pushed out of that fight. You're not
really looking to get out muscled in
that spot. So I do like that play.
Again, trying to keep the tempo high
here. keep the points up as 4Runner gets
redeployed and turn gets passed back. So
that's going to be four points now for
the Jinx holding onto this minefield for
dear life.
>> Yeah, that's going to go up to four
points which we're feeling confident
halfway to the winning mark. Uh and I
mean at one we need to do a lot to come
back
>> that double death. That is double super
mega death. Not enough runes to play
both. So this first formula is going to
be extremely sticky. Instead it's going
to be a seal. Interesting choosing to
recycle here instead of tapping the
seal. Usually playing steal by tapping a
seal is kind of a a very classic play
from Origins, but wanting to maybe
preserve it for something else. So, a
bigger play coming perhaps. It's going
to be death rocket discard.
>> And we get Arasa again. Uh I wouldn't be
surprised if we decide to play. We are
kind of low on hand, but this is where
Jinx's legend comes in. Jinx has a
really interesting legend where believe
it is when you're at one or zero cards,
you get to draw an extra. So, you know,
maybe you don't see the small of hand
normally in a uh miracle or, you know,
Ezreal engine deck, but for Jinx, she's
really happy here.
>> Yeah, this is kind of actually a unique
spot that Jinx gets in this shell versus
something like Draven where you can kind
of go low, look to trade down
aggressively with your spells, with your
units against your opponent, and then
catch back up on cards by naturally
having things happen. So, going to play
this jigs here as well. No battering
around mercifully uh for silverfuse. So
not that much might but traveling
merchant moved back. Discard drew a card
I believe drew the rasa that is now in
play and then that was discount enough
thanks to all of the discarding that's
been happening. So I was wondering why
the units were moving back to base. It's
cuz you already got the point and you do
get benefits from moving the traveling
merchant specifically. So this is
looking like a tough spot here as Ferris
4 going to go to Vom's lair which I
love. This is basically saying this is
my arena. If you come you cannot leave.
Let's fight.
Yeah, I'm not. I mean, Project's been
avoiding it a lot, but oh my gosh, a
second Ferris 4Runner, and it's going to
be hard to dece
>> displace
>> displace them from uh the Vile Mall. We
did see Rebuke, which is an option. Um,
but I will say, as I mentioned earlier,
Fighter Flight isn't one that they can
use here.
>> Yeah, shutting down that card seems
pretty good. Decent amount of might on
the other side. And I think the other
thing is like, yes, you're getting this
battlefield. It's likely you'll be able
to hold it potentially for the entire
game. These are two six might units that
make three might unit two three might
units each and they also have shield
currently thanks to rumbles legend. So
that is 14 might right now holding onto
that layer. But Jinx is at four points.
You can just start racing. If if you
basically each decide that I'm going to
take this battlefield, you're going to
take this one. Let's just race to hold.
I'm going to win if this is if this
stays like this.
>> Yeah, but we do have gym gym miner deck.
Is it? Yeah, I think it's gimm bubble
that gives ganking. And so while maybe
maybe solar fuse can't move back from
biom to base ganking is fair game.
>> You can you can move from one
battlefield to another if you have the
ability as super mega death rook coming
back in
again just kind of using it as a almost
like a card to discard here to this
merchant wanting to again continue
cycling through the deck ready the Jinx
make her bigger. I kind of like that
actually. again was a pretty good
removal spell in the mid game is taking
out that rumble from the champion zone.
That did seem like quite a threat. But
now it almost seems like a card that's
just helping you cycle through the deck,
which is an angle that this version of
Miracle, the Jinx version, is actually
unique to it. This is something Draven
cannot do, of course, because Draven
can't play Jinx's signature spell.
>> Very true. Very true. Uh it looks like
we are playing a hidden up at the top
battlefield.
>> Could be anything.
>> It could be. There's so many choices.
Any guesses?
>> Could even be a boat. Uh Edge of Knight,
I think. I'm going to I'm going to make
my call. There are more fighter fights
and edge of knights in the deck. I think
there's only two fighter fights if I'm
remembering the Jinx deck list
correctly, but I'm going to say this is
the one of Edge of Knight.
>> I would love it be edge of knight. I I
think it may be one of my favorite cards
of the set that's not, you know, a unit,
I guess. Um, but I just think like
bringing out that gear, it introduces
not permanent, but close to permanent
might that you can attach to any of your
units and then Silverfuse is going to
have to keep their eyes on it the whole
game.
>> Yeah. again kind of starving for might
in general especially in this kind of
matchup because Rumble is just
presenting such big numbers on each
battlefield. So any little bit you can
get and again I like the bluffing
aspect. We mostly expect fight or
flight, right? That is the card that
when someone hides a card, you This is
the card I'm expecting as Brin here.
She's going to be put onto the board and
started. Hey, it was edge of the night.
Look at us.
>> Yeah, look at you. You got the guess.
But we will react with that edge of the
night. Uh once Brin here
>> resolves. Yep.
>> Then broad project will not be able to
play any more cards till their turn. So
they don't have flipped it, attached it
to that Rossa said we're eight might
deal with it.
>> Yeah. Again, quite a lot of might to get
through Brin here. Five might on her
own, which is a pretty sweet rate. When
you play, your opponents can't play
cards this turn. That isn't just spells,
that is anything. So, if you have a
hidden unit, you can't do that either.
If you manage to play on your opponent's
turn, you can have a lot of fun. Not in
these domains, but I know some people
have been cooking with here to help,
which seems like a fun way to terrorize
your poor opponent in a game of
riftbound, but I think the same issue
here with six points to three. Yes, you
are likely holding this battlefield for
a very long time, but you need to kind
of hold. Well, you at least need to
prevent the double conquer and you
definitely need to prevent a hold. So,
going to be a tough spot here for Rumble
to get enough might over there to
displace the eight might rasa and that's
not including the rest of the might
that's currently hiding in base.
>> Yeah, there is so much on project side
and Silverview is going to have to find
a way to make it back. Three versus six
points. Better than one versus four in
my opinion, but let's see how it goes.
>> 11 might right now. Boots of fifth is
going to make it two more and of course
give that pretty critical ganking which
is a nice way to get out of the lair if
you find yourself trapped there.
>> Very true.
>> But death rocket once more shoot the
Brin here. Basically anything with five
might the rocket gets pointed at. I just
don't want to deal with that. Take that
out and uh can we get enough over? We I
mean I said there was 11 might on uh on
the side before boots is plus two.
That's 13, but it's 14 including the
shield with the two ferris four runners.
And you don't not not only do you not
want to go Well, you do want to go there
cuz you want to get the four runners off
there,
>> but not only is it a lot of might for
you to to get off the board, if you do
get over there, you just give them more
might.
>> Yeah. I mean, you you take it and
there's six babies in the in the base
and then you don't even have to worry
about him finding Gem Jammer. He can
just move up into the other battlefield.
It's a lot to think about, but it looks
like Rosa is going to be coming back to
base. And it kind of says to me we're
going to be really pushing next turn to
take not only the seventh point, but the
eighth as well and finish off the game.
>> Yeah, kind of a classic Jinx play even
though this Jinx deck doesn't have a lot
of assault in it. Uh playing for the
last two points by conquering both is a
very common play pattern in general in
Rift, but especially with legend like
Jinx. So, six points sitting pretty so
far against the four after the hold here
of these two fourrunners. Again, this
fire monster is going to be extremely
hard to kick these units off.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> But being behind in the race means you
can't just sit there and hold for the
rest of the game. You have to keep
putting units on the board. But
thankfully, that is exactly what Rumble
wants to do is here's four caster, not
shout caster, going to look at the top
card with vision and then decide to put
it on the bottom. Kind of like a very
tiny stack deck effect.
>> Yeah, we get to see the cards, you know.
Uh so at least we'll have an idea what
we get in our next draws. There are some
cards, you know, that Silverfuse has
that have the additional ability of
drawing as well. So maybe it will help
us set up for this next turn.
>> What card did you talk about earlier?
The two drop.
>> H it's stupifying me right now. What was
it?
>> H I definitely heard uh gem jammer at
one point. And I'm pretty sure I see
three of them as well. Someone use his
hand. That would be a way to get another
point this turn. Unfortunately,
generally the odd point break points are
the ones you love in Riftbound because
you, as you pointed out, you generally
get points in even increments, two at a
time if things are going well. But it is
going to be a reinforcement here with
dangerous duo, which I'm going to need
to have production pull the text up
because I do not remember what that card
is. When you play me, give a unit plus
two this turn. Okay, so a nice little
three drop that sometimes in the mid
game makes things a bit bigger. Not
super relevant here. uh does trigger the
legion text, but that is not going to
matter currently as the stupify is just
going to get cycled here to draw a card.
It looks like unless there's a damage
buff coming after this.
>> You see stupify
>> shrinking the Ezreal.
>> So, we shrink Ezreal to two.
>> I think we've already Yeah, I think I've
already discarded Bella's breath, but
right now it would do would help to kill
Ezreal and put additional damage out,
but it may just be a card draw as well.
We got to vision. So maybe we've set
something up at the top of our deck that
we needed to draw and stupify was an
option for that.
>> Yes, Jam Jammer also going to come down.
Reinforce the same battlefield. Seems
like Civil Fuse is committed to at least
putting as much might as possible on
this vile moss there. Does see another
stupify and put it to the bottom thanks
to Forcaster, which does trigger every
time you play a mech, not just the time
you play Forcaster itself. And that's
going to be a pass back here. Two runes
open, but not that many cards in hand.
again just really going for this plan of
I'm gonna make you get the last point
and you're never getting it from this
point because again as you pointed out
it's a hold or a double conquer to win
that eighth point to get that winning
point. Yeah. And as you said there's two
more gem jammers in hand we're
threatening a lot here and while we have
two runes up on silverfuse's side we're
kind of not only threatening
plus two. I mean, if if I read the
dangerous duo correctly, when you play
another card, it gets plus two.
>> Ooh.
>> I'm not sure if if I actually I could
have read that wrong for the record.
Maybe it's a when I think
>> when you play if Legion
>> Never mind then. I'm thinking too.
>> That is correct. That would be hype.
>> Yeah, that would be hype. That would be
hype. I'm not I didn't know the card
enough. Obviously,
>> it's certainly a card like danger zone.
You could have a pretty good rumble
card. What happened to poor FRA? Oh, it
got pushed back I think. Rebuke, I'm
guessing. No, I don't see a rebuke.
>> Oh, here comes Fizz. I looked away for
one second. Where' the fire going to go?
>> Oh, Fizz. Fizz getting rebuke recycle.
That's almost assurely what happened.
Now, death rocket's going to shoot this
thing. And again, shield is pretty good
from the legend out of Rumble. You do
not get shield when damage spells are
being thrown at your face. Only when
you're fighting on a battlefield.
>> Yeah, that's like one thing that's so
great about these removal spells or
these like damage spells.
Shield doesn't come in either. Like
effects for like defending don't come
into play. And so, we are able to go in
and kill some of these units. We still
do have eight 10 I guess if you're
including shield here in bile mod
though.
>> Oh that is really sick.
>> Oh that's that's so cool. Okay so uh the
rocket trigger happened on conquer
discarded a card which triggered the
other rocket and then discarded the
rocket that they picked up before after
the conquer just to pick up the other
rocket. And you might think why on earth
could you do that? That's so useless.
It's cuz Jinx gets bigger every single
time you discard.
>> You just got a free might by cycling
through your rockets. Yeah, that's so
nice. Eight now.
>> Yeah, she's huge. I mean, again, we only
need to get through this battlefield and
there is only six might left. Seven if
you count the one shield that Rumble
gives you, but only need one more
conquer. Seven points. The eighth could
be coming through here. There is so much
might moving onto this battlefield.
That's six. That's the gate from the
boots. And that's going to be the game
here. We are going to play a game number
three almost assuredly.
>> Yeah, it looks like game three is going
to be coming down here. I don't think
two runes is enough to stop it and it
doesn't look like Silverfuse does
either. It's time for game three and it
looks like it's going to be that Grover
the God Willow versus Obelisk. Uh we've
seen a lot of holding this game. So
Grove of the God Willow will do great in
that type of position helping draw more
cards. And interestingly enough, Obelisk
is a really cool one as well where your
first turn you may channel an extra
rune. Hopefully we'll see both players
do that.
>> Yes, please both players do not forget
the world's been updated slightly. You
do have a little more time than normal
to remember. obviously does give your
opponent a bit of an advantage. But
generally when I've seen oblisk uh just
getting an extra rune I think either on
the play can be good but makes sense
here that Jinx wants to go a little bit
bigger kind of have a more explosive
first turn when they are starting quote
unquote behind right cuz they don't have
the first opportunity to play a unit I
assume silver chose to go first here in
this final game but yeah we have seen
quite a lot of like let's call it uh
like meat and potatoes riftbound right
just a lot of holding a lot of
conquering a lot of might numbers being
added up and at the end of the day you
know the miracle shells can do a lot of
like very uh very powerful things but
they are still trying to play riftbound
at the end of the day. They're just
putting a lot of bite in. The way they
do it might feel a bit unfair, but they
are ultimately just trying to get big
numbers onto battlefields.
>> Yeah, it's very true. I'm interested to
see as well though what Silverviews has
to do with this mulligan. I think I see
Bellow's breath here. And it is, you
know, a removal spell we can see early
in the game. It did look like there was
a chance that she was going to mulligan
it away. And if I remember correctly,
she doesn't have too high of a count of
Bellow's breath. Um, so be very
interesting what she decides to do here.
I do also see that Plundering Pora,
which is our two drop. Uh, and then on
Jinx's side, do we have do we have a two
drop? I maybe I see traveling merchant.
>> Um, I'm using my keen eyes as best I
can. I see an edge of knight. I see a
>> scrap scrap. That's two. I see a seal.
And I think last is the final card
though in Jinx's hand. So is going to be
resolving some mulligans here for both
players. I imagine Por is getting kept
especially on the play. Seems quite
good. And you know, we can we can be a
little red here. We've seen two games
now between these two decks. It does
seem like getting on board early looks
pretty important.
>> Not not game by any means. Both decks
certainly have ways to come back in the
midame, but getting on base seems pretty
good here.
>> Yeah, it does seem like whoever does
that ends up pulling ahead and neither
decks have been really able to come back
from that. Maybe we'll see it a little
bit different here. And we do have more
runes, as we mentioned earlier, for this
first turn. Uh Project, I'm assuming, is
going to be going second. So he'll have
four runes and silverfuse will be going
first but he'll actually have three
runes instead set of two. So multiple
options
>> looks like just resolving mulligans
here. I think keeping poro no dupa is
going to the bottom. So I assume poro
and I think bellow's breath is the other
card that's getting capped. We're going
to find out very soon though as game's
going to kick off. Silverfuse is in fact
going first. Obelisk is going to
trigger. Good work remembering your
trigger in round one of the RQ.
>> Don't want to forget that one. Draw your
card and put something on the board.
Plundering power did get capped. I see a
falling star in hand as well. And
Pondering Power going to kick things
off, pass it on back to Jinx.
>> Yeah, and with one rune up, there's I
mean, they're not going to battlefield
yet, but we'll have to see if there's
anything that uh Project has to worry
about. I don't think so.
>> See mind spplitter in Project's hand.
Just peeled that one off the top. I
don't believe that was in the main deck
when we checked before. So, that one
coming in for kind of the the later
stage of the game wants maybe just
bigger units, bit of disruption, and
just plays the edge of knight. Natty,
>> interesting choice. I mean, it's a it's
a we got to spend our our runes that we
get to spend later, so it's nice.
>> I think in general, when your opponent
makes this play on turn one, you are
extremely happy as an player cuz your
opponent's playing Obelisk, they are
trying to maximize their first turn as
much as they can. They want to use all
of their energy and uh seeing just edge
of knight, nothing that's really
committed to the board as far as a unit
that can maybe challenge you at this
battlefield. Especially when it's Grove
of the God Willow, you're going to get
your gold on Conquer. you're going to
potentially get your hold as well and
get an extra bit of card draw. So
reading Jinx knowing that that is a unit
that can absolutely be played next turn
after two more runes I've channeled.
Does need a discard to ready it. But
that Jinx would be quite good at
challenging the lonely parro that only
has two might.
>> Yeah, it very potentially could. I
wouldn't be surprised if we were just
checking to make sure or see if there
was an accelerator on something. You
don't see Jinx too often. Uh so just
making sure that plundering Porro here
is safe in the girl with God Willow
because we would love to get that extra
draw. We'd love to get that head start
in points and uh we know that that is a
threat like you mentioned
>> just playing the rumble on curve again
just so nice for these rumble decks to
just have a two a turn two play that
you're always happy to put out. Uh Jinx
would have could of course if she was
able to get ready to get bigger could
potentially have challenged at the
battlefield. There's only one mech or
only one instance of shield. So the math
gets a little funny but I think
silverfuse taking the more conservative
line just playing out the unit and
saying you know what if the power
already got a point I already made a
gold if I hold and draw a card.
Excellent. I've done 99% of the things
this plundering pro could ever do. It is
overachieving. If you don't, if you do,
that's fine. I just lost a unit. I
already have my point.
>> Yeah, he he may be a plundering pro, but
he's an overachieving poro.
>> Certainly isn't this day. This is uh one
of the hardest working pros I've seen on
the broadcast so far. We'll see many
more this weekend, I'm sure.
>> Yeah, very very hard working. I say he's
MVP so far of uh the blue sides. But
>> let's see here. A second gear coming
down. Second potential equipment. I
think Silverfuse is happy to see it like
this thus far. Already at two points
even more overachieving on that poor.
>> I would not be able to contain myself.
If this was the turn the way I started
in game three, my first round of the RQ,
I would be out of my chair jumping up
and down. This could not have started
better for the Rumble. It is nothing
committed to board. Some gear that
certainly can be used later. We know
that there's ways to, you know, ready
units to kind of get not pseudo
accelerate. I guess it is pseudo
accelerate cuz it's fake accelerate, but
it does share some of the DNA from the
champion zone with the Jinx. We know
these miracle decks, they're good at
coming back. A lot of times you just
give six points and then you do so much
stuff in the mid to late game that
overwhelms your opponent that you're
happy. Know what Rumble wants to do.
Rumble certainly wants to start early
and then have a really powerful mid game
with a lot of those big sixes
especially. But uh this I mean the the
Porro is just gold starro at this point.
>> Oh yeah, gold star. He's uh number one
in his class. Yeah.
>> And uh we're going to be taking that
other side as well. Obelisk not as high
of a priority as the Grove of the God
Willow, but
>> it does give points.
>> It does give points and we've already
drawn off Grove with God Willow. We
don't even care about anymore, honestly.
>> Even a blank Battlefield gives points,
which has to feel good. Rumble Scrapper
going to come down here looking for the
hole. Does not choose to reinforce here.
Again, being a bit conservative, wanting
to let Jinx commit to Battlefield first
before deciding to kind of go back in.
But this is going to make uh Obelisk
especially a much harder prospect to
hold on to.
Yeah, harder to hold on to, but it's
nice to develop our base. We need to get
might in our base. So, if project is
able to clear the two battlefields, we
still have a plan for our following
turn. And we have a it looks like a
couple runes up as well. I'm not sure if
it's one or two or more. Uh but there's
hopefully things that we can do here. It
looks like we are going to be spending a
lot of runes though here on project
side. And what is going to be coming
down? I love the the rune he has by the
way.
>> Oh, it's beautiful looking. Going to
recycle one more and the seal. It's mind
splitter.
>> We did spine mindsitter earlier. Shows
the hand. A Kaiser, Bellow's Breath,
Falling Star. I love to look at all the
pretty cards. Piercing Light,
Singularity, Long Sword. This hand was
really good.
>> That is really, really good hand here. I
would it would be a difficult choice for
me. What do I think here would be the
most important to take out? Singularity
is, you know, able to take out larger
might units
and multiples of them, but maybe it's
not the immediate threat. Kai'Sa is more
might on board. Long sword potentially,
you know, that semi-permanent might. I
don't know what I would choose.
>> I think the good news for project is
that no single spell can take out this
mindslitter.
>> That's true.
>> That would be bad time. So, singularity
going to be the choice. I think probably
the best choice given the texture of the
mid game. lot of like fiveish might
units, right? A lot of lot of units in
range of singularity, let's say, in this
uh in this Jinx deck. So, wanting to
just take out the spell that is most
efficient in terms of taking out the
most amount of might. Still on the back
foot here again, Mind Splitter, very
powerful card, very good seven drop
here. And that seven might is going to
be pretty good when we walt over to the
battlefield, especially if we have some
equipment. But, uh not this turn
unfortunately for product. going to be
five points behind in the current state
if this holds.
>> And now I'm really going to wish I had
Rumble Scrapper on a battlefield
>> for sure. I'd love to get that plus
three might mech for I'd love it for
sure. But uh it is the safer play and it
looks like we are deciding
>> that we're going to attach our gears
here.
>> What is that an 11 m mind split or is it
>> 7 plus 44? Yeah, it should be 11. Has
ganking and uh it doesn't have the edge
of knight text. the the rest of edge of
knight is just hidden text as you can
see fuse is saying playing hey just
especially for the feature match can you
stack them nicely so we can read all the
numbers and it is 7 plus two plus two so
as you pointed out 11 might
>> that is so much and it's going to be
hard to deal with as silverfuse
especially preemptively before it could
even take one of these battlefields
>> not going to matter this tournament
grove of the godwill is still going has
made a gold drawn two cards and scored
three points this game
>> yeah I think he made it to college and
may have gotten a PhD while holding on
this Grove the god Willow he cannot not
stop over
>> PhD in piracy. This blundering working
so hard out here in this final game of
round one of the original qualifier here
in Las Vegas. Five points to zero.
Looking like a dire situation, but do
not count these purple decks out. Chaos
is quite a good domain and Jinx
certainly has the tools to get it done.
I think especially from the champ zone,
we see saw a lot of cool discard
readying action in last game actually
for project to close out game number
two. I think the thing to note though is
that this play of making the mind
splitter really big by attaching all the
gears very committal as far as resources
go. Only going to have six runes at the
next turn. Whereas you look across the
board and there's an embarrassment of
riches on the other side. As are we
playing two spells here to take out the
splitter?
>> I wouldn't be surprised. We have six
come down first. All right, five left.
>> So we need Yeah, five more minimum here.
But I think we have it in hand, right?
Like we saw so many different spells.
doesn't got a second falling star as
well. And mind spplitter,
>> we spent four power on him last turn and
>> he's in the trash.
>> Seven energy, four power. Yes, one of
those was a seal, but didn't see the
second falling star when the mind
splitter happened. That one came off the
top thanks to the overworking Porro
drawing an extra card on the turn from
Grover the God Willow. And that is I
mean it was always going to be a twocard
play to take out this mine splitter
which is not the most efficient but at
this stage of the game you are just
happy to get the work done and falling
star falling star about the best you
could ask for as far as two cards to
answer one.
>> Yeah looks like silver fuse is very
happy with the what the plundering
decided to do throughout this game. It's
you can rest in base camp. I'm going to
swap you out with uh my blue rumble who
will make more babies for base as well.
But we are sitting pretty here on on
both battlefields. It is going to be two
more turns though before we even win.
Even if we hold another turn, we are
only going to seven points, which does
mean Project still has time to come
back, but it's going to be a difficult
game.
>> Yeah, we can do a bit of math here as we
kind of look at the battlefields that
Silver is presenting as far as might
goes. Reminder, shield on Rumble Legend,
so you get plus one when you're
defending, which as you can see, both
mechs currently are, and then plus one
thanks to Rumble Scrapper. So it's full
base smite for the uh rumble on the
bottom of your screen. So make it five
plus one for shield is basically six and
it's four in the same math on the other
side. Plus one plus one for shield. So
two sixes here is fight or flight's
going to kick rumble scrapper out of his
home. The grove of the godwiller which
would have been such a delicious bit of
value if able to hold. Unfortunately
going to be a scared back to base by
Jinx. Yeah, we didn't have to worry
about it as much last game because of
that viol. But we are very happy I feel
like define fight or flight if only to
be able to push them off say ple like
not to hold and not to get an extra card
draw, not to get the extra mech as well.
It would have just been disastrous for
that hold.
>> Yeah, unfortunately for the points not
going to make the biggest difference
just because uh you're going to be
effectively in the same spot. The double
hold would have gone from five to seven.
the double conquer that you're basically
inviting your opponent to do because
with one rune, what is what is Jinx to
do in this spot. So going to be
basically in the same spot as far as the
game's points go, Civil Fuse should go
to seven on her turn. Not a lot left in
the tank for Project and just this lone
Fizz. Again, that mind splitter was
really the play that was committed to
this board. No other units clearly in
hand in the early game cuz of all this
gear that was getting played. Making one
big unit feels pretty good, but plenty
of removal spells over in Rumble to try
and uh cut that down. So we are going to
go again. Fizz is going to be the unit
that is towered up to a seven might unit
>> in this kind of board with these mechs
and these rumble passives seven is not a
very big number.
>> I will say it it is you know trying to
stop some of those those like damage
spells because without those two
piercing light could have wiped the fizz
off the board. We could have potentially
maybe like moved up ponying porro gotten
a gold then piercing lighted the punning
puro and fizz. Where do you come back
when you continue to not have units on
board? And so it's good to keep it safe,
but it's costing us a lot.
>> I mean, look, you're absolutely correct.
This is the play you have to make. Oh,
yeah. It's not the play you want to make
when you're playing this deck. Rumble
hotaded going to go ahead back to the
obelisk and get point number six. And I
think the question is how much might do
we want to stack here? Plundering Porro
again, a second gold made in this game.
This is the same Plundering Porro that
was played on turn one, I will remind
you. And so I have to imagine that the
we're going to stack as much might as we
can on the top battlefield cuz we're at
seven. We just need to hold here.
>> Yeah, I think it's interesting. I think
Porro has gotten like four points this
game, but he's only gotten us two gold
because we have just been holding,
holding, and holding. Uh looks like we
are going to be playing that Ferris
4Runner, which does threaten two extra
mechs in base if you decide to kill it.
Um and it leaves up a rune as well,
which we're going to have to watch out
for.
doesn't want to commit scrapper to a
battlefield. Interestingly, decides not
to maybe overfill one of the
battlefields there. Wants to hold it
back.
>> Mhm.
>> I mean, most of your units end up back
in base when you're playing against
purple cuz of all the uh the I guess
base bounce style effects, things like
fight or flight.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh with Fizz, of course, can do a rebu.
Here's Ezreal. We're going to try and
find a few more cards. Ross is straight
to the trash. That card doesn't do
anything right now for you.
>> Yeah, we do not have a lot in our
discard pile, but seal Ezreal feels so
nice. a little bit later in game than we
would have preferred. Uh but it is, you
know, still Ezreal regardless. We still
have two runes up as well. Fizz is a
seven. So potentially able to take out
at least the obelisk of power one, but
we have to clear both sides if we don't
want Silverfuse to win this.
>> Is Rebuke only from Battlefields? I
believe it is.
>> Uh I believe it's only from
Battlefields.
>> It is. That is the reason Scrap is in
base.
>> Yeah, it makes sense. Love that play
from Silver wanting again. So you said
seven and it immediately triggered in my
brain. Oh, I have to do rumble math
again. How big is Ferris 4unner just on
its own as a mech? It's the only mech at
this grove. What's six plus the shield
is seven plus the scrapper is one.
That's eight. That is much bigger. Well,
a little bit bigger than the Fizz is
right now. And that's what I was
thinking. I was like, why wouldn't you
put Scrapper on the battlefield? Gives
you five M. Well, you actually just want
the passive. And of course, if you know,
you can maybe get a double conquer if
there's not enough to to really do some
damage on both these battlefields, which
I will remind you, Jinx needs to conquer
or at least push the units off both of
these or the game is over and you are
losing round one of your RQ.
>> Yeah, it's it's that holding to eight
points again. That's Project's threat
here. There's that OP, but there's so
many things that Project can do. There
is only two runes up though, which does
decrease how many we can do, but there's
a lot of options still within two runes.
We have that rebuke you mentioned. We
have fighter fighter flights, but it
looks as we game and Rumble an awesome
round one match. I love that.
>> Exactly the sentence I expected to say
at the start here of the arcum in Vegas.
Rumble is going to win our round one
here in Vegas. That's a totally normal
sentence.
>> Yeah, I completely expected. It feels
like we're going to see it for the rest
of the tournament, but I doubt uh that
is the case actually. Rumble so
interesting to see. So happy to see it
in Jinx versus Rumble. Such a cool
match. Yeah, I think you saw projects at
the end there again. Not the greatest
start with all the gear early, not a lot
of units to try and contest the early
battlefields that Rumble wanted to.
Stack deck, cold shot, uh, Ezreal was
all happening there to try and get
through the deck and find some answers.
But after that mine splitter play,
committing so much of your resources,
losing a bunch of them to recycling, and
then just getting that unit killed by
two falling stars, and there's nothing
else you really have left. You're just
digging for answers, and even if you
find them, you don't necessarily have
the energy or the resources to even
deploy them. So, very nicely navigated
game there for Silver Fuse. Yeah,
fantastic by Silverfuse. It was really
painful for Project. We had to play two
gears in a row and obviously we tried to
protect our units with it later, but
just so much removal from the Rumble
side. It's about a loss at the
>> Really great game one. Can't wait to
hear what the winner has to say cuz we
have an interview with Silverfuse coming
right up.
>> That's going to be so much fun.
>> All right, so I'm here with Silverfuse.
Took down my girl Jinx playing Rumble.
Why Rumble? Um, big thing was I played
Kai'Sa last set and I didn't have a ton
of time to prepare. So, I also was
looking to get a best of. So, those
things came together. I knew the colors
and had a general idea of how the deck
would play. So, I went from there.
>> Cool. That was my next question. So, it
was a big question in these tournaments
of are you playing during the whole
tournament? Are you going for one of
those awesome best of? So, Rumble should
be a pretty good best to go for.
>> Yeah. Um, I saw that he was pretty low
overall and uh I just like the mech
tribal overall. So, I wanted to play
that for that reason. And the best of is
just like a little bonus on top of that
potential.
>> Awesome. And then overall vibes for the
event. How are you enjoying it so far?
>> Oh, it's been incredible. I've met so
many people that I've been looking
forward to see that I've been testing
with, talking with, people that I
haven't seen ever, even though I've
known them for five plus years. So, back
from the Legend of Terror community.
Shout out to them. So, yep.
>> Awesome. Great stuff. Well, good luck
today. May you rumble many folks.
>> I love to hear it. Shout out to the
Legend of Terror community. Silver Fus
again, someone I've literally worked
with on Legend of Mater events back in
the day. Great to see her winning her
first round here.
>> Yeah, it was so awesome and it's so cool
to see so many different communities
represented within Riftbound. Uh, you
know, Legends Rune Terra, one of them,
and so cool to see Rumble again.
>> So, uh, did you have fun commentating
that game? Do you like seeing games of
Riftbound on stream?
>> Do I like Riftbound? That's a great
question. I might like Riftbound. I
might.
>> Would you like some more? Is what I'm
asking.
>> I would love We have some coming up
right now. Now, we have our backup match
here from round one. Still in our first
round here. Let's have a look at our
deck list and see what matchup we have.
It's going to be kicking it off with the
deck we're going to be talking about
quite a lot throughout the course of the
tournament. It is Draven, Glorious
Executioner.
>> Yeah, he is such a dominating force in
this set, I think. But I will say runes
much more normal here with a split
between both colors. There's going to be
so many things to watch out for, but uh
it's
Draven. I think the number one thing
though is going to be his leader
ability. For those who don't know, when
he wins a combat, you do get to draw a
card. And that can be a lot of different
things, including when that fight or
flight happens. Uh we mentioned it and
we saw it a lot in our last game, but if
you're able to fight or flight someone
back during a showdown, it will count as
a win in combat and a card draw.
>> A spicy piece of tech I see in this main
deck. By the way, there are three copies
of detonate in this deck. Kill a gear,
its controller draws two cards. I have a
feeling it's going to get pointed at
scrap heap quite a lot.
>> Yeah, I think it may as well. And it's
just another way to I mean draw more
cards. We do love card draw. I would say
that
>> especially in the shells. We are going
to have a look at the other side of this
matchup. This is deck number one. It's
Draven versus Aurelia. This is a match
up we're going to see probably quite a
lot this event.
>> I love Ireelia. These two decks play
very differently though. I would like to
say that Aurelia is like a protect the
madam president. Um, this deck largely
built around protecting Ireelia and
you're going to see trying to make those
zonas, those guardian angels getting to
the turn so we can just protect Ireelia
and she can dance around the battle.
>> I believe I heard Amy from the Bolognia
broadcast say protect the princess and
that is what I'm going for. I think
that's great. Only eight units. Very
standard looking Aurelia list here.
There was of course a Aelia finishing in
the top four in Bolognia. I've looked at
that deck list many many times when I've
been playing Aelli and this is looking
uh very standard. So super excited super
excited for this matchup.
>> Yeah, it's gonna be so interesting to
see. I am excited to see how it ends up.
I love Ireelia. Draven's an interesting
deck and I'm but I'm sure we'll see it
later as well.
>> I think this Draven build especially is
really unique. Again, detonate main is
not a card I expected to see. Treasure
Trove, that's a card that usually goes
in Shovel Civer. These are cards that
want you to turn through your deck at
kind of maximum velocity. Really
committing to the I'm trying to get
through as much of my cards as possible
and then set up with all these recycle
effects. So there's definitely lots of
speeds you can build these different
miracle shells. Draven is obviously the
most popular version of building this
kind of deck, but some decks will
certainly have more units. This one is
like nah, I just need to get through my
cards as quickly as possible.
>> Yeah, I mean a lot of these decks are
built around drawing and drawing, but I
Yeah, as you mentioned, we haven't seen
Treasure Trove as much in the Draven
itself. We're seeing it in like maybe
other purple list but not Draven. So
it'll be cool to see how they decide to
play it.
>> All right. Well, I'm very excited for
that. But unfortunately, I have to issue
a slight apology to you all. That is
going to be our round two. If you saw
that, you did get spoiled. Just forget
you ever saw anything. We're going to
have a look at our round one deck cuz
that's where we still are. We saw round
one, Rumble versus Jinx, and we have a
backup match to show you as well. We are
going to have some deck list on your
screen in just a moment. So, be patient
as we do bring you up those matchups.
So, then I'll ask you the question. I'm
excited to see that when it happens.
What are you excited to see now? Cuz we
don't know what's coming up.
>> Hm. What do would I be excited to see? I
think I have like a couple decks I would
love to see. I'm a I'm a big Azir fan of
see Azir. Uh I think maybe like one that
we sometimes saw during set one like
Volibear would be cool. I played against
it in some of like the grassroot
tournaments I played in. Um I lost sadly
>> to Vol.
>> Yeah, I don't think a lot of people say
they lose to Voli Bear, but it and Leona
I have like a negative win rate against.
>> I've lost to Voli Bear uh in the trial
decks. I played a lot of uh a lot of
those decks, taught a lot of people uh
how to play Riftband, which is really
fun. I was actually going to point out
that one of the things I consistently
made a mistake of is you mentioned it in
actually in our first game where you
know you can tap your rune and then
recycle it to a seal.
>> Getting that in my brain took weeks,
like an embarrassing amount of time for
me to be like, "Oh, that is so not how I
thought that would work." But in
Riftbound, they are two different
things. Recycling uh and exhausting your
thing are two separate things. So, you
can do both.
>> Yeah, I I'll agree as well. It was one I
had a lot of trouble with in this game.
You can float your runes, which means
that you generate energy by exhausting
it or turning it sideways. And then you
can also recycle it and generate a power
by putting it at the bottom of your
deck. And I remember whenever I feel
like all of us when we first started
playing the game, we were like really
heavy on seals and we all wanted to do
it and then we were like, "No, seals are
terrible." And then obviously we're back
here and with so many seals.
>> Seals might be pretty good. So we do
have necklace for round one. We have our
backup match, our B match if you will.
Hey, you got it wrong.
>> Poly bear. Oh no.
>> How did you get it wrong? It's Poly
Bear.
>> I am excited about this one though.
There's a couple things that we can
watch for. Um it is an Aurora list. Uh
but I think this deck has a little bit
of a different curve where we are going
to be looking for some of those units
prior to the Aurora because then Chag uh
CAD we were told earlier.
>> Yeah,
>> it's like Kadrean. That's what I'm
running with. Yeah, Kadrian is able to
draw off these mighty units. So, we'll
have to see how it plays out, but very
excited about Voli there.
>> Yeah, Volley definitely has the
advantage of being able to cast quite a
few of the targets you have for Aurora.
So, unlike maybe the MF Aurora decks or
the Civ Aurora decks that I just want to
play, you know, a low number of units
like five while we have three, six, 9.
We have 12 actually 15 with Minotaur
Rear and then so the hits won't be quite
as uh high rolly, let's say. But you
will consistently put good threats onto
the table.
>> Yeah, very good threats. big mighty
guys. That is for sure. And I they
definitely play a bit differently,
especially coming into the set two with
uh last rights, the purple Aurora list.
>> Yep. Triple Storm Spring, a triple sky
spitter. Lots of love here in this deck.
Very fun one here, but we are going to
come back to us for just a moment and we
keep up our second deck list. Volibear.
Not a deck I expected to see. I'm not
surprised it's an Aurora variant. That I
will say, but I didn't think we'd see
much Volibear at all.
>> Volibear is so interesting though. But
it is going to be, looks like the one we
accidentally were mentioning is going to
be those last rights. Dazzling Aurora.
And in this deck, you're able to run so
much fewer units because of that last
rights going to recycle them back. But
as you mentioned, much lower counts.
Three minds spplitters. Voli Bear as
well. Two Voli Bear. Oh yes.
>> Um and so we're going to be able to high
roll into those mind spplitters.
>> Yeah. So it's fun. I'm glad that we teed
up the uh the miracle stuff with Jinx
and a bit with Draven. Uh again, no
spoilers. Uh cuz this deck is actually
weirdly trying to do somewhat of a
similar thing. Obviously, the way you
get there is very different, but the the
end result of having an Aurora in play
with only having five targets and having
two copies of Shovel, which is probably
better known by its real name, Last
Rights. Uh you can just consistently
replay put cards back into your deck and
replay them over and over again. The
best thing to replay is mindsplitter
because if you mind splitter your
opponent every single turn of the game,
not only is that seven might that you're
putting on the field, but your
opponent's hand just gets completely
ripped apart. And I don't know if you
know this, but trying to play a game of
Rift Mound with zero or one cards in
your hand is not very fun.
>> Unless you're Jinx.
>> Unless you're Jinxless.
>> Not in this match up.
>> Not in this matchup. That was the other
matchup. But yeah, it's so strong. We've
also seen like an addition of like gear
removal in set two. We're running a lot
lot more of it, I would say, especially.
But mindsplitter, you're trying to high
roll up into that mindspplitter on your
first Dazzling Aurora and be able to
mind spplitter out whatever would have
been able to destroy your dazzling
Aurora.
>> All right. Well, players are ready, so
let's get down to the feature match here
to cover an Aurora mirror of sorts. We
are going to join in progress. This is
game number two. Ashurn's climb was
selected for both. And now it's Sigil of
the Storm versus Obelisk. Here it's
Idris on one side with Volibear and
Steven on the right with MF. Aurora did
make top two in Bolognia. I will point
out this is a deck people certainly had
on their radar but probably not the
Volibear version.
>> Yeah, I don't think Voly Bear version
was it to Aspirin's climb in game one. I
don't think I've ever seen it. For those
who don't know, Aspirin's Climb, it
increases the amount of points that you
need to win the game by one. So, it
would actually make it 10 points for
game one. But we are going straight into
game two. These two battlefields, we've
seen Awaska Power does start you with an
extra rune, but Sigil of the Storm to
conquer it, you're going to have to
recycle specifically a rune, not a gold.
And uh
they're kind of counter counter
battlefields almost it seems like.
>> Yeah, it's it is they're kind of
opposites of each other. I mean, this is
kind of a classic in Volibear. It was
actually, funnily enough, one of the
battlefields in the trial deck.
Volibear, of course, whenever you play a
mighty unit, you get to put a channel a
rune exhausted from the top of your rune
deck. That is a very nice way to
mitigate the downside of sigil of the
storm where your opponent does not get
that luxury and as you pointed out it is
not pay a power it is recycle one of
your runes. So you are if you want to go
there you are going to be forced to pay
the price.
>> Yeah very important in uh set two where
we now have gold that can pay the power
but
>> all these seals running around as well.
You can't use those and it'll be
interesting to see what they decide to
mulligan. I did see uh that Steven had a
punch first in his hand. We are
mulligating after that but punch is plus
five.
>> Uh and it's definitely something that
they would want I feel like against
these huge mighty units of Volibear.
>> All right. See Aurora for the one Aurora
player. So that's a good start there for
Steven who did win game number one. I
may add again. We are joining in
progress here in game number two. So it
is three runes channel and a pass from
Steven into four runes channel here for
Erift into Confront. Cycling that there.
Not going to ready anything. Just wants
to draw another card again. Both players
are speed running to play the first
Aurora. Yeah, they have. Oh my gosh, we
have so many pretty nexus knight runes
on the misfortune side, but confront it
is basically to draw a card here. We do
have the dazzling Aurora on Steven's
side. He's at five. We were able to play
I mean we play catalyst of aons which is
really nice to ramp up here for two more
runes. Uh and we're just trying to get
to nine runes as fast as possible but
you would play that over.
>> You know what uh 7 plus two is? Hm.
Nine.
>> It is nine. And I see six runes
exhausted. Thanks to the catalas. I see
one there. I see two more channeled onto
the battlefield. And here I see an
Aurora down to the battlefield here for
Steven. Going to win the race to play
the big gear.
>> That is a rough getting it immediately
down. We'll have to see what he hits.
I'm not sure if Edrift has uh a Dow on
hand as well, but if he hits
Mindsplitter. Oh, but it's Volibear.
Where's your high roll now?
>> I mean, still pretty good. Yeah, I mean
both hits are good. That's the nice
thing about this version of the deck,
right? Only five units. So if they get
stranded in hand, it can be kind of a
feels bad for Aurora, but Aan
take away the Aurora. That's so sick.
>> So yeah. So Aan, such an interesting
card. You're able to take control of
your opponent's gear until the Aan dies.
So you thought Steven had an Aurora.
Jokes's on you. Ed has it now. And it
looks like we're going to get to use it.
What will we hit? We see another dazzing
Aurora. We're gonna hit Minotaur, which
is going to disable the a lot of the
movement cards that this purple
misfortune also has.
>> Actually, a card that seen a decent
amount of decks here. Uh, if they're in
the fury domain, units can't move to
base the exact texts on that five drop.
Not the biggest hit. Again, this Volibe
deck is kind of playing a more medium
set of units and playing way more of
them. But stealing your opponent's
Aurora. I thought it was Jova. It may
be, but for the other player,
>> Volbe going to go to the obelisk though
and get the first point. 12. Sorry, 10
might. It's a 12 drop, but 10 might. If
you go somewhere else, I draw a card.
>> And there's Oh, goodness. Fading
Memories.
>> And yeah, that's going to We're going to
We're going to have a reader on stream
for the first time.
>> Uh yeah, fading memories makes a gear be
uh
>> ephemeral. Temporary.
>> Temporary. There's the word. Yeah, at
least I'm 97% sure. Yeah, temporary.
Yeah, gear or unit. So, we're making the
dazzling Aurora. Basically, Steven's
having to kill his own Aurora here, but
it will finish off this turn before he
dies.
>> Yes, that happens at the beginning
phase, which obviously is at the start
of the turn. I think that things like uh
Sprite Mother that make a Sprite, that's
another unit that has temporary that we
saw a decent amount of in Origins. It's
given a unit at a battlefield or a gear
temporary. Notably, the gear doesn't
have to be at the battlefield because it
can't. There's there's no way, I don't
think, yet. Uh maybe an equipment.
Anyway, that's I'm not going to think
about the potential complexities of gear
being a battlefield. I'm just going to
say that uh correctly noted by us today
that that gear is now gone as sabotage
going to be floated on over.
>> Interestingly enough, it will take out
another I'm assuming I'm assuming here
it may take out another dazzling Aurora.
>> If it doesn't, I'm going to give you
$10.
>> Yeah, I think he's taking it out. I
don't There's 97% sure. And it is going
to go to the bottom of his deck.
>> Should have made the number bigger. It
would have been more dramatic.
>> Yeah, but we have our own Dazzing Aurora
now. We already spent the fading light
and so what is Steven going to have here
to take out this dowsing Aurora on Ed's
side.
>> I mean Vol still on the battlefield.
That's that is good. Again, if you go to
the other battlefield, Steven's going to
draw some cards. It feels pretty good
for any player really. But I'm always
going to be happy to
>> get to the next Aurora cuz we've already
seen two go by the wayside. One is on
the bottom of the deck, one is in the
trash
>> after getting clipped by Fading Memory.
So, actually, I'm going to go over to
the sigil. Going to go ahead and recycle
Aroon.
>> Mhm. No discount yet from the Voli Bear
Legend, but did trigger off the Menota
earlier and is going to trigger. In
fact,
>> probably going to trigger off the
Dazzling Aurora. Action is a hit that
does not trigger. Hey, there's another
Axan. That's that's a miss, quote
unquote.
>> Yeah, sad. Uh yeah, with Noi on the
other side. What is Axan really doing
here? Sadly, but um
>> swinging in.
>> Yeah, he's swinging. He's still four m.
He's still four mine.
>> Better than nothing.
>> Yeah,
>> doesn't get a doesn't get the rune
channel. Does get some more uh material
on board. Can't imagine there's more
than two Archons though, so at least the
next hit. Surely we're in Vegas, right?
Got to gamble a little. Surely the next
hit is going to be a big one. As Vol
continues to mount up points here for
Steven. It's two to one right now in
that regard. Is stack deck going to be
put on the chain?
>> Uh yeah, I think you know, you're right.
Dazzy Aurora is very good for Las Vegas
or should say fits the theme. It does
look like there is still nine runes up
though for Misfortune. So, we are
digging for that third uh third dazzing
Aurora in Steven's deck. To note, if we
can find the called shot, this really
interesting part of set two is that
because shot doesn't take an energy, but
takes a rune from what we were talking
about earlier with floating. You can
actually use both of the called shots
triggers,
float the two runes, have to recycle the
two, but you would still be able to
technically have the nine nine energy uh
that you would need to make a uh dazzing
Aurora.
>> Yep, definitely a way to find it there.
Uh like took a little double take there
cuz like how did Vol get over that? He
just don't have ganking. Misfortune of
course we don't talk about this much
when we talk about Aurora, but it does
come up every now and then. You can give
your units ganking and kind of go from
battlefield to battlefield. So now going
to go ahead on the sigil. Is going to
have to recycle one. But last right's
going to be the play here.
>> Yeah, it does look like we I mean I love
her ganking. I think it's one of the
reasons that she's such a strong leader
for dazzling Aurora. Um but yeah, Last
Rights coming down. We don't see the
recycle from it yet, but there is going
to be that called shot. Two more. And I
think I saw the Aurora. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Not going to be playable this turn
cuz last already ate some of the energy
we would have otherwise committed. given
that we there's already a volar in play
that's dealing just really being a
menace on this battlefield at 10 might.
I mean, there's going to be enough on
the other side maybe this turn, but uh
there's a punch first as you noted that
Steven is likely does have here and is
obviously holding up. Just slow playing
a little bit. Decided that you know
what, I only got one Aurora trigger
before bad things happen to me. That
might actually just be enough.
>> Mhm.
>> And it looks like we're actually be
playing a dead bloom to the base, which
is very unique. Well, not unique, very
rare, I feel like, for dead bloom. He
has a very interesting uh
>> uh ability where when he is played, you
can play him if there's another unit in
the battlefield like that your opponent
has to immediately start a showdown. But
we are going to be playing a base just
to get that extra might, start building
it up here um and hopefully be able to
deal with the volley bear in these
upcoming turns.
>> Yeah, got to crack through the volley.
So, uh it's two points a turn right now
thanks to MF just with one unit which is
pretty spectacular as far as rates go.
Already got one for holding as we noted.
MF that legend exhaust can give ganking
over to the big teddy bear who can walt
back on over to the obelisk of power.
And we know the Aurora is there for
Steven. Uh it's slightly better
osplitter than a Voli Bear for what it's
worth. So if you do feel like you want
to rip cards out of your opponent's
hand, uh you can get that going there
here as well. Of course, you you don't
know. It's simply uh whatever's on the
top of your deck. And I can't imagine we
don't want to redeploy Aurora here. I
think we are going to have some extra
runes ready. Five. Is that 10 11? My
brain is hurting as I try and look
through the beautiful borders of these
runes. But Aurora, you know what? I'll
just let Stephen show me how much how
much does this cost and how much you
have left at the end. The answer is
zero.
>> Looks like we're going to use Yeah. all
of our runes here to get down aurora.
But you don't need to have runes to play
a card here with dazzling. Looks like
we're getting a second ball here,
though.
>> Reinforce. Let's go.
>> Oh my gosh. What is that like 24?
>> Oh yeah, shield
>> cuz he's got plus two shield. like plus
it's 24 in that obelisk of power. We
currently have
what is it? Oh, it's Oh god, it's 26.
He's plus three. I was giving him plus
two with it. He's 26.
>> The 25 I believe 8 16 20 plus the five
from the man. I believe it's 25.
>> Yeah, so we're not enough.
>> That's somehow not enough, which I
didn't think was the sentence I would
say after playing all these dead blooms
and triggering Aurora for ourselves. But
uh it's rough out there sometimes. These
big teddy bears are really dominating
the battlefield. It may be that all you
need is two 12 uh two 10 might volley
bears that are a bit bigger on defense
to get the job done. And again, if you
want to try and get points on the other
side, you can, but you're going to just
let your opponent draw cards as Katarin
appearance.
>> And he draws for each mighty unit.
That's Minotaur.
>> It's it's not everyone but yeah. And
then the two dead blooms that and
himself, I'm 97% sure. So,
>> that's going to be four cards here that
Ed is going to get to draw.
>> It's going to be actually insane here
for Ed to get those and then we'll have
to see if he's a pull anything from
there. Looks like we're going to go to
end their turn though, triggering the
dazzling Aurora and another dead bloom,
which uh we'll we'll play to base.
>> So, now the interesting thing is going
to go to six from holding here for
Steven.
Does going to seven matter? Aurora is a
deck that holds quite often uh as far as
things go. Oh, I drew a mindslitter off
the top by the way, which is incredibly
good here cuz we already played our
final Aurora. So, we're going to mind
splitter into mindslitter here. Going to
give ganking to the bear. Not yet.
Making some decisions. Floating a rune.
Volibear goes over. Going to get point
number seven again. Holding feels like a
way you can uh keep stay in this game or
win this game at this point. So, it's
just a matter of what else do you want
to do? Do you want to commit the
splitter? Do you want to hold up all
your interaction? We have a bullet time.
We have two punch first. We have a fight
or flight. We have a lot of ways to kick
these big mighty units away. And if Edri
can't get in here, the game's just going
to end.
>> Yeah. My only question is I'm not sure
like the full text of Minotaur. I'm not
sure if he can push
>> your own our like our units back here,
but it may be that Minotaur is only from
your opponent's map.
>> Oh, it is everyone. You are correct.
Bring up Menotaur and just
>> refresh ourselves on the text one more
time.
>> Units can't move to base. You are
correct. You cannot go home.
>> Fighter flight therefore is not an
option here uh for Steen. Um, so just to
keep a note because Misfortune loves
fight all of Purple does and Minotaur
says no ma'am.
>> Yep. No, absolutely not. So, punch
first, I believe. Two copies of that, a
mindspplitter, a lost rights, a fight, a
hard bargain,
>> and a bullet time. Always a fun one,
especially in the end game when you got
to do some shooting.
>> Yeah, misfortune. A lot of times I feel
like during against Aurora, you like
have to try to hold into your last point
and bullet time is not good for that. If
you try to hold against her uh against
Misfortune, she's able to pay her runes
to increase the damage to each of the
units and it can completely wipe a
battle.
>> Yeah, using every part of our deck here
by the way. Seen the legend activate a
couple times now. The champs coming out.
There's Mindsplitter off the Aurora,
which we of course knew was going to
happen. Now going to take the best spell
in the hand. There are some decent
targets here. Skysplitter challenge. I
mean, probably one of the removal spells
if I had to guess cuz again to remind
you all, seven points to one when you
have two big units holding each
battlefield. only need to hold on to one
more point to get it done. That mines
splitter did reinforce on the sigil by
the way,
>> but Don doesn't have to recycle because
you haven't conquered. You've simply
been chilling there for most of the
game.
>> Yeah, that's going to be nice. And it is
going to bring up that side to 20 might
as well. And we know that Steven has
extra in his hand.
>> So, I don't know if there's enough to
punch through. Excuse the awful
unintentional pun.
>> Unintentional.
>> It was I I'll actually unintentional.
Well, I did work with Freak for quite a
while, but that one uh that one is
unintentional. So, we can use the math
once again. Right now, it is 10 plus uh
actually that one's easy. That's 20. 7 +
three for the shield and the 10
naturally on the Volibear. That's 20 on
one side versus 13 on defense on the
other. So, let's again go over what the
other side is. Is that nine? Why is that
unit so big?
>> He's he's gigantic. We did get that
challenge discarded by Mindsplitter,
which I feel like is going to hurt.
Challenge is a really nice uh I mean I
think it's also an action but it's a
spell where you're able to basically
send your might as an attack to the
other random other unit. Not random, but
you select it and then they send it back
as well. So we could have flooded like
one battlefield and then tried to
challenge to clear the other side. But
I'm not sure he has I don't think he had
a second in his hand to be able to do it
now.
>> Okay. So uh while you were talking I did
try and do the math. Mhm.
>> Uh I think it's 42
>> on the side.
>> I think so.
>> Is it Is it 8 each for a dead bloom or
six?
>> I think it's
>> eight production pull up dead predator.
>> I
>> 86 24 + 9 that's 32.
3 no 33.
>> Oh god.
>> Yeah. 33 + 4 is 37 + 5 42.
>> That's a lot of money.
>> If if Kate is a nine and dead is an
eight. I believe I have done the math
correctly. I believe there's 42 combined
might on Edra's side.
>> I do think Kadricken is nine. Either
way,
>> I'm looking at it
>> now. I'm like I like suddenly can't
remember. I
>> It looks like an eight from here.
>> It's a nine. Kadrian is an
>> Oh, I'm meaning the dead bloom. It looks
like an eight from here.
>> I think it's an eight.
>> So, if that is all true is 42. The
meaning to the answer to a lot of
questions.
>> Something very meaningful here. So, that
is enough to break one of these
battlefields. But you do need to kick
both all units off all battlefields.
>> Very true. Yeah. And so we'll have to
see what they're able to do here. I
mean, we you said could take one side.
We do have to be wary of those punch
first. And
>> I mean, Ed kind of has to not care
what's in hand in the case that
>> it it's the last turn. He can't really
wait any longer. So, he's going to have
to punch into it. Yeah.
>> And uh see what comes down. It looks
like we are bringing
>> Oh, snap.
>> Yeah, carnivorous snap vine. He's able
to deal his might as an attack to one of
the units in the battlefield. Doesn't
look like it's going to kill anything
here. Um, it will die itself, but it
will be extra damage that gets
calculated into the showdown.
>> Yeah, just have to mark six damage. Six
again. Going for the bear once more. So,
remember one of the Vol has deflect.
This one has shield. Shield, as we
pointed out, not good if you're not
actually getting attack. So, we're going
to clear that out with two snap points,
even channel extra rune thanks to the
Volibear Legend. And then we are going
to move in onto these two different
battlefields. And all of a sudden, it is
13 versus 13 and seven my onto, not 20
and 13. That's a big difference.
>> Huge difference. And it's going to be at
least nicer to go into. We still have to
worry about I mean, four, five runes on
Steven's side, but I mean, we may have
the might to do it now.
>> As you pointed out though, we can't play
around everything. Now, it has to decide
what do I think I can play around. There
is two. We know there are two punch
firsts in Steven's hand. So, you're
going to move in with uh I have to do it
again. 21 m 9. Yeah, 97 and then four is
21. So, uh good number in Vegas. Uh 21
versus 7 certainly going to seem big
enough. And uh 10 + 7 is only 17. 21 is
still a bigger number than that.
>> Yeah. So, it looks like we are going to
be
work here.
>> Oh, that doesn't work. Yep. Points to
the minotaur.
>> Oh, ouch. And that is going to be
fighterflight stopped by the minotaur.
Little rewindy.
>> Yeah, it I don't know if they but yeah,
so it does get stopped. Misfortune loves
it.
>> Yeah, sorry. You cannot fight flight a
unit back to base here as you pointed
out.
>> Yeah, you can't firefight him back
because of that ability of the Minotaur
really stopping some of the kit that
Misfortune relies so heavily on. And it
does look like Steven was depending on
here. Yeah, looks like we are going to
have I assume a little bit of discussion
here with some of the judges at the
table, but in general, it feels like
that's a spot where, you know, player
didn't realize usually typically fine to
rewind into spots like that. I'm
certainly not going to speculate. I'm
simply going to commentate the game as
it continues on. And looks like we have
rolled back to uh Steven's action on
show and showdown as well and we'll see
what Steven wants to do cuz as we
pointed out needs uh quite a lot to
overcome uh this seven versus now 21
rumbling in. And as we kept doing math,
it is only 13 with the shield on the
volair side. And there is uh more than
13 uh waiting in base.
>> Yeah. To note though, it is not 13 if we
see that challenge. I saw a challenge in
Misfortune's hand, but it's only a 10 in
challenges if we see that come across.
Uh it is only a 10 if we have more
damage come down, but it is 13 if we end
up going in with the 16 or the dead
bloom or 21 as you mentioned with the
minotaur.
>> A lot of 21s. I mean I guess 42 does
split quite evenly into 21. So uh two
pretty good takes here. Mind Splitter is
going to go bye-bye.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh Idris going to start crawling
back into this game again. Steven is at
seven points today.
>> Oh, and Mind Spree.
>> I think it's basically free.
>> It is just cost of power. Just the fury
power.
>> Yeah, just the fury power because it
discounts based on the highest might
that you have. So we have more than
eight might units on our board. And so
Sky Spitter only the power is going to
be able to kill that Voli Bear or at
least put five damage on the Voli Bear.
And so we are going to go in Moden pick
it out.
>> That was nice. I guess as you as you
pointed out a few times, shield only
works when you're getting attacked and
removal spells do ignore that fact. So
Katin coming down off the Aurora. Lots
of cards getting drawn here. All of a
sudden this game is turned completely
around for Ed Rift.
>> This is really nice. And then the
question is, can we come back? And Ed
has a lot more units in his in his uh in
his deck than Misfortune does. We just
got three sent to the discard pile.
Obviously, Last Rights does have some
options to bring them back into the
game, but Ed is going to have a lot of
might here trying to hold and there's a
potential that he could hold all the way
to the win.
>> Certainly could. And have to look at
bullet time real quick here cuz that of
course is the signature spell of
Misfortune. Uh that one is basically
deal damage to all enemies at a
battlefield. A battlefield. Only one
notably, not both, which is pretty
important in this spot. Not like
unchecked power. Deal one for each rune
you decide to recycle when you play
this. So, I think it's one base, and
then you can just basically say, how
many runes do you want to send to the
bottom? Now, if you're going to win when
you cast the spell, you can just chuck
them all to the bottom. That feels
pretty good. Uh, you're going to need a
pretty high number to clear these
battlefields without any other effects,
which I guess right now it has no runes
up, so probably nothing you have to
worry about. Quy not going to be a
thing. Wallop not going to be a thing
here.
>> So, uh, you can channel a decent number
here and clear one of these battlefields
if you channel nine runes, which is a
lot. been taking a stop by mind
splittering here and just taking the
card away as that's a pretty big hand.
Thanks for this double cadre.
>> Yeah, I uh I love the two rows of cards
here. Uh I I had a little bit of a laugh
at it, but there's a couple things here
like maybe we would want to look at.
There's that third Kadrian that could be
more draw. But with already what three,
four of our units of our five being
played. That thermmo bean might be, you
know, the card we have to discard here
because otherwise last rise could be
gone and then how do you get them back
into your deck to continue the game?
>> Yeah, we take out the Aurora as well,
but at this point feels like you kind of
got enough out of the Aurora. You know,
your opponent doesn't have that many
units. They're going to run out
relatively soon. You don't really want
them recycling them all. You obviously
have more hits you could go for, but I
actually kind of like thermob as an
option here. So, might be something that
Steven is priced into, but Stormbringer
volley signature spell mentor reckon are
going to be the one already shutting off
the fight or flight we saw Steven try to
cast earlier. So, apparently does not
want that effect anywhere near this
game. Unfortunately, that's a backup
copy in their hand.
>> There's a a backup copy in hand. There's
also a backup copy on the board already.
It's in the base, so fairly safe, you
could say. Um, and Ed was very careful
to make sure he did not move it into
either of these battlefields where it
could potentially be taken out by bullet
time, could be taken out by a unit
moving up into the battlefield and uh I
think it's a key here to continuing to
win for this for Ed.
>> I know I think I know there's this
splitter correct. I think Steven has
gone through now unit number five at
this point going to get splitted again.
So now can take the beam uh had the
option knew that this was going to
happen. So was able to strip two cards
away on this turn no matter what. Trying
to remember if I've seen three minds
spplitters or two. Obviously last rights
can get them back. Good call today
though. That thermobam is going to hit
the bin.
>> Yeah, there goes the thermmaab beam. Uh
try and protect last rights because I
think it's just something that's so
interesting about this Aurora list. Like
last set we saw nine sometimes more. I
mean Ed's list has a lot more units in
it. And one way that deck would lose was
you would run it out of units. And here,
Misfortune going down to five units has
even more of the risk. Really relying on
that last rights to bring them back in.
>> The other thing though is like, do you
even have enough stuff like there's just
more might total in Ed's deck? Just
playing more units and they're huge.
>> Yeah. I mean, I would say in Misfortune,
you only rely on the big might of Baldi
Bear, but what about when you're against
Volibear?
>> I don't know. Reckon they're going to
come down. Bunch of your tools are
getting turned off here thanks to these
two men that are just being chilling in
base. five points for holding uh from
three to five this turn. Sorry, from
holding. So going to presumably go to
seven and then all of a sudden we'll be
back in an interesting spot where a
player can win by holding at seven. But
now that's true for both players instead
of only one of them.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a difficult
spot. I think looks like Ed is playing
his
I think. Oh, okay. So that was from hand
from base. That one moved in.
>> Oh, from base. Okay, sorry. So we're
just holding even more into it.
>> What do we have left?
>> Oh nothing. We're fresh out.
>> Did we just Ouch.
>> something in hand perhaps?
>> Trying to count. I think it's 15 units
in the main deck, but we are in game
two, so some might have been sided out.
>> Yeah, he did have another manar in hand.
He had another cadre in hand. He had
>> Oh, you're right.
>> Uh,
>> that seems like most of them.
>> Yeah. So, it does seem like they're
they're mostly in his hand potentially.
I'm trying to think there's like any way
that he can recycle them back in his
deck as well if they're in the discard
pile. And I'm not sure. I don't think
so, but we'll have to keep our eyes
peeled perhaps for something like that.
>> Uh I think it is very telling that this
manur is important for Edri to hang
around. We know challenge can you snipe
a man in the back, but not both of them
if you only have one copy of that card.
So really value in keeping things like
fight or flight at bay and Aurora some
cards are just a little clunky, right?
Like your ramp is really good at getting
your Aurora out early, which is exactly
what your deck wants to do. Doesn't
really do anything once we've ch
basically all the Auroras in the game.
Yeah, I will definitely great point. Uh
once you've already gone through them,
what is this catalyst of aons doing?
What are like different things like
mobilize doing? It's great point that
like once you're there,
>> what are you going to do? I will say I
guess there's some world where like we
don't have 10 runes down if we ever want
to play the Voli Bear that's in our in
our spot. We do need more runes.
>> I completely forgot there was a Voli
Bear in that.
>> Yeah, I was actually thinking like are
there any other Volibears in his deck? I
don't think so. It's like the one time
you would want your chosen guy to
actually be played on the Aurora. But um
yeah, there is that option as well to
bring him in. I will say it does look
like Ed's deck is a little bit built for
playing from hand more cuz we see
confront which allows him to come in
ready. Uh and so he still could play
Kadrian ready with confront even.
>> I'm trying to think for Steven.
>> I think you have to try and make a push
to win this turn. And I don't think you
can win this game by double conquering,
which means you're now trying to win by
holding. And if you're trying to win by
holding, you have to break one of these
battlefields first. So we got to pump up
a mind spplitter here with punch first.
That's going to go from 7 to 12 power.
12 might.
>> Mhm. So 12 might on this one. It does.
So both battlefields. Okay. Top
battlefield
>> is
>> I did the math already.
>> Oh, you did? Oh god. 25. And then the
bottom one is one left.
>> 17 + 4. 21.
>> 21. Okay. You've already done it. Yeah.
Now, we're not we're not fully there
yet. I'm glad you did the math.
>> We did challenge uh Kadrian, though, so
>> Oh, someone's dead.
>> Out of there.
>> Get out.
>> Still 12 down there.
>> Gets punched by the big mine splitter.
Rumbling on in. Hello, my giant minds
splitter would like to take out your
units. You only have 8 plus 4. That's
12. Hey, I'm rolling with a Oh, that's
also a 12. So,
>> oh, wow.
>> Showing something here. Skysplitter.
>> Going to try and change the change it
change it here. There's a hard bargain
available. Steven does have a window to
to play this as a reaction if he wants
is going to go ahead and do so. Cut that
off. And I think the plan right now is
to hold this battlefield and then just
send it with your bullet time.
>> It looks like that could very
potentially be the way to win here. We
do have two units as well in base. So,
as long as they're able to make their
way in.
>> Shovel. Yeah.
>> Seven and eight points. Well,
>> okay. This is nice. This is really nice.
Okay. So, here's what's happening.
Shovel's getting equipped. We are
recycling two units. That is the cost of
equipping a shovel. Both volars are
going on the bottom of the deck. So, we
are going to hit a Volibear if I've done
my if I've counted units correctly. So,
that means a Volibear is going to join
this battlefield that has this mine
splitter on it. The skysplitter actually
took out the other mines splitter that
had already been marked for damage. So,
that mines splitter didn't make it. But
the backup mines spplitter is going to
make it. So, that basically traded off
cuz they just left both at 12. MF's
going to go over here. And I think the
plan is I mean both times are not going
to do that much damage out at this
point. It was much better when you had
eight runes you could potentially
channel away from it. Now you only have
four, but trying to hold up enough
spells here to just hold for this final
point cuz I don't think if if Ed double
holds, he's basically in the same spot.
So you have to get on base first and
then just try and hold on for this final
point as we're going to flip over quite
a few cards here. Again, there are two
vol on the bottom at light speed we go.
>> I will say the one negative thing about
Aurora is your opponent gets to see your
entire deck,
>> but uh Yep, there is that you
>> I think it's I think that's aura.
They're showing your opponent entire
deck. Yeah, I think it's just like look
at what I have. Aren't they great?
>> Very dazzling.
>> Can you beat this?
>> All right, so 10 7 17 + 4 21 once again
plus two might on the shovel. So 23
might currently hanging out over on the
battlefield. And uh Volibar does not
give uh one of her units ganking. That's
misfortune.
>> It does not. That is misfortune. And so
we only have 10 in base.
>> There's 25 stranded on that top
battlefield. That would be really nice
in base right now.
>> That that would be really nice in base
right now. We do have confront in hand.
So cards in that we play could come in
ready. Uh, do we have anything? I'm
trying to see if there's any like
>> anything to confront. There's Oh, that's
a Stormbringer. There is a sweeper in
the hand. That is going to do a lot of
damage. Choosing you in your base. I'm
going to choose this five might one.
Deal damage equal to its smite to all
enemy units out of battlefield. Then
move your unit here.
>> So that's going to take out one. Now
five is going to challenge the rest of
this. But there is still damage marked
on these units. Do not forget. So
Volbear is going to get the shield
trigger. That's going to be a little bit
bigger. Call it an eight at this point
with five damage marked on it. Mines is
a nine taking five damage. Called a
four. So, one thing is going to get
taken out here, but this is not enough
for Ed to kick off this battlefield.
>> Yeah. And the sad part here is is at the
right now they both have five damage on
them.
>> Whichever one survives will be healed.
And if both of them survive, they will
both be healed because in the end of a
showdown, all damage is healed.
>> It looks like showdown uh the punch
first has come down and edges and
conceds. That's a two for Misfortune.
>> Didn't need the ball at time, but punch
first was enough. Very nicely navigated
by both players. Steven correctly
identifying their turn where I have to
go here. I have to go. If I don't get a
unit on this battlefield, I am not going
to break the might you have presented.
Ed had so much might. We were counting
20s constantly on both these
battlefields. And yet Steven found the
line to hold with only one unit. You
only need one. Whether it's a plundering
poro or a mind spitter, you only need
one.
>> You only need one. And he was able to
get that win. Honestly, when there was
over 40 Mike in the battlefield and over
50 if you included Ed's base, I didn't
think he was going to be able to pull it
off, but he was. And Steven still
brought out the win. 2 and 0, I think.
>> I think for round one, I could not be
happy with the match we've gotten. And
you know what? We've got a bit of bonus
content cuz we have a winner with the
interview from this game.
>> All right, Stephen, that was a crazy end
of that game. Uh, I walked away when the
board was completely cluttered. Great
comeback. Yeah, it was pretty bad. He
got I think his one of his battlefields
had like 20 something might and the
other one also had like 9 22 might. I
think it was like 22 22 and he had 10
more in the base. That was
>> I wrote you off. Uh and maybe I
shouldn't have. Sorry. I walked away and
I'm like, "Wow, you won that one. Great
stuff." So, uh Emma Aurora, uh why did
you choose it for the event?
>> Um honest answer, I feel like there's a
lot of Draven representation and I do
fairly decent into it as long as I see
Aurora. I think the hard part is when I
ran to Miracle and they high roll. But
besides that, I also did not have a lot
of testing going into the event. So, I
felt like playing something that's
pretty simple like ramp up, put down
Aurora, put down your bodies, and just
try to play it out from there is was a
lot safer than trying to like play
something complicated really like
without much practice.
>> Sounds great. So, overall thoughts on
the metag game and the tournament? Got
any big predictions for the weekend?
>> Um, I feel like it's pretty I mean, I'm
only going based off yesterday. It
wasn't like too diverse, but I feel like
today we're seeing a lot more
representation. I definitely walked by
at least like four gars in the room,
which is like I'm praying for one.
>> God bless them.
>> Yeah, they they got that.
>> But besides that, I feel like it's it's
nice. The venue space is really good.
It's really big. A lot of judges on
staff, which I heard was going to be a
problem, but it feels like it's working
out pretty well today. And yeah.
>> All right. Awesome. Great stuff. Well,
good luck today. Great start to the
tournament. Good luck.
>> Thank you.
So decided to play Aurora cuz they
wanted to play something simple. Would
you describe that last game state as
simple as day?
>> I don't know if I would call that last
game state simple. I will say maybe
Aurora I can see what he's saying. But
when you're going up against 50 plus
might I don't think any I mean I don't
even think I could do the math. It
wasn't so simple.
>> I have to do my brain already hurts. And
this is round one. Uh I I do like that
uh you know wanting to play to Garen.
Again, bless the Garen players. I know I
know T's out there representing trying
to win the best of again which will be a
pretty amazing feat. Uh I do like you
know being honest with yourself. I just
I see them out there. I appreciate that
the Gar players are playing. I would
like to parent to you because I think my
matchup is good.
>> Oh no.
>> All right. Well, that was an awesome
round one. We do have a break, but don't
go too far away. Round two from Las
Vegas Regional Qualifier here for
Rebound is coming right up.
>> All right. I'm here with Randy fresh off
his top eight in Bolognia here in Las
Vegas looking to try and do it again. I
mean, even in Houston, there's a top 64
finish. So, you've been going
>> 32
>> 32 almost.
>> All right. So, back to back to back of
making the top cut is the goal here. How
are you feeling coming into Vegas?
>> Honestly, pretty confident. I made some
changes to the deck. Uh play tested a
bit more because I was very light on
play test for for Bolognia. Just
switched deck last minute and uh yeah,
feeling pretty good.
>> Okay. And I mean, let's let's get into
the deck a little bit. Why not? You
know, you swapped from Civer in China
getting that top four over to Draven,
able to make the top eight. Tell me a
little bit about your version of Draven
because it is a bit different. You were
playing some unique tech cards.
>> Yes. Uh so me and Talion, my my friend,
we built like a special Draven. So we I
switched from CIA because I figured
people were going to play very slow
because it's the start of the set.
They're getting to know the cards. They
don't really know. And Cir is a very
control/combo heavy deck. So she wins in
the late game. She needs game to go
long. And I I felt like it would be a
hindrance to my ability to top if I took
this deck for certain rounds. So I
decided to switch to Draven. And we
built a version like uh of Draven that's
in between the two current like popular
version. You have mid-range Draven which
plays a lot of tricks and heavy
creatures like Mind Speeder, Foreigner
and all that stuff. And you have Miracle
Draven which plays seals, cold shot, air
and tries to go fast with the RAM. And
we built something that's like in
between with interesting side deck and
we think that just like the best deck in
the game by a pretty large margin. So
two of us took it last week. I got to
top eight. Uh he went day two and
finished I don't know top 100. I don't
know not very great for him but still
pretty good. So yeah.
>> All right. I mean with that confidence
level coming in where do you see
yourself placing? Is this another top
eight for Randy?
>> Uh I'm aiming for the win obviously. So
uh top eight would be like good for like
stability, consistency. I mean it's
pretty hard honestly. Like over like
1500 players entering eight make it to
the to the final stage. Uh, top eight
would be great obviously, but I really
want that win. Top four in China, top
eight last week. We I I wanna I want to
get this one.
>> All right. Well, let's see if you can
continue on this legacy you're building
in Riftbound. Good luck in the
tournament, Randy. And hopefully we'll
see you on the stage.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
on
to
whenice.
So, we those were some awesome games of
Riftbound. If anyone is interested in
starting Riftbound, one great way to do
that is by going to your local card game
shop and finding the Nexus Knights. They
are so much fun to play in and a great
way to get started in Riftbound.
>> Absolutely. I think one of the most
rewarding things about any card game is
meeting the people in your local area,
playing games, getting better, and
honestly just making friends.
>> I agree. I think it's honestly the best
part about card games in general, just
how much fun the community is.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I think there's a lot
to love as far as like Riftbound.
There's really everything to offer,
right? We're here at almost the top
level of competition, right? These
players are trying to qualify for like
the pinnacle of rip organized play,
which hasn't even been announced yet as
far as when that's going to happen. And
already this many players are turning
up,
>> but there's things you can do. You can
do it next time. It's much more casual,
really chill. Get to know uh your local
scene. Maybe play a Volibear, you know.
>> Yeah, true. Voline,
>> but
>> okay, with that, we do have a fun bit of
content coming up that I'm pretty sure
we were both in. Do you remember words
you may have said yesterday
>> uh about Nexus Knights?
>> No. We're going to throw to some hot
takes. We'll see who had the most
scorching hot take as we throw to this
little video of a cast of interviewing
some people you may recognize.
>> Me,
>> I got to ask you, you got any hot takes
for the weekend?
>> Uh Garen's the best deck in the format.
There's nothing close. Uh all these
people are playing Draven and Ezreal.
They don't know what's up. It's Garren
or Bust.
>> Yeah. Uh, I think Aurelia will convert
more than Draven into top eight. I think
that's a hot take. I think the deck's
really good. I think like it maybe can
win this weekend, but obviously hasn't
had quite the best results, even though
I think it's very powerful, but I think
Aelia is going to do really well this
weekend. That's my hot take.
>> Uh, hot takes. Draven isn't actually the
best deck.
>> Ezreal, Resident Sleeper, uh, nobody
builds Aurelia, right?
>> Hot takes for the weekend. I actually
don't think I don't even know if it's a
hot take anymore. I don't think Draven
is winning this weekend. Respectfully.
respectfully. I do think Voli might make
an appearance in top eight.
>> Oo. Okay, that that one is that's
certifiably hot.
>> Uh I think my hot take for the weekend
is I want to see Annie in the finals.
>> Annie in the finals. Okay, that's a
pretty good one. That is that is a hot
take for sure. Yeah, I think one of
these players who came into the event
saying, you know what, I'm going to play
one of the less popular legends and get
a best of card. It's going to sneak into
top eight. They're going to have good
matchups. They're going to overduct
really well. They're going to play
really well. They're going to find
themselves with a little big surprise in
the weekend. Any hot sex? I think Civer
gets it this weekend. I think Allan uh
Allan loses the finals to uh to a Civer.
>> Ye uh destroys Ezreal.
>> Okay. Okay. Do you have any hot takes?
>> I do have a hot take. My hot take is
that there are not enough Yortals in the
game right now. I need a Bandal City set
immediately and I need to play Lulu all
the time. I need to stupify and I need
to polymorph a lot of people. That's my
hunting.
Some scorching takes I have to say
there. That was fun.
>> I think my favorite one was the Lulu. I
would be so down to see Lulu in the
game. Like chosen champion Lulu.
>> It all tastes like purple.
>> It does. Yes, allegedly.
>> That's I think that's what she says,
right? I haven't in a while.
>> That's what she says. Uh I do think
though I like the person that was just
like firing off hot takes. It was like
going to win. Draven sucks. Edgel's
resident sleeper. That's the kind of
energy I like people bring into the game
here as we are going to get ourselves
into round two in just a moment. We may
have spoiled the matchup for you all
just earlier, but we'll we'll throw up
the deck list in just a moment when we
have them ready just to, you know,
refresh your memory about what we're
going to get into here for round two.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see if those hot
takes are real. I think was it Draven
versus Ireelia? Supposedly Ielia is not
built correctly and Draven's not what
everyone thinks it is. So
>> maybe we'll see that in this next game.
Well, one of them has to win.
>> One of them does have to win. That's
true.
>> So, certainly that's going to be coming
up uh in just a moment. Again, a match
up I'm I'm really excited for. I think
this is a matchup that many players
coming into this event, especially
obviously if you're piloting either side
of this, you expect to play this quite a
lot. So, I do think players will be very
practiced on how to approach these
matchups.
>> Yeah, I think that's going to be great
to see. Like, we had some great gameplay
obviously between Jinx and Rumble and
the Volibear Misfortune, but I'm not
sure they had the reps into those decks
as much as we're going to see for this
Draven Ireelia. And we're going to get
some hopefully, you know, season
gameplay of knowing what to do each turn
and hopefully figuring out the way to
win.
>> All right, so we'll have a look at the
deck list for our round two matchup
coming up in just a moment. I may have
misremembered cuz it's Leona, baby.
>> Leona going to be on stream.
>> I do love Leona. I said this to you
earlier. I think I'm maybe one of the
few players with a negative win rate
into Leona. I've never beaten it. Uh and
I think with set two, it only gets
better. You have the wonk which is
absolutely insane or a pete. Uh that is
a stun. Stun is so much fun in this
game. It absolutely just cuts out the
might that the unit would be able to
deal and you still get to deal might it.
It can just basically send them back.
You also see like really cool Emperor
Divide. But I'm going to watch that
silicorn herder I think to see if it can
draw the cards it needs.
>> Yeah, these are honestly just domains at
least in this combination that we just
do not see. We see a lot of karmatelia
running around the place. see some Yaso
sometimes see some Ahri is a reasonably
represented deck often and we know kind
of what the toolbox of those cards do
things like Zas G not so fast all these
new tools added and uh you know we don't
see that much order Victor really is the
one that runs order and Leona isn't
running any cards that Victor wants to
run it's all Leona cards right three
Zenith Blade in the main deck there
really trying to leverage Leona's legend
ability
>> yeah it's gonna be really interesting to
see if they can do it in a way that
brings in the win I will say the one
leader that has a similar color scheme
unless my color blindness is like making
me completely forget Azir, green and
yellow. Uh, absolutely love him.
Obviously, there are some huge
differences. Zir's running a lot more
gears. This one's going for a lot more
stuns, but uh it is the same domains.
>> All right, we'll see what's on the other
side then, cuz everything I know is a
lie. And that's not anyone's fault but
my own. Who's on the other side? It is
>> no shot we're playing a mirror. We are
playing a Leona mirror in round two of
the original qualifier.
>> But they're completely different.
one was built more around that stun
package that comes with Leona herself.
And this one with baited hook, which
we've seen a little bit in Darius. We
saw a little bit in feaura feiora
uh in in uh China. I think there was
like a baited hook in the finals one in
one of the regional opens over there and
now in Leona. I'd love to see it do
well.
>> This is going to be such an exciting
matchup. I mean, baited hook definitely
a very unique card, very powerful card.
We'll talk more about that as we get
into the games themselves. But big
differences here, bigger, much bigger
units that the deck wants to play.
Really trying to take advantage of the
hook to effectively cheat on some cost.
Think about the thing Aurora does where
you play this big gear, but once you
play it, you get to basically put very,
very big units into play for free. Hook
need to do a little more work to get to
that point, but the end result is
roughly the same. You are trying to go
from a smaller to mid-range thing to a
significantly bigger thing.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see if they're able
to pull it off. Uh, I mean there's a lot
of really cool units in this deck that
could lead into it. I'm looking at that
harnessed dragon. That could be cool.
It's basically a kill spell. When you
play it, you get to kill a unit. We have
things like this green or we have yellow
Darius. Not the Darius you normally see.
And I I think Tasty Folk was my favorite
card of set one.
>> Well, there's one here as well
potentially for the baited hook to hit.
But let's stop the happening once again.
It is time to get down to our feature
match once more for round number two.
We're here in Las Vegas. Luna Nicole is
playing Leona at Radiant Dawn and Straw
Hat Skulls is playing what do you know?
Leona Radiant Dawn.
>> I don't think that it was,
>> you know, I might not have expected a
Rumble round one. I did not expect a
Leona versus Leona anywhere in the
tournament. Uh, two different
battlefields, but both very interesting
ones. Trifarian War Camp is one that
affects both people attacking and
defending. it is plus one might and so
that's going to be really interesting
and figuring out the trade-offs of might
and who's going to win win. Uh and then
also dreaming tree when you target a
friendly unit you get to draw an extra
card and I think Leona had a little bit
of difficulty with a lot of decks had
difficulty set one with maintaining card
resources. Maybe it's going to help a
bit.
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean uh the calm
package that Nicole is playing very much
kind of reminiscent of of things like
Ahri. So, uh, something like dreaming
tree, which both Aelia and Ari and now
Leona apparently do share as as a common
bit of DNA does make a lot of sense.
Really utilizing, you know, lots of the
stones, lots of the tricks, lots of the
buffs. On the other side, we're playing
a brutalizer on turn one. We are trying
to make some big might numbers cuz
again, the thing to remember with baited
hook, you need to care about what might
numbers you are going from and to and
equipping your units, especially with
something like brutalizer, which gives
three might plus one plus the plus two.
If you do it that turn, that lets you
hook from a very small unit into a very
big unit. And that's exactly the kind of
resource imbalance you're looking to
take advantage of.
>> Yeah, it's going to be so nice. And you
would think with baited hook like having
to I think it's kill your unit that has
the might would be bad. But we've talked
so much about how holding is strong um
because you don't expect your unit to
survive. So you kill the guy and then
you get your new one in base that's
still protected. So it does work out.
Stellicorn Herder is going to come down.
And this is one of those cards that's
just so nice for drawing. Whenever we
move, Cellorn Herder will draw one
similar to Traveling Merchant, but now
we get to draw, not just discard.
>> Yeah, cost cost twice as much, but is I
would argue more than twice as powerful
maybe, especially in the decks that
wants to move a lot. Obviously, Aurelia
loves this card, but in general, I feel
like Karm was wanting more options for
card draw, and this is one of the most
stellar ones and in the game. Lonely
Porro, though, going to go ahead and
poke around one of the battlefields
maybe.
>> Oo, I think Lonely Lonely Porro is is
adorable. I love Lonely Porro. And we
will have to watch that death nail. It
is a draw effect as well. When Lonely
Porro is killed, you're able to draw
one.
>> And don't make the mistake I made when I
play this. If I died alone, one of the
saddest pieces of text on a roofbound
card, but deathnail, if I die alone,
draw one.
>> It's a lonely poro. You're not allowed
to make it not alone.
>> Yeah. And Warcamp, by the way, I just
I'm I feel like the Kasanova, by the
way, big baited hook for your enjoyer.
So, uh, sorry that they're missing this
match, but I do remember the other thing
that War Camp does for you in Bed Hook
decks is you get might, which doesn't
sound all that good cuz it's works for
both players. So, you know, kind of in
the wash as far as doing the math on the
might goes, but when you move a unit
there, well, the unit at the battlefield
that has more might and Baited Hook
cares a lot about the might number on
the unit, not printed on the unit, the
might that it has at the time you've
sacrificed a unit. When Hook gets
played, don't worry, we'll bring it up.
That's going to be one we are absolutely
going to have to read. But Leona is
making her appearance from the chosen
champion zone into the base for Nicole.
Yeah, we get to see that chosen
champion. Uh Leona is a very I mean very
nice card. Also a very fun uh character
to play. Uh Leona determined she does
have shield which we saw a lot of with
Rumble with the Baldi Bear. So she gets
plus one when she defends, but also when
she attacks she gets to stun her enemy
unit there. The hope is is that Leona
will have more might than her opponent
and she'll be able to kill it without it
killing her. And of course that plays
into the Leona legend ability which if I
remember the text correctly off the top
of my head when you stun a unit buff a
unit.
>> Yes, I believe that is correct.
>> So even more might. So a lot of really
good numbers that Leon gets to pump out
here. A seal of unity going to be popped
onto the battlefield here. Again, Baited
Hook costs a lot of power to run. So
triple yellow seal here for Strawhead
Skull, which makes a lot of sense. And
it's going to be uh
>> Vanguard Captain. Vanguard captain is a
>> legion.
>> Yep.
>> I believe uh
>> if you legion make two recruits here.
>> Exactly. Makes two. And so by playing
that seal of unity, honestly, it is such
a strong turn to pull off. You get your
your seal down, which is almost
permanent resources. You get to also
spin the the vanguard captain, power it,
and get more and more units.
>> Yeah, very victor coded here. Playing a
vangar captain to Fran War camp. It's a
lot of extra might spread across, but
it's time to raid baited hook because it
has been played. A three energy gear,
pay one and a power exhaust this, kill a
friendly unit. That doesn't seem like a
very fun thing to do. But if you do so,
you look at the top five cards of your
main deck. You may play a unit from
among them that has might up to one more
than the killed unit, ignoring its cost.
Then recycle the rest.
>> Yeah. And that is so nice. And it
doesn't matter too much bringing one off
the battlefield to kill because you've
already gotten the point and that's all
that really matters.
>> Yeah, I think especially things like
vanguard captain right already made two
extra recruits that it left behind. You
really want things to either do things
when they enter the game when they leave
the game or if you're really lucky both
cuz you are going to constantly be kind
of bouncing units between zones with
things like baited hook and again when
you equip when you at the war camp when
you can make things bigger you can kind
of go from a very small M unit like a
three all the way to something else.
Let's just do a little bit of math right
now on stream. Venga captain's currently
at three might brutalizer would be plus
oh sorry four for the war camp excuse me
uh four from the war camp plus three
from the brutalizer on the same turn
it's attached that's seven. So if you
activate beta hook sacrificing your
vanguard captain after you do all those
steps you can look at the top five cards
of your deck and you can pull a unit
that has cost uh is it might it's up it
is it matches might. So might eight or
less goes up to one more and you look
from that top all the way down and you
get to play it ignoring its cost. That
seems quite good. Yeah, it seems really
nice. And or you could even do these
smaller units like the recruits that
were free to play in the first place.
They're two in the Travarian War camp.
Imagine you hit another Vanguard camp
and captain and it makes two more.
>> Yeah. Or if you get the brutalizer, you
can now look for a six, right? Cuz it's
five plus the one that Hook goes. So the
the words ignoring its cost as we've
learned from things like Hook and
Aurora. Very powerful piece of text to
put on a rift card. But we are back to
the other side. Sorry for the baited
hook tutorial. Hope you all enjoyed it
here as Nicole going to go ahead and pop
a Zenith Blade onto the board. It is
time to do one of the coolest things in
Riftbound. This spell is so sick.
>> Yeah, Zenith Blade is an interesting
one. We'll have to see what we're able
to pull off here. What exactly does
Zenith Blade do here?
>> Let's give it a read cuz Xenith Blade
has a lot of text.
>> It does.
>> Uh action. Stun an enemy unit at a
battlefield. Cost two power by the way,
so you know it's good. Uh you may move a
friendly unit to the enemy units to that
enemy unit's battlefield. Uh and so stun
and move something bas Yeah. So you stun
a unit at a battlefield. You can then
move a friendly unit from your base to
that battlefield. And then Leona is
going to get an attack trigger when she
moves over and buff herself thanks to
the legend. So pretty much what happened
is Leona is coming in stunning two
things moving for free. Still stays
ready and is going to now just try and
cut down the things at this war camp
though. So it doesn't matter that
there's four units on the side here for
Straw Hat Skull. Doesn't matter they
have extra might from the war camp cuz
two of them are stun. They can't do
anything in combat.
>> Yeah. What are they supposed to do
there? And that buff from Leona is just
going to keep helping her. She is
currently a six smite unit here at the
Trafarian War camp. Uh so she could kill
a good number of uh Straw Hat Scarl's
units.
>> Yeah, two fours and two twos is kind of
the way to look at it here. Two three M
units plus two ones giving plus one to
the wall camp cuz again math is mathing.
Only six might as you pointed out from
the war camp there. So going to you know
do the math and take out two. Not going
to take any damage but does have to go
back to base because I don't know if you
know this and I had to learn this very
early on playing against the Leona. If
you are the attacker and move into a
stun battlefield, the stun units win the
combat if they're left. So, the
attackers get kicked out. But the good
news is because the end of the blade
doesn't ready you to move. You can just
go straight back in
>> at least. Yeah, that is so nice. And
they'll potentially act up to kill here.
This time we get another stun. And stuns
do last throughout your turn. Uh so we
could potentially stun one. Left it
there. Stun. And now we can come in
hopefully not get dealt too much damage
and take the battlefield. It looks like
looks like exactly what's going to
happen. And Trafarian War Cape is
definitely a nice one to hold.
>> So very Yasawo coded thing. I should
probably stop saying Xcoded things on
stream here for Leona. Moved in for free
with the Zenus Blade. Got kicked out
thanks to all the stuns, but still
stunned a couple units moving in. Moved
back in, stunned another unit cuz of the
attack trigger and then cleaned up the
entire battlefield. And because two
stuns happened, two buffs happened. So
Leona's got a buff and that little
lonely par is not so lonely now. I've
got a buff as well on the dreaming tree.
>> He's going to have to stay lonely though
if he wants to draw a card. But uh yeah,
I mean
>> worth it. Stay there.
>> Stay up there in the dreaming tree. Uh
but he will be three might if uh Straw
Hat does want to come up into that
dreaming tree. No units on board right
now though, which is pretty nice
>> for our other Leon.
>> That was such an efficient use of the
interplay to clear an entire
battlefield. Again, lots like quite a
bit of complexity there with lots of
different triggers and readying and
moving back or moving and still being
ready to go back in. But the end result
is wiping your opponent's board and
giving your unit some extra stats while
holding two battlefields and scoring
some points. So, three points to one.
Feeling pretty good. And we are going to
go into the baited hook mode in just a
moment cuz that lonely parro I have to
tell you it's going to die alone.
>> It is about to die alone here. It is
currently though a five meaning we can
look for a unit up to six might. Uh and
let's see what happens. We are going to
have to read the text a little bit about
baited hook. But I don't think many of
us practice too much against baited
hook.
>> Depends. It depends how much your
testing group might be cooking. I
suppose
>> how much they really
>> We're going to look at five. I see a
three. What else do we have? I see
another baited hook. That's not
something you can bust out of the top of
your library unfortunately. I see a
seal. And the selection is going to be
Oh, that's a Darius. That's not so bad.
Your lonely poor duard made a Darius.
>> Yeah, not so bad at all. Uh, and the
rare yellow Darius is going to come into
play here. Uh, let's see what they're
able to do with it, though.
>> Do like what's happening here. Again, a
nice way to answer back here. Have a
quick read of Darius in the order domain
cuz again, don't think we expect to see
too much uh yellow Darius today. So,
this one, we know what the direct one
does. We still got a lot in Origins
there out of Kaiser. This one cost six
is six might, which is uh works out
pretty nicely. uh Legion when you play
me ready me we've certainly done that
having to play that lonely parro and
other friendly units have plus one here
wherever I am and as you kind of noted
there's a lot of things that make
additional units that do extra things
when you're going in and out of the
battlefield so things like vanguard
captain which is a card Victor loves
Victor would probably play this card if
it was reasonable for him to cast
>> but in a baited hook Leona deck much
easier to put in play and now we're
going to go ahead and challenge the poor
lonely porro on the dreaming tree
>> yeah six versus uh three I think this
Darius is going to take the win here on
the showdown do have three might uh
three runes here though on Luna's side.
So there could be some different spells,
but it looks like the Porro will die.
We're going to get a draw off of that as
well. And sad lonely poro.
>> Well, you know what? You get something
when you precious porro does perish. You
at least get a card at the end of it
all.
>> That is true. So, it's not so sad for
the user. Uh but
it is going to decrease how many units
we have on board. At least we still have
the Leona on the other side. We are
going to play Leona as well to our base
and it looks like we will be passing.
>> Yeah, nice little rebuild here just
playing chosen champion. Again, you saw
how good Leona was early on for Nicole.
Have to think if you're playing a Leona
deck, it's going to be a similar story
here even if the decks are very
different. So going to hold to four
points here. Currently ahead by two in
the race, which is a pretty good spot to
be. But Darius, of course, hanging out
with six might over there. probably
nothing to really worry about as far as
tricks go with all the runes currently
exhausted, but still want to make sure
you progress the game forward cuz you
know as every turn this hook goes, your
opponent is trying to get as maximum
value. So generally you want to try and
mitigate the activations cuz something
else is always going to happen. You're
never going to play a unit and not get
something. You know, lonely power is
getting played. It doesn't just
transform into a dice. It also draws you
a card and things are going to get worse
once uh this hook deck can find more and
more things to kind of combo together,
right? by getting an effect again from
the unit you play, but also the unit you
find on top.
>> Yeah, it'll be interesting to see how
big these units can get. Uh, and how
well this baited hook works in Leona. I
mean, it's Leona versus Leona, but two
completely different.
>> Uh, and so interesting to see how
different players can pilot but also
craft these different leaders.
>> I also want to point out there is a
sleeve kind of dangling between the base
and the champion zone there for I
believe that is a hidden card. So at the
battlefield there uh yep going to look
at it like it's a little trap and it is
indeed a hidden card there for Leona.
Could be hidden blade the most obvious
of the hidden cards. Teleon hoarder
going to actually get played to base
which makes me feel like oh actually
interesting. Just wants to move Leona
away and have the hoarder hold it
instead. So still holding up one. That
hidden card still there as well. So
options here for Nicole. We're going to
pass on back and see if she can't hold
on to this point at the war camp.
Yeah, let's
silicorn Herder is an I mean interesting
choice to hold here is only four might
compared to the six that Leona had, but
hopefully there's some type of stun that
could come down and stuns are really
interesting even to these big mighted
units and I think that's something to
watch for. Uh obviously Leona is very
built to stun. Leona chosen champion
itself is a I think it's win attack
stun. Yes. So if any of these units come
up into the Trafarian War camp, even if
let's say they were multiple times
larger than Selicorn Herder, if Luna can
stun it, it can't deal damage and as you
mentioned earlier, will just be bounced
back into its base.
>> Okay. Well straw hat skull. I talked
about, you know, when to get value out
of your baited hook, it is value town
USA right now. Unsung hero when uh it's
a little unit, only a two might unit,
but if it's mighty when it dies, you get
to draw two cards. Well, brutalizer two
plus three as it turns out when you
attach that's five. So you have a mighty
unit, it goes away, you get a glass
mixologist off the top of your deck,
finding a five might unit with another
death nail that helps you kind of recur
cards back from your graveyard. And all
of a sudden you are, you know, turned
your little two drop into a five drop
and two cards.
>> That is really really nice. Very unsung
hero uh and definitely the hero of the
turn. It is going to make it now up to
11 might up in this dreaming tree which
is so much. Darius also giving one more
as well to units that are here with him.
It's 12 total I believe. I don't think
Darius buffs himself and it's going to
be hidden blade targeted at the stone
holder. Now you do get to draw cards.
It's a controller of the unit that dies
which has to feel pretty good. But of
course if the Stilicorn holder goes away
that hidden card's going with it.
>> Yeah, I wonder what we what the hidden
card is if it is something that could
help here. Hidden blade is battlefield
only, but I'm not sure that there's
anything that could pull it out of the
battlefield. Oh, it's zonas though,
which does mean Celicorn Herder will be
able to survive this hidden blade. It'll
be moved back to base.
>> And I mean, it's just really nice to be
able to keep that Stellar alive.
>> Yeah, I think important note, uh,
recalls the unit, puts it back to it,
which explicitly in the reminder text
says this isn't a move, which is very
important for this exact case with
Cilicone Holder. So, you don't get to
draw an extra card. You do get to save
your unit. You
interesting
drawing for turn. Did I I might be
misunderstanding how the interaction
works.
>> But maybe not.
>> That's okay.
>> Oh, hidden blade. There we go. That was
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. The hidden blade drew,
too.
>> Okay. Everything's above board. Don't
you worry. Hidden blade. Oh,
interesting. Hidden blade still lets you
draw the cards even though the Oh, it
did die. It just got replaced. That is
confusing.
>> Yeah. So, it does survi. I mean, it
stays alive in the base. So, we do get
those two cards and that it's going to
be really nice for Leona. Uh,
>> those effects are not tied explicitly
together. The unit doesn't have to die
for you to draw the cards.
>> Exactly.
>> Which I guess in theory means you could
do it to your own unit if you had a
zonius.
>> I was actually interested like if if it
was a hidden hidden blade, could they
both kill it and then you draw four?
>> You might actually. I'd have to
>> I don't know. I don't I don't know. You
know what? That's a rules question I'm
going to ask in a in a in a rounds off
cuz I'm curious to know cuz that would
be a fun bit of value to get instead. We
pass it on back. It is three points to
fall here. Straw hat skull establishing
a pretty nice board especially in that
northern battlefield but still plenty to
go here. Leona back in base where kind
of she wants to be. You can see both
players actually leaving her back for
the exact balance you prescribed where
Leona does want to be attacking to get
those stun triggers and that cascades
into a whole bunch of fun stuff for
Leona to get to do. But right now, you
know, it's I think 12 might in the top
battlefield versus only the uh eight we
can see right now on base. And as we
know, plenty of tricks, plenty of moves,
plenty of fun things for Leona here to
try and pick apart these battlefields.
do want to do it pretty carefully,
especially when your opponent is
presenting two runes as well.
>> Yeah, and two can just be so many
things. A little bit less in green and
yellow, but still a lot that it could be
as an answer. It does look like guardian
angel is going to get played. Guardian
Angel is very similar to Zona's except
that as a gear, it attaches directly to
a unit. So Za's only bad thing is that
it's the next unit that gets killed, but
because G is attached to one
specifically, it's whenever the one
you're attached to dies, so you can be
much more targeted on which one will it
will end up bringing or recalling back.
>> Yeah, getting the extra might as well
also makes it a bit better on offense.
>> Mhm.
>> Cuz you can kind of send in, get a stun
here from Leona, maybe, you know, trade
off of the unit, die, but the G pops and
then go back to base and go again. I
don't see another way to ready or move
right now in Nicole. She flashed it very
briefly, but uh there's a lot of spells.
>> I do think there's a discipline which
could be helpful here.
>> I think there's also I think it's
Emperor's Call, Emperor's Divide.
>> There was an Emperor something in the
deck list. I do see the card that you're
talking about. Uh not fully.
>> I'm going to find it.
>> Okay. Uh but it'll be interesting to see
how this happens. Sometimes you would
may would want to maybe play like
discipline early to be able to see what
you draw or make sure it
>> it resolves before you bring up a unit
that is extra might or would die
otherwise. But in this case, because
it's dreaming tree, we're probably going
to want to save these disciplines for
when you're actually there so you can
get the additional draw off the Dream.
>> Yep. Okay. Going in stunning the Darius,
I assume, and then buffing the silicon
here. Empress Divide was the cloud of
Synov, which is Aziz's ulties in League
of Legends. In this game, it's an
interesting one. It's a hidden card that
lets you recall friendly units from a
battlefield to your base. So often
hidden is kind of an a proxy copy of
zonies or GA where you can save your
units. It's a bit different. Doesn't
quite get maybe not quite as powerful,
but kind of uh does a lot of the things
you want it to do. So discipline, as you
noted, is going to come out here, make
this Leona even bigger, and draw two
cards thanks to that text on Dreaming
Tree. So it is a stunned Darius and a
glass pixologist versus a quite large
Leona. Four, five, six plus two. That
would be eight might right now. Yeah, it
is going to be able to potentially kill
either. We stun one in that ultra witch,
but ouch, thonk is going to come down. I
actually love Thonk.
>> It's a great card.
>> The name as well is top tier. Thonk. You
know exactly what's going to happen.
You're stunned.
>> Yep. Rune Prison. Pretty good stun card.
As far as Leona goes, thunk a little bit
better. It's an action. Uh it stuns an
attacking unit. Uh but you can repeat
it, which when you have some extra
resources lying around,
>> pretty good to get two copies of spells.
Not so fast. Straw hat skull. Not so
fast. Uh, but that's actually the name
of the card that got played as well. Uh,
yeah, another really great name. We got
the long not so fast.
>> Top tier naming happening in Riftbound
here. It is a reaction speed one step up
from action itself. And it can counter a
spell or ability that chooses a friendly
unit or gear. So,
you don't get to choose my Leona here.
Uh, so we are still an eight versus
either six or six.
>> Yes, it's two different sixes. So, he's
not going to win out the combo here cuz
the can only deal so much damage. You
don't do extra damage cuz the unit stun.
So, he's going to be pushed back thanks
to how the rules with stun and attacking
and defending work. The the the way to
shortcut that in your brain is that
defenders win uh when stunned units are
left at a battlefield. So there was only
enough which I feel like is the right to
try and pick off here.
Stac
might plus two for the different effects
that are floating around on it. Draw a
card, hide a card. And uh pretty good
times here for Nicole. It's currently at
five points as Draw Heart Skull kind of
getting the value but struggling to
really deal with the continuous Leona
plays. In fact, it doesn't even seem
that bad to get kicked out of your
battlefield as Leona because you kind of
want Leona to be in the base anyway.
Yeah, I would say that it's almost a
plus to have your Leona in the base
because you want to be attacking with
Leona. She does look, you know, like she
would defend well, but she actually
attacks well. And so being able to bring
her back up in and attack your following
turn is just so nice. You get that stun
off, which as we have mentioned, I think
the most times all day, is a really
great ability.
>> Yeah, we maybe we'll only mention it in
this round. I don't know how much more
we are going to see throughout the day,
but this is a fascinating little not
mirror match exactly, but I mean a
fascinating legend mirror match here.
Certainly a fascinating uh match up
between these two different versions of
this deck. Kind of much more standard
good numbers, good tricks from Nicole.
And then Straw Hat Skull with the baited
hook in play trying to extract as much
value as possible. We're going to start
by equipping this Leona who again is
going to buff when a stun happens thanks
to that legend ability and it's going to
be quite a bit bigger than this tele.
There is something hidden and today it
is Empress Divide going to save that
stalk. And this one is a move. You get
to draw a card this time.
>> We love moving. I sail corner.
>> I love drawing cards.
>> We love drawing cards. Uh and so yeah,
we get moved back. We are going to be up
to four points here. So we are starting
to close the divide between points. Uh
potentially try and come back. Five,
sorry, five versus five. My bad on that.
Um, and let's see if Straw Hack can
completely bring it back. But Luna still
with two units. It's not like either
have died here.
>> Yeah, it's a kind of interesting back
and forth because even though Nicole's
constantly picking off units by sending
in the Leona and kind of presenting the
tricks, has the G to kind of reset,
maybe go again if you find something
like a Zenith Blade to, you know, move
the Leona with the stun that's attached
to that. I don't know how many other
ready effects Nicole is playing in her
deck, but uh certainly there's this
interesting pattern of like why I can
pick off your units quite easily.
They're quite vulnerable on battlefields
in this match up cuz Leono is just so
good on offense when you start stunning
things.
>> So, but if you don't kick everyone off,
you do get points for holding. So, this
is kind of eb and flow of like I'm going
to get points sometimes if I manage to
finish the conquer. Even though I'm
getting value by picking off your units,
I'm not necessarily taking the points
away from you. And at the end of the
day, the points are the thing that you
really have to focus on, especially as
you get near the end of it. So, five a
piece as we awaken here for Nicole. And
looks like one battlefield at least
ready to claim here. Is picking off the
potential Leona more important as Straw
Hat Skull has presented four open runes
here on this turn. Going to be quite a
lot to navigate here.
>> Yeah, it's going to be really
interesting to see what Luna does about
the the opponent's Leona. Uh we have
Yeah, I do think that there's a little
bit of problem Leona where she's so
strong attacking, not good defending,
and then you have that problem as you
mentioned. But in this case, they both
have that problem. So, I guess it's not
as big of a deal. Uh it will be
interesting to see if we can find a way
to take both battlefields again, try to
pull ahead. Um but it is rough right
now. This Leona is at seven in the
bottom battlefield for Trarian War camp.
Our Leona only at six. We could bring
both in, but then you potentially have
your Leona die as well.
>> So uh so on the the math, they both each
have a buff and a plus one piece of
equipment. So the math checks out that
uh Nicole Leona is currently going to
win the fight cuz uh the Leona's
battlefield is going to get stunned.
>> Yeah, for some reason I thought there
was an extra plus one on this Leona down
here. You are correct.
>> Not going to get not going to get to
fight back and she's okay on defense.
Does have shield actually which you did
not earlier. That is actually going to
matter if we want to travel to the
bottom battlefield on Nicole's side. So
instead it's circle and holder take the
easy point going to six. Six a number
that feels pretty good and you can maybe
hold back here. But I do think trying to
clear out this Leona feels relatively
important. Although it kind of depends
how much danger you putting your Leona
into. It's a BF sword being put into the
table now. That is going to give enough
might for the other Leona to pop in. And
again with the G, I think Nicole's not
too worried. This Leona can get sent in,
threaten to hold for the win at seven
points and just say, you know what,
>> deal with this cuz I don't think you
can.
>> Yeah, it's going to be a lot to deal
with. Uh bringing up plus three from the
long not long sword uh from the BF sword
and then also the two the one for war
camp. It's going to be so much here uh
for Straw Hasgar to deal with.
>> Yeah, it's currently 10 on seven, I
believe, if we factor in the wall camp.
>> 6 plus one versus 9 plus one. Send in
the Leona.
>> Stun your unit. Buff nothing. Sadly,
there's nothing that's unbuffed. You
don't get some extra value, but still
going to feel pretty good here. Pass it
on over and there's a death crit.
>> Plus five here. It is stunned, so it
won't be able to kill our Leona, but it
could push us back. And going up to six
points does not seem good for Luna
Nicole.
>> I I just love the synergy that's present
in this beta hook version of Leona. The
death reaction I think Oh, never mind.
Not going to get cuz happens. So that
would have not only buffed and drawn a
card, but triggered the mixologist,
which gets a unit back from your trash
into the base. So ton of value presented
on the death g. And Nicole reads the
card for two seconds like, "No, I don't
think so. to buy that one away and try
and hold for the win here again. Seven
points with two units on each one unit
on each battlefield threatening to win
if Straw Hat scar can't displace these
units from their current places.
>> Yeah, I think defy is one of those cards
with fantastic flavor text is exactly
what I think when I play defy. No,
>> no,
>> I only need one word. Yeah, there's a
there's this long-standing term across I
think a number of different games where
spells like this are typically called
permission spells because uh when you
play a spell, your opponent holding the
position spell, you have to ask them
permission if it can result and if I
simply giving you the answer, no, you
don't have permission.
>> Actually, no. I love that. That's a
really great name for it. I'm
>> This is my first like game that has
these type of spells in it. So, it's
very interesting to see. Um we do have a
couple options though. It looks like I
did see Tasty Faith Folk in hand. TCbook
does have accelerate. Something to watch
out for here to help move in, you know,
a unit potentially wipe uh Luna Nicole's
board, but we'll have to see. We are
just doing some math as well. Looks like
on this
double triple check on the 10 from what
I'm reading. T with a guardian angel
most notably. So even if this Leona is
taken out, she's going to be back and
available to swing back in to the
battlefield. So throw out skulls got
quite a task here and does have a decent
amount of runes, but you have to kick
both units off the battlefield either by
taking them out or by stunning them by
pushing them away in some way. Uh and
after that, you have to make sure you
don't get double conquered on. So uh
>> is likely going to live through this
turn because of that GA.
>> So I'm not sure how much Straw Hat Skull
has to maybe make work here, but I see a
bait hook. I think I may have spider
called a weak flicking through the cards
very quickly. I'm trying to catch just
the tops of the costs. I see the
faithful you mentioned his glass misl
going to start in with the simple stuff
I suppose rumble on in with the sticon
hoarder but again even one open there's
something like on guard if got that in
her list there are options here still at
one but instead we're going to try we
have to try right so we're going to
start by trying to take out the
battlefield that looks a bit easier to
take
>> yeah and potentially we can play
something to help this unit win we could
draw more cards off that dreaming tree
call of glory so call of glory is an
interesting card because not only does
it have a cost that is ruined runes, but
it can have an additional cost for
instead you pay a buff. And Leona has
been making the buffs this game. So
suddenly we're not just a four at
Dreaming Tree. We are now a seven.
>> Much bigger there for Silicon Protected
there. Call of Glory. One of the few
kind of free spells in the game of
Riftbound so far. But it's just so sick.
You get to take a buff from the other
battlefield. So it doesn't even affect
your might there. You get to target your
telecon at the dreaming tree for the
first time ever. So you get to draw a
card. There's just so much good value
built into this Leona deck. And again,
there's a lot more complexity, perhaps a
lot more really cool things happening on
the baited hook side for Straw Hat
Skull. But in this particular position
when we're trying to kick these units
off the battlefield, I mean, to call it
one rune open, she still has one rune
open. Didn't have to use anything to try
and protect that Silkon who's still
going to stay that big for the rest of
this turn.
>> Yeah, that's going to be so nice. And
there is a second buff if we had like a
second call of glory or needed it. It
does look like we have a unsung hero
being played again. And we are going to
use that brutalizer. to make its might
even more to potentially get a really
good card off of this baited hook. But
to note, Luna Nicole is at seven points,
meaning Straw Hat will have to clear
both sides with whatever he pulls off of
the baited hook
>> for a harness dragon, which would have
been great, but that's not enough might.
Only looking for a six here in the top.
And there is a couple options. No, it is
a harness dragon is a six. I forgot it
costs eight, but it is only six might,
which makes sense because getting to
kill a unit when you play it is quite a
powerful effect. So, we wanted to give
the dragon less might, but that is
actually perfect for a deck like baited
hook.
>> Which one will die though? If we kill
the Leona, it does go up to War Camp,
but it will still survive in the base.
If we kill the Stellorn Herder, it does
officially die.
>> You have to do both. That's the problem.
You both units need to leave these
battlefields here.
>> Otherwise, Nicole is going to take game
one in uh what is starting to become
kind of a tight one. In fact, never
mind. Straw Hat Scar decides I did that
much. That looked pretty good, but I
could not take both battlefields. Nicole
going to win game one on her. Let's call
it regular Leona.
>> I like it. I did see like Straw Hat did
potentially have a way to do. He had a
second harness dragon in hand, but I saw
him count his runes and he must not have
had enough to play a second one. So, we
are going into game two. It's going to
be a little bit different. That obisk
power for ramping up runes, but also
arena's greatest to ramp up the speed of
our game. very interesting that uh
Arena's greatest would be something that
Hook would want to go for. But I guess
in general you're trying to do kind of a
lot of powerful things in a somewhat
condensed timeline, right? I think in
general games that go really late unless
you have like a big engine building can
maybe be tough to to crack through. So I
think trying to win a little bit faster
because you are generally deploying
things far ahead of schedule, right?
Much like Aurora when you get the things
down, you know, you flip a big, you
know, harness dragon that's got six
smite and kills something when it comes
into play. If you do that on like turn
three, let's say. That's very ahead of
schedule.
>> Yeah, that would be absolutely insane.
You would clear a board and get that
huge might unit down. There's so many
options with this baited hook. And it's
so cool to see it paired with the
equipment.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think uh Spirit Forge
adding a lot to the the baited hook
decks here. Brutalizer especially giving
so much might for so little investment.
Just two for the gear itself. Plus, it's
free to equip. I mean, you have to
recycle a room, but you don't have to
pay resources, let's say. and just
giving so much on the attach which is
really the only time it matters. Beta
actually a pretty cool deck in that you
get to move your equipment around a lot.
Typically when you equip equipment it
stays on until the unit goes away but
this deck is trying to take its units
away. You get a lot of additional value
there as OB is going to channel an extra
one here on turn one.
>> Strawhead skull I believe did remember
the arena's greatest and there's a
vanguard captain with a seal. That is a
real nice opener.
>> That is such a strong start. Immediately
we get the seal for the baited hook. We
get the vanguard vanguard captain with
three mightite and two one might units.
Oh my gosh, that is absolutely insane.
And going first here, it's only possible
because that obelisk of power. I will
mention Reena's greatest and obvious
power are both triggers that you have to
call and it looks potentially still at
one zero for straw hats.
>> I did see him like point to the card at
the start of the game. So I believe the
players have remembered their trigger.
It may just not be reflected on the
overlay, but we'll see you know what
happens. We'll kind of let it play out
here as now could conquer both here.
going to go for one, go for two.
Recruits really good at taking points
here. So, Strawhead Sky going to start
off at three. It should be at the end of
it all. And that's brutal. Cole the
week.
>> Cole of the week is such a strong card.
It is two and power one. We have the
seal. So, we kind of get to cheat it.
But when especially when you're making
to these like uh token units, the
recruit I mean that is only one might we
didn't really even have to pay for in
the first place since Vanguard captain
did it. We can kill one of those and
it's any of the units on Luna's side.
Luna though only had one unit. She had
nothing to protect her Leona and now
that chosen champion dead in the trash
pile.
>> Yeah, don't uh don't get fooled. I
believe there's more than one copy of
this Leona in the deck, but the one that
was from the chosen champion zone, it's
kind of floating between the the
graveyard and the chosen champion.
>> She's trying to crawl back.
>> That was the Yeah, that was the one that
made it in there. So, that one's going
to the bin for now. Lonely Porro
deployed again. Quite good in both
decks, as it turns out. Fun to see them
both utilizing Lonely Porro in such
different ways.
>> Mhm. But already off to a roaring start
here for Straw Hat Skull. And again,
score not currently updated on the
screen. Maybe the players are know the
button they have to tap to update the
score. Maybe two locked in.
>> Yeah, who knows? I did see her write
something, so I assume
>> I believe it's currently 3 points to
one. That would make sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah, they just they both updated.
>> Oh, one from the arena's greatest. There
we go. We've we've solved it.
>> Yes. Uh so we did get that updated to
reflect the arena's greatest. Let's see.
>> Nothing else there for Nicole. just
holding up some runes wanting to try and
uh you know this is relatively small
units but wanting to maybe try and fend
them off but here's something bigger.
There's Leona out of the champion zone.
>> I love all the arts alt arts in this
game. They're absolutely gorgeous. Leona
so cute. She looks like a lion and I
absolutely adore it.
>> That should be to five points now I
believe. So held both after countering.
So 5 to one is the start here for Straw
Hat Skull and again the arena's greatest
accelerating this game. And we're still
playing to eight. That feels more like
seven when you start with the three
point.
>> Yeah, you were mentioning how
potentially baited hook could accelerate
and go in, but we didn't even need
baited hook to get five points here.
>> Yeah. And that's it. Game game two was
done.
>> Scooped up there for Nicole decided that
start was actually just too good. Baited
hook not even needed heart is going to
equal it up in about 3 minutes. I think
that game was
>> insane. Game two. Arena's greatest is
able to speed it up so much. It looks
like game three is about to start. I
assume Luna Nicole is going to go first
here. Grove of the God Willow. We saw it
earlier. When you hold able to draw an
extra card and we're also going to be
going into build temple.
>> Yeah, Veil Temple is kind of a fun one.
When you conquer Hig ready a friendly
gear if it's an equipment, this is the
important part of the decks for this
deck. You may detach it.
>> This is actually a way for you to detach
equipment. Again, some decks like the
Vanguard Armory decks sometimes like
this. You can reactivate armory. That's
pretty sweet. This deck actually wants
weirdly the function or like the the the
perceived less good function, let's call
it the detaching part actually mattering
for moving those equipment around,
shuffling the brutalizers, shuffling the
other equipment that Straw Hat Skull has
access to here as players are going to
land up here for our final game, round
two. And already we're going to game
three between again two Leonas that are
one and zero.
>> I love it. I absolutely I would actually
I mean obviously getting those
brutalizers move around would be great
but reading a unit would be so
interesting in a baited hook deck. I
mean I just like think like the vanguard
captain line potentially or you already
have those two tokens you could do both
potentially. That being said only up to
two might but still crazy.
>> You you figured it out. That's actually
the that's actually the best use case
for it's ready friendly gear. If it's an
equipment you'd attach it. Baited hook.
Thank you for reminding me of today is a
gear. So that is a way to use baited
hook multiple times in a turn. A single
hook that is immensely powerful. We kind
of saw that like in the value Luna
Nicole felt pretty comfortable.
>> Oh yeah,
>> baited hook pretty good when you do it
once. Backbreaking if you can do it more
than once a turn. And there's a hook
right on time.
>> Yeah, baited hook immediately coming
down here. Game one came down at a
pretty good speed. Game two, you didn't
even need it to win. Game three, turn
one, absolutely insane. And we are gonna
have to see how Luna Nicole deals with
it because not only she have to deal
with it immediately after turn one,
she's potentially having to deal with it
as well twice a turn. But Leona is
already made also with that guardian
angel. So it is kind of two copies down.
>> Yeah, it's a pretty big Leona. Going to
be a six if it stuns a unit thanks to
the legend ability. Kill a gear though,
salvaging that guardian angel. So no
extra protection. And notably Nicole had
to recycle two runes to make that play.
played the Leona but paid a power for
both the GA equip and the Leona herself.
So not a lot of resources here to work
with and throw Skulls deciding to play a
bit slower here. Wanting to set up a
bigger baited hook turn just saying you
know what one Leona right now not
particularly scary when you only have
four other runes.
>> Yeah, he is getting set up though. He's
got that seal of unity already in play
that can help with this baited hook. Uh
we are going to be moving up Leona
though to that God Willow. He h because
Straw had no has no cards in play as in
units in play. Hopefully this Leona will
be able to draw a card off Grove of the
God Willow. I do think there's more draw
in this set two, but especially set one.
If you could get just a single card of
Grove of the God Willow, sometimes it
could win you the entire game.
>> Yeah, Grove is a very powerful thing to
hold on to. So, Lonely Porter going to
get deployed as a bit of backup and does
feel like the temple is fairly
important, but deciding that the card
draw is more worth it right now. There's
nothing really to contend for. So, also
no units for skull. So, not a lot of
potential threat for a conquer right
now. So Nicole going to take the early
points and try and get ahead kind of in
tempo which I think given the texture of
the first game especially something this
Leona deck kind of needs to be in this
particular Leona match up.
>> That's not confusing at all. It's fine.
>> Yeah, it's fine. It's fine. We do also
have a hidden card coming down in that
growth with Godwill. So I do think we're
really committing to holding
>> Zas.
>> Oh, it could be Zas. I would love to see
it be a second
>> second hidden blade. Are we
>> hilarious? Uh but we do have one hidden
blade coming down threatening this
Leona. It looks like it's actually
Emperor's Divide uh which going to help
protect this Leona. Brings it back to
base. And while we're not going to get
that hold, we do keep the Leona.
>> Yeah, not to stuff the Hidden Blade.
Notably did not get to draw cards this
time. So, it does look like the card has
to actually I guess it doesn't resolve
cuz it has to kill out of battlefield.
Leon's no longer out of battlefield. So,
doesn't get the extra bonus that that
Zony's ended up getting, which was quite
juicy. But saving maybe your most
important unit in your deck feels pretty
good.
>> Yeah, I would say she's kind of
determined. M
>> to survive. But we do finally get
teleorn herder. So straw hat is
threatening to be able to take points.
It's also with three might potentially
threatening that baited hook. But we're
going to be the one going up with lonely
porro into that v temple. I think
picking which battlefield go to here is
a little bit interesting in this matchup
because a lot of times you would think
of the god Willow is like the higher
priority, but if you could actually get
two baited hooks off like that's insane.
So which one is it? Oh,
>> unfortunately we're not going to get to
answer the question of two hooks cuz it
doesn't matter. Salvage is going to put
that baited hook into the bin.
>> Two points and uh the main engine of
Straw Hat Skull's deck is now deleted
from the battlefield from the base.
>> Yeah, hopefully he'll be able to find
another one. He did so he has that
ability. He had two at the end of game
two, but uh it's definitely painful.
Straw Hat said no to the guardian angel
and we're saying no to the baited hook.
>> Yeah, I feel like I mean both pretty
impactful cards I have to think for the
baited hook deck losing your namesake
card feels pretty bad but a big rune
advantage here. This is the thing like
Nicole is using a lot using a lot of
power to generate these turns right. So
uh definitely has to try and halt here
once again to get the early points. I
think at this point like you are going
to get overwhelmed especially with
against Veil Temple specifically because
there is so much extra value that this
baited hook deck can kind of turn out.
So, Celicorn's going to going to get to
draw another card. Lots of runes in play
here to try and make a play. So, we'll
see what draw lines up. It's simply a
harness dragon cast the oldfashioned
way.
>> Yeah, you know, nothing wrong with
actually paying for your cards.
>> It does mean you won't
>> feel I feel I feel targeted. I do not
like paying for my cards. I like
shooting them into play.
>> I mean, like, it's a lot stronger not
for, but you know, sometimes you just
pay for your cards. And with it, I
wouldn't be surprised if we saw this
Leona die. Uh, so I do assume it is
going to go Leona versus giving a draw
to the lonely Porro, but what is the
hidden card I think is going to be the
huge thing here with this playing out.
>> It could be a Zagna, which would be
maybe not the best thing. I mean, you
kind of have to get through it. So maybe
you're just priced in at this point for
Straw Heart Skull. I did get a peak
though and I I can tell you it is not
AAS. There's almost some level of like
bluffing happening here where Nicole's
presenting a car that is going to
protect this Leona and Harness Dragon
says, "You know what? Let me see if it's
if it's a Zist. Show me if it's an
Empress, which I'm pretty sure is what
it is. Unfortunately, moving away unlike
Hidden Blade does not save the day.
>> Tragic. And it is just like you said.
Dare you see the hidden card was
supposed to be hidden.
>> It was Sorry, Nicole. Flashed it a
little little too far up on the top of
the overhead view we have here, but
Solicorn still going to move in for a
point and a card. First point scored
here by Strawhead. Skull always feels
pretty good. But it does feel like with
this board and again with how much
investment Nicole made in recycling
these runes to kind of get on board all
of a sudden you seem woefully behind.
>> Yeah, three runes going to five just
does not feel enough when you're going
into some to a player that already had
eight runes. They are stuck at it again
after paying two. No, they only had to
pay one because of the seals. Yeah,
>> man. Sals are just too strong. But uh as
it turns out,
>> yeah, going to five versus going to
nine. Does that Yeah. Nine is just so it
does not feel a good spot to be in.
>> No, we'll see how much play Nicole has
here with the cards in her hand. Pra did
at least score a point. Again, very far
ahead on points as well. So, uh can
maybe try and navigate to a position
where can look to score those last two
points, but the uh the units that baited
hook Leona is going to present just
going to generally be a lot bigger and
have a lot more impact when they're
played. Right. Leona wants to kind of
combine a lot of cards. Here is Sona
actually to reinforce this battlefield.
>> Trying to deny some value from the
hidden temple and just say, you know
what, I'm willing to hold up all my
runes and I am not leaving this
battlefield until one of us wins this
game. Hopefully, it's me.
>> Yeah. And I think Sona somewhat like
kind of solves that problem you
mentioned where we do not have the runes
that Straw Hat does, but she has a
really unique ability where when she's
at a battlefield, not holds, not
conquers, but at, you're able to ready
four friendly units at the beginning or
not beginning turn, at the end of your
turn. Which means as we go into Straw
Hat Carl's turn, while we would have
only had one up, we now have four that
he has to, you know, account for with
the harness dragon with these different
cards he has if he wants to take Temple.
>> Trading back the Porter base actually.
So wanting that maybe for a future turn.
Silicon Holder got the point beholding.
Now going to move back to relative
safety and draw a card after scoring the
point. Silicon Herod uh maximum points
once again. Not quite uh the
overperformer that our plundering pro
was earlier as hidden blade is going to
be targeted at this Sona but full runes
open. Lots of spells Nicole can have
here to deny this.
>> Lots and lots of spells and it is only
at battlefields as we saw a couple turns
ago. Uh so that is to remember. It will
also though if we can't find a way to
stay there harness dragon could just
move up.
We'll have to see here. It does look
like we are going to use two of our
runes to discipline. We're going to draw
off of it. It will leave two up. Is
there something we can do? One more.
Does what? Here. No.
Okay. Plus two. We got our draw. Trying
to think what we're looking for with the
with the two runes up to be able to save
the
>> to fire and not so fast would both work
here. Unfortunately, not so fast in
particular wouldn't mean that Sona can
win her uh subsequent combat with the
harness dragon. So, kind of need like a
defy and an ong guard here. Just
thinking about the tools that are
generally in arsenals. There's no buff
either, so we don't have cold call to
glory as an option to maybe use here.
That would be really nice. But haven't
stunned anything yet. It's just kind of
been, you know, removal traded back and
forth. There is the defy though, which
that's going to stop the hidden blade.
But Dona have another plan cuz that
harness dragon's going to come rumbling
in right about now.
>> On the plus side, they're both six to
six right now. So you would have to
sacrifice the harness dragon, but he's
kind of done his job. His job was to
kill the Leona, and he succeeded at it.
>> Certainly did. So will the dragon ride
on into the Veil Temple? won't get a
conquer. No bait hook to speak of just
yet, but perhaps I've spoken a little
too soon.
>> Three for one.
>> Vanguard Captain.
>> There's two cards in this deck that that
could be for the cost. And it's uh it's
the less fun one, but still the very
good one.
>> It's the one that really develops your
base though, which is just so strong.
And when we do find the baited hook
could be really nice.
>> It's a bluff. That's the thing I'm
trying to think now. Oh, never mind.
Death is going to be like I don't care
what you have. I'm just going to go
ahead rumble on in, draw a card,
sacrifice my unit, which you know,
Vanguard Captain already kind of did the
job. Left two units behind.
>> Going to make this dragon even bigger
than the on guard that could be lying in
weight and rumble on in to try and
conquer the Veil Temple. And Sona goes
goodbye.
>> Sona goes bye-bye while death grip also
gets that extra card.
>> Really sweet card though.
>> I love it. It's It's great in his ear.
>> It is great in his ear. I was going to
say I think my problem with death grip
is it's kind of hard to find decks that
really want to utilize it. The beta hook
lion are obviously one that does want
to. I think that just means I'm not
playing the decks that want to utilize
it.
>> Yeah, I think these decks that just
generate so many different units are
cool with killing their own units. It it
does find a nice place in it and it
doesn't cost power which is really nice
as well.
>> Yeah, that see I saw a yellow Darius
once again is Salvage going to take out
the seal here almost just to cycle this
at this point. I mean, not bad to try
and, you know, push your opponent off
future power cost cuz do you have to pay
quite a few to to power the engine that
is this baby hook or even things like
follow up dragons, but it just feels
like at this point the board states just
don't feel equal. Even though the points
are still in your favor, it's a lonely
porro versus the world right now.
>> It is a lonely porro against the world
and don't really have the runes that
Straw Hat has. I guess we are slowly
crawling our way back. It is uh you know
another card draw as well. I wonder how
Luna and Nicole will be able to, you
know, I don't want to say bring this
back cuz we are heading points, but it
definitely feels like behind when it
comes to the board.
>> It feels like getting to six and then
setting having a setup turn and then
playing for a double conquer feels like
kind of the line you're looking to
navigate here. Getting to five is okay,
but obviously it's uh not the the point
value you'd like to be at when you we're
genuinely playing to even numbers of
points. And there's going to be more to
come here. Brutalizer out of Straw Hat
Skull. That Darius, by the way, Legion
ready me other units get plus one here.
So that Darius represents not just a lot
of might on the Darius side, but a lot
of might with this very wide board
herder going to move on in, draw a card
and challenge the lonely lonely Borro.
>> Lonely Porro.
>> Yeah, getting to also get that Darius
down when you're trying to hold on and
grow is so nice. And there are other
units that we can move up there like
those recruits. So, I don't know whether
we'll see it, but it it definitely can
get a lot of value off that Darius.
>> Looks like five points right now.
Straw hat skull still a little behind on
the point race, but catching up pretty
rapidly, it feels like. Here's a hook.
>> Ooh, there's a hook.
>> Does have to pay power now. Doesn't have
the seal that we invested in earlier.
>> But now we do have the seal.
>> Oh, it's so back.
>> Yeah, we just got it back. Let's go.
>> And then here's the unsung hero. This
might be a Didn't do it. Didn't want to
activate the hook this time. and
Brutalizer actually notably still
attached to the circ. So he couldn't do
the fun thing with unsung hero instead
just going to pass back with a what's
that five units and a bunch of might
over with both battle fleets being held.
Seems fine.
>> Seems fine. I feel like we're in a good
board state. We're we're sitting pretty
here. And I wouldn't be surprised though
if we could, you know, see the unveil
temple or the build temple being used
just in the way that you mentioned
earlier with that detach instead of
actually using it to run a baited hook
twice. unfortunately already held at the
temple which means Nicole passed back
with six runes and no plays. I said
getting a six and taking a setup turn
might be the thing you have to do. I
don't think there's a way out of this
game for Nicole.
>> Channel some ruins draws a card doing
the pleasant
>> check for it.
So fast
>> that hand is not it and that should be
game here for Straw Hat Skull. Well, the
shake of the hand does go across the
table and baited Hook Leona is
undefeated at the Las Vegas qualify.
Exactly the sentence you expected to
hear today.
>> Yeah, I mean I think this went exactly
how everyone expected today's tournament
to go. Leona Baited Hook maybe the best
deck in
>> I like that Nicole's panting back to her
friends. Hey, look over the first game.
Okay, it was going well. Everything was
okay, but unfortunately at the end
baited hook Leona was enough to kind of
push it over. I mean, game two very
fast. Just kind of a blazingly fast
start. But then you kind of see I mean
the engine that this deck assembles
being very powerful. And again this is
kind of a thing with decks like Luna
where you have a lot of interaction
spells and you have a lot of units. If
you draw a mix you usually feel pretty
good. If you draw all of one and none of
the other feels kind of bad.
>> Yeah. And that's exactly what happened
in game three sadly. But great job by
both of these Leona players. It was so
cool to see just how you can build them
differently and how they can succeed in
those different games. Well, I would
love to hear more about how that deck
was built. And there's no better person
than that than the winner of our last
match who we have an interview with.
>> All right, I'm here with Straw Hat Scarl
fresh off a victory in a Leona mirror.
First things first, I got to ask you,
you know, why Leona?
>> I mean, realistically, I was kind of
thinking not a lot of people are going
to be on Leona. I played Leona a ton in
solo Q after she came out. So, playing a
little bit of a different list though.
We're on baited hook just I don't know.
Regular Leona package feels so bad in
such a removal heavy meta. So, I just
figured baited hook was something that
no one's going to see. And sure enough,
now people saw it. I guess it didn't. It
worked, but you know.
>> Yeah. I want to ask you a little bit
about this match in particular. I mean,
it's it's a Leona mirror that can be a
little dicey just due to, you know,
there's shield and then stun. So,
there's offensive and defensive
pressure. How do you feel your hook deck
was fairing? Did you get any advantages
from being hooked versus not being
hooked?
>> Yeah, so game I think it was game one
definitely I hit a harness dragon off
the top which is really nice. Uh it's
really hard into like traditional Leona
sometimes with my setup because we're
looking at G ZAS emperor's divide like
all of the ways to save everything. I
mean everything in green right just
saves everything not so fast. She not so
fast with the harness dragon which was
excellent by excellent play by her. Game
two started with arena and led with just
vanguard captain seal. So it was kind of
just cooked from the start. It was I was
at five in 3 minutes. It was not it was
over on that one. And then game three, I
just drew every single piece of removal
that I sided in and it was just cola
weeks hidden blade and she just couldn't
keep a unit on the battlefield. So I I
think overall a lot of decks that we're
seeing right now that are really good
are token decks because a lot of removal
hits like one thing or two things like
singularity. It's like they're not going
to spend a singularity on two tokens
normally or if they spend it on my stuff
I know when it gets back or I draw or
whatever. Um, but I think stuff that
really hurts it is like Bella's breath
obviously that hits a lot of stuff. Um,
I don't know. Tried the pre- regional
last night and it was fine, but uh I
don't know. We'll see if we can shoot
for a best though.
>> All right. Well, good luck with that and
thank you so much for the interview.
Congrats on the win and good luck in the
rest.
>> Thank you.
>> Now, we'll send it right on back to the
desk.
>> We're so back still here in round two of
the Las Vegas region qualify. I'm Pat
Time. That's Earth today. And I don't
think I expected anything that's really
happened so far. I'm glad I read enough
cards because we've been throwing some
curve balls as far as matches we've had
on feature so far.
>> Yeah, there's been so many really fun
decks between Rumble, Jinx, I want to
say Leona. Leona, like who would have
even expected to see some of these
matchups and so it's been so cool to see
really just the spice that are bringing
to Las Vegas.
>> It certainly is. And speaking of spice,
I have something that we have uh we've
teased you with for quite a few rounds
now. We once showed you Aurelia and
Draven as the upcoming match up. Well,
look, guess what? They're finally here.
It is Draven versus Aurelia. And this is
again, I will refresh you all. This is
an extremely unique take on Draven. I
don't believe triple detonate main is
standard.
>> I'm just going to put that out there. I
don't know everything about Draven, but
I'm going to put that out there.
>> Yeah, it's it's an interesting list for
sure. This detonate could be so cool.
I'm excited to see how it plays in this
matchup coming up. We do have Unveiled
Temple in this list as well, just like
we saw in the last game. And I think one
thing to note is the one spinning axe in
Maine. In the future games, we're going
to have to look out for both of them cuz
there's a second one. And there's it's
the reaction speed is just so nice.
>> There's pack of wonders in this
sideboard. That is one of my pet cards
from Origins. If you don't know what
that one does, you exhaust it. You can
pick something up and put it back in
your hand. So, if you pick up a scrappy,
you get to uh you don't get to draw a
card cuz it didn't die. When you replay
it, you get to draw a card. If you pick
up your Ezreal, you can replay it and
draw a couple cards. There's a lot of
cool things you can do with pack one. In
fact, if you pack one is a treasure
trove, well, that one's just a leave
trigger. So, you just get the benefits
of the treasure trove while still
keeping the treasure trove.
>> Yeah, and that treasure trove is in
main. I was interested to see treasure
trove there without Pack of Wonders
being in the main. So, we'll have to see
how that ends up uh playing out. I also
just kind of love pack of wonders in a
lot of these like purple decks.
Sometimes like the misfortune list will
run it to pick up the mind spplitter and
put the mind splitter back down. Pick
the vice and then you just have it
repeating over and over. We'll have to
see how that plays in this deck for
sure. But a lot of cool uh plays we've
seen.
>> Yeah, we'll talk about it more in the
games, but this is definitely what feels
like a really miracle shell. Kind of
pushed to the the extreme limit of the
idea, right? really trying to play all
the card draw trying to get through the
deck as fast as possible and then
recycle things and have just a really
robust deck you're consistently
recurring things from. We'll have a look
at the other side though because this is
a matchup maybe on this exact deck list
but a match up we are going to see quite
a lot over the course of the weekend. It
is Ireelia and this list looks great
very standard. We had a top four list
this looking very similar to what we saw
in Bolognia.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a really great
I mean I'm really fun excited to see
this matchup. We will have to look over
that sneaky deck hands. It's not uh
surprising to see it in this list, but
if we can get sneaky deck hands out on
that turn one, a lot of decks really
kind of want to get some early point
leads against Ireelia, and the sneaky
deck hands stops it.
>> Yeah, Dean's a fun one. Uh getting your
points and then kind of comboing off to
the end of the game is the thing that
generally wants to do, but I don't
really know what Draven wants to do in
this matchup cuz again, this is such a
different build of Draven. Again, plenty
of Draven decks do this, but this is
kind of the quintessential I want to do
this specific game plan pushed as far as
you can. So, you know what? Instead of
speculating about what's going to happen
in the match up, let's go ahead and
watch it. We're going to go down to our
feature match area and a match up we
expect to see quite a hit in round two.
It's will pull versus troop dupe scoop,
which is quite a set of words with a
bunch of in them. Going to put Obis
power here. Draven versus Ireelia today.
>> This is such an interesting one.
starting with both obla powers. Uh I
feel like often times you don't really
want that to happen. Um but so we are
going to be starting with our first
player with four runes potentially. Our
player going second having five runes
potentially. Not the counts you normally
see, but it will mean we could see
Ireelia really early. We could see a lot
of cards from Will. There's so many
different things that could happen here
with these two oblas of powers. So, both
players going to mulligan two cards it
looks like here.
>> And fist pump goes out. And the first
player is
>> we'll find out soon cuz they're going to
have four runs. It is going to be Draven
going first.
>> Let's see.
>> Doesn't get to draw card for turn. Feels
good. And let's just play this thing.
Yeah, sure. That seems good.
>> Straight to Draven. Uh we're going to
get him out super early. if you can win
those combats. Obviously, our leader
Draven is going to be so nice to draw
cards in those showdowns. But when
Draven Vanquisher comes in, if he wins a
combat, he gets to get a gear, a golden
gear as well, which is just so nice.
Start building those resources. So,
let's see.
>> Yeah, the second line of text on Draven,
by the way, not one to ignore. When I
attack or defend, you may recycle a uh
red power. Only red tower. If you do,
you get plus two this turn. Uh, I had
this happen to me cuz Jim Davis took me
out with this
>> because it turns out you get to pay this
every time Draven attacks or defense. So
if you get, I don't know, say fight or
flighted out of the battlefield after
Draven pays, Draven can pay again and
all of a sudden you have to deal with an
eight mark unit after getting pushed out
for the first time.
>> Yeah, it's definitely painful. And if
you're like defending as a a well with
him, you can just keep doing it as many
as you win. We do see that Silicorn
Herder coming down on troop side. Uh, it
will help draw those cards. And while we
may have had enough runes to play the
Ireelia, which is going to be, you know,
our endgame here, the thing is is that
you do not want to play Aurelia if you
don't have the cards to protect her.
There's only one Ireelia in this deck.
And if she dies, your game plan, there's
some options, but not many of them.
>> Yeah, certainly Aurelia is your best
threat. So, you want to try and protect
that one as best you can. We are going
to see Ezreal discarding a scrap heap,
though. So, again, pairing through this
deck at light speed. Cold shot also
going to keep chopping through some
cards. And we that die by the way that
is counting how many cards have been
played this turn. Why would that
possibly be important today?
>> Who I wonder if there could be a batter
battery
>> battering ramp
>> battering ramp. Uh but yeah, battering
ramp is so nice. We have so many of
these discount cards. We've talked over
and over today about how much
discounting cards can be powerful. and
battering ramp for as many cards as you
play the turn discounts I believe down
to one uh one energy. Um and it does
look like with three we'll only have to
pay two meaning that's not just a four
Draven threatening six it's nine
>> yeah conquered all the way to free but
two feels pretty good at this stage with
all of that might presented on the
battlefield. So, this is kind of the
thing that Draven does to you. Just
presents really good numbers, puts good
might on the battlefield, and ask you a
question. Do you want to try and
challenge me? Because if you do, and you
are wrong, I get further and further
ahead.
>> Yeah, he is so good at that, drawing
cards, generating gold. It he can just
gain such a lead. And I mean, Ireelia,
we didn't hit the sneaky deck hands.
We're already at one point. Still
corner. It will help draw cards, but
Ireelia needs to find a way in. and then
dance around the field to a win.
>> Have to respect troops bling. I will say
it's a beautiful looking deck so far.
These beautiful alt out runes. This foil
Stellin Herder. The boots are going on.
Aelia's popping. We're getting ready
just to draw a card here from the Stone
Hood. We already scored our point. We're
not getting over on the other side.
They're just going to get ready and
maybe think about ganking, I suppose.
But it's only five might right now. And
that's just the might printed on the
battering ram.
>> Yeah, that is not nice. But it does look
like a charm is going to come down.
There are no runes up on Draven's side.
So the printed cost at least for the
battering ram
>> is, you know, the same one, but you do,
I believe, only play a power for the
Draven plus notrect energy. So we could
still see him go to six. It looks like
that would not be the case. And uh
Draven will die.
>> Yep. Had the option and now going to
gank on over there.
That's five currently. Draws a card.
Going to need to play another spell, but
there's plenty of gas in the tank here.
Unguard
>> going to be the trick of choice here for
troop troop. And that's going to give
plus two to the lonely Stellicon Herder.
That's going to get a point and a
another card for removing and of course
a point for conquering. So very
efficient bit of uh movement there from
the Creelia player and that's exactly
what you need. When it starts going
wrong against Draven, it usually
snowballs out of control. That turn was
very well kept under control. Yeah, I
think we put Dven in his place a little
bit here. The Sailorn herder, but I mean
she is a five right now sitting in the
Obeliska power.
>> Pretty big.
>> I mean, good size for sure. Our player
does have Ezreal though able to discount
these additional costs.
>> We're doing it again. By the way, we're
putting the die out to see to indicate
how many cards we have played this turn,
which again battering ram to one is
going to be the potential here.
>> We have two counts though.
>> Cold shot going to get put on the chain.
I think troop asked just to just to hold
on a little
cuz uh is going to be a defy on the
other side.
So not wanting any more selection. That
also does uh turn off the count card I
believe for battleing ram. Yep. So it
does tick down. Troop does know how that
works. Very similar to Raven Bloom
student if you're familiar with that
interaction out of Origins. So you're
going to have to work a little harder
here at a battle ram. And in some ways
having a little die to remind yourself
that is good. You may have accidentally
tipped to your opponent that you have
another battering ramp. Or maybe you do
it every time and they just have to call
your bluff.
>> Yeah, you I feel like you'll have to do
it every single time otherwise it's
going to give a little bit too much
information. It looks potentially
deciding to move Ezreal. And we're
putting our three Ezreal up into the
Stella Corn Herder. We must have
something here. And it looks like a
Rebuke is going to come down here.
>> Kind of nice actually baited out the
Defy potentially. Oh, actually you can't
defy Rebuke. Never mind. that cost two
power. So, not even an option. Not so
fast turned off in some ways by tapping
your opponent under two runes. So, it is
going to work out. And of course,
Draven, the one thing that really makes
it sing is that when you win a combat,
you draw a card. And it turns out
bouncing a unit back to hand when you
have a unit there is winning a combat.
>> Who would have thought? But that being
said, it is so nice to get that draw.
It'll help us find more cards, the
pieces we need, maybe more cards to play
to discount other cards in our deck. And
so, it all comes together. so nicely
with this uh miracle drapment.
>> Yeah, Aurelia are a deck that really
commits a lot of power though when when
she does powerful things. Kind of saw
that with the equipment, the Aurelia
activation for the Stellicorn. So does
have room to replay the Stellicorn, but
just doing that now feels like you're
maybe going to be a little bit behind.
So curious how much Troop Duke wants to
commit here by readying again,
reattaching the boots, maybe rumbling in
cuz again when you choose wrong against
Draven, you get punished. So if you
cannot beat this Ezreal in combat, not
only you going to probably lose your
unit, but Draven's going to draw a card.
Yeah, it is so painful to lose a combat
here, especially when you don't think
it's possible. You're there with your
swiftness. You're like, I'm a five
versus your three. What's going to
happen? And nope. Rebuke takes out. It
looks officially coming in though. So,
we must have something to be able to
protect her hopefully. Does look like we
are currently just tapped out though.
We're going to leave in base.
>> Yeah, taking a turn off here. Not even
equipping with boots of swiftness.
Obviously, uh that equip can be a choose
effect for your Aurelia Legends. So, you
do kind of want to bounce around those
different things, but this is kind of
scary. I don't know how much removal is
in Will's deck. I don't didn't remember
it all off the top of my head, but Tra
Merchant's going to move in, try and
cycle through some cards here. This
Aelia is looking a little bit vulnerable
potentially over on the other side, but
if she lives and there kind of a setup
turn here for the Aurelia player going
to have a lot of action to dance over
these battlefields, as you so pointly
put it.
>> Yeah. Uh it'll be interesting to see
what she's able to do. Hopefully she
does survive the turn while she's
vulnerable here, but we'll have to see
if Draven can so deal with it when she's
moving around.
>> Here's we should probably read Ezreal,
by the way, cuz we are going to see him
a lot.
>> That is true. We've been talking a lot
about his discard. Yes,
>> but I think the one of the big things is
his optional additional cost. It gets
discounted. We now have two down, which
does mean we're going to get even more.
And so things like uh the accel
accelerates, the repeats, and different
additional costs like that uh are just
going to be discounted here for our
Ezreal. Both I mean Ezreal's just been
so strong in so many decks this set.
>> Yeah, Cold Shot definitely the one that
kind of most people think of, but lots
of different things with the repeat
effects that Ezreal lets you get a very
big rebate on. Four to two right now as
far as points go with Traveling Merchant
holding down the fort in the northern
battlefield. So Rileia is going to go go
ahead and say, "Hey, let's challenge you
and see if you can get away with it
all." Already has an extra might thanks
to her. When I ready get plus one or
when you choose me, give me plus one.
And awakening at the start of your turn
is readying, which I literally looked up
last night because I wasn't sure.
>> Yeah, it's crazy. She reads like a four.
You see her, she's a she cost five and
she's only four and you're like, "Oh
man, she's not even that big for how
much she costs." But the moment she
awakens, she is already up to a five.
And with this when you choose me or
ready me, give me plus one. You just
continue to grow her. We attach the
boots. She gets, you know, chosen again.
If you discipline her, she's not just a
plus two. On guard is not just a plus
two. It is so crazy to see her grow
because she can become monstrous.
>> Yeah. So now the thing is, are we
holding this Aurelia as we play this?
Replay the Silicon. Looks like we are.
So Aurelia currently a six at the
battlefield. Again, readying during your
opponent's turn. Not impossible, but a
little trickier. So it's just one rune
open here. There is a zas in play
though, so we'll have to see if this can
live through the fight. Either holding
at the battlefield, which would be best
case scenario, getting a point or just
getting pushed back to base with that
zas, replacing her potential demise.
Again, need to protect the princess here
on the Aurelia side as Draven is still
cycling through this deck.
>> Yeah, we have to protect the princess.
Zonas will do that, but we do still have
one rune up, meaning that there could be
things like defy that come down. We
could see things like onguard that can
make her I mean, she's a four. She's six
right now and it would make her up to a
nine. Nine
>> plus two plus one thanks to that early
attacks. A stack deck is going to
continue the battering ram counter I
guess we can lovingly call it. And again
will just trying to get through this
deck as quickly as possible. Not doing
nothing on the road to doing that I
might add. Like still playing units
challenging there trying to get Draven
triggers. Like you still play you know
regularish riftbound but when the game
gets really late that's when things can
get out of control. The question is, can
you actually get that late against who's
going to constantly put pressure on your
battlefield? And here's a Bushwack. This
means this turn is going to get quite
big.
>> This is going to be an interesting one.
Bushwack is a I mean, I like the card a
lot. It's a nice little red when your
friendly units uh they enter ready for
the turn and you can also get a gold
gear exhausted, which is so so nice.
>> Now, when would we want to ready units
on a turn? When would that maybe be
good?
>> H
>> Let's see. Maybe if we play some big
units that might want to attack, maybe
battering ram can come in ready. What is
this detonate though? You did mention it
earlier.
>> Took out the zas. So again, I did look
at this card and think, is this just a
card draw spell for Draven? But there is
a lot of good gear running around in
spirit forge and just even giving your
opponent two cards like hidden blade.
Sometimes that's okay because you kill
the single most important piece of
equipment they have and that zone is
just gone.
>> Yeah. What is this Ireelia going to do
now? Again, we still have one rune, but
the zona's was her trying to protect the
princess. It was that fell safe if we
weren't able to make give her enough
might to be able to survive whatever is
coming at her.
>> And Rosa coming in here. I have a
feeling we did not get have to pay very
much of anything with this big discard
pile.
>> Doesn't look like much got paid again.
Very aggressively cycling through the
deck. And now that six might plus the
three from the rumbling into this
battlefield thanks to Bushwack is going
to get readed. That's without the Rams
even coming through. There's so much
discounting that these decks do, these
miracle shells do.
>> And now going to challenge Aelia, who as
we noted is currently a six, but could
be bigger.
>> She could be potentially a nine with an
ong guard. So, we could see a trade, but
I'm not I mean, we would not be happy as
I to have that happen.
>> Yeah, you can see we're actually I think
counting exactly to those numbers,
thinking on guard, the most obvious uh
card being represented here by a troop.
>> Can't really can't play charm in this
spot. So, that's not an option there.
I'm trying to think what else you could
even have. I mean, defy is the kind of
the obvious one you think of, but that
doesn't matter in combat. That only
matters when, you know, spells are there
that you can potentially counter. And
there's defant dance.
>> Defant dance. I didn't even think about
it. Even though I've been saying dance
way too many times this turn, while it
does get plus two like on guard, it also
minus twos your opponent, which means
what was a nine is now a seven and we
are a nine.
>> And you get plus one. And that is an
effective plus five for a single energy.
And I don't know how that slipped my
mind cuz this is one of the reasons to
play a rail. Such a strong signature
spell and that is going to turn this
combat upside down for our poor Draven
player.
>> Yeah, it does look like we're going to
be paying for something here. So, it
looks like we Oh, it's the one I
mentioned earlier, which is our reaction
speed gear. We are going to try to
counteract that minus two. But again,
it's still only a trade right now. And
the problem is as well is while this uh
spinning axis is so strong giving plus
two if the units attached to dies and it
doesn't it's not attached to something
else that by the end of this turn it
will dissolve. I mean it'll be temporary
>> does have temporary unfortunately
actually gives us plus three which is
mental amount of I did not know that
number that was was that big. So
Ezreal's going to live. Ax is going to
get unattached. So we'll have to
reattach it if he wants to hold on to
the axe. But winning the combat, drawing
a card, and most critically taking out
the Aurelia, the one Aurelia that the
Aelia deck has.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely insane. I always
forget it's plus three instead of plus
two, but it's absolutely huge. And it is
going to be able to make this Ireelia
die. And we still get the obelisk of
power.
>> Got the point as well. Ezreal maybe
going to rumble on over and just uh try
and take another point. Get to six.
Feels like a pretty good number to be
at. stack deck instead. Going to take a
peek at those cards and see what we can
find on top. I see a battle ram. I see a
detonate that immediately gets put to
hand.
>> It's going to be so nice. It is
interesting to see the bing ram go away,
but we do have no runes up for the end
of our turn. So, when troop does play
this next one, he'll have all the
information possible of what could occur
to him.
>> Yeah, tough when you don't have your
biggest threat available. But this
Stellon can still get some damage done
with the boots especially can go around
drawing cards, finding pumps. the card's
going to get hidden. Wonder what that
one could be. But that's uh that Ezreal
in the back is actually not going to go
over and grab point number six. Deciding
that five is enough. Wanting to present
uh some might at the one battlefield
that we kind of forced to hold thanks to
the exchange that happened earlier
again. Threaten some Draven triggers if
troop does want to come in and then you
just hold back. Feels like the position
in the game is fine. Doesn't need to
push all the way to six and try and
threaten a win too early. Can get to six
next turn maybe from a hold or if you
have to just conquer to five it's fine.
I think in some ways taking a turn off.
Well, kind of cuz he had a massive turn.
Like Will's runes are just gone at the
bottom of the rune deck.
>> Yeah, this is kind of crazy. I mean,
Ezreal can do things with these like
lower rune counts cuz they're able to
discount so much, but sitting at one
rune, I feel like never feels good in
this game.
>> No, I mean, if if it if it wins you the
game,
>> you feel pretty good about it. But in
spots like this, we are still scrambling
for the final points maybe doesn't feel
so good. So, what's that hidden card?
We're going to move with this teleorn
and draw a card for troop. And are we
going to show our opponent a fight or
flight? That's the obvious one. There's
an on guard. Going to make you move
first cuz my unit's already bigger.
>> And it is fight or flight just like
>> the Ezreal.
>> Really? I think I saw that correctly. I
think he he played fighter flight and
tapped his Ezreal.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Looks like we're going to
defensively move back here. We There's
too many I mean it's like runes up that
we're worried about. You know, he may
spend a defy if he actually targets our
the opponent's card, but we are going to
take that point here.
>> I mean, Ezreal's pretty big. Has the X
there. So, six for the Ezel just on its
own. There's another one in the back of
course that can add this is quite a bit
of power, funnily enough for Draven,
despite all the runes getting recycled
under the deck. But Troop is getting
closer to kind of the magical mark of
points. Again, Aurelia is a deck that
when she gets the six, she's really good
at taking those last two points.
>> Yeah, she definitely is so strong at it.
And a lot of these decks that run like
ride the wind, hitting six can just be
so important. I did notice this Draven,
I believe, is not running a ride the
wind, but I see one in troop's hand. So,
it's something to watch for. If he can
hit six here, then we could have a
really strong turn even in the Draven's
turn.
>> Yeah. And again, readying the Hera,
sending it back to the other battlefield
thanks to ganking. And what did we just
say about six points being good for
Aurelia?
>> Crazy. It looks like we hit it.
>> Are we going to be able to move the
Stellon back or we just going to let it
hang out and hold already? Stellicorn is
three plus two plus three. That's six
might at that battlefield. Ezreal is
already bigger with the one with the axe
is looking pretty good. But Aelia does
have tricks. And there's one of them
going to try and charm a unit to the
battlefield cuz that Stellon already got
bigger.
>> Yeah, that is so nice. So, this charm is
going to be able to bring it in, kill
it, and hopefully if we can in before
they're able to attach it, that will
that threat will disappear as well.
>> I mean, you can attach cuz you have
power, I suppose, but doesn't feel good
to roll the axe over. Nope. Never mind.
Just goes away. Yeah, right. Beginning
of the turn, of course, the axe goes
away. No real window to reattach it. So,
bye-bye axe.
>> Exactly. And we have to really, you
know, worry here if we do decide to move
in one of these battlefields because
with two runes up that that uh ride the
wind is definitely an option. It does
look like we are going to be having
detonate come down again to take out one
of these gears. But
>> spending these these runes and making
what you stopping the ride the wind like
bringing it not an option is kind of
dangerous.
>> Yeah. And Will's digging. It just
detonated a treasure trove, right? You
do get the trigger from the treasure
trove and you get to draw two cards.
This is the thing I was talking about
with this where this is a really
interesting flexible spell in this
Draven build, but behind here I mean
absolutely threatening to win on troop
side even with not that many runes. That
Celicorn's going to hold for one and you
best believe it's looking to gank over
on the other side. So Will needs an
answer pretty soon and that could be the
one hiding a card at that battlefield
and redeploying a treasure trove. That
is basically I have a fight or flight.
Please do not have a counter.
>> Yeah, for sure. Sure. I think it's so
interesting that he just like let the
Ezreal move in um instead of like right
uh riding the wind over, but
>> I think we'll still have the option. We
show the fight or flight to try to push
this Ezreal back because Ezreal is no
longer at Obeliska power. That hidden
can't really be used and it I think it's
like dissolves uh and so we're able to
move on over and take the win.
>> Exactly. Correct. You in order to
control a hidden card, you need to be at
the battlefield where the card is hidden
and when you get pushed away, you are no
longer there. So that is a win for
Aurelia without Aurelia in the middle
point of that game. Very impressive here
for Troop navigating with a Stellicorn
Herder and a dream.
>> Stellic corn herder and a dream. And
they made it all the way to those eight
points going into game two. It looks
like we will be doing sunken temple and
temple. So very, you know, we are really
matching all of our battlefield today.
First the power, now the temples. Uh but
we will have to watch out I feel like
for those gears sim similarly how we saw
it last game or last round with the
built
>> players are going to put some cards
under their deck as we kick off game
number two. It is one zero up right now
for Aurelia. See if Draven can mount a
comeback with again this very draw heavy
build of Draven. Scrap heap. Not a unit
being deployed here on the first turn.
Going to draw a card and that threatens
a little bit more than it might look
like in terms of cards in hand. not so
good at contesting battlefields, but
maybe you don't need it. A sneaky deck
hand makes the way to the temple.
>> That is gonna be so nice for Aurelia.
That's exactly the start you want,
especially going second. Sneaky deck
hands is really going to put us so far
in the lead, even though it doesn't look
like it just yet.
>> Yeah, like we said, Aurelia, a deck that
once she gets the six, she can kind of
play to set up for the win, right?
There's a lot of powerful things you can
do, especially if you have enough of a
lead to to take some time and set up.
And Sneaky Deckan's the kind of card
that just gets you points early. you
kind of really want to, you know, get in
early on the battlefield, get to points,
and then set yourself up to win. Whether
that's with something like Draven,
audacious, some of the decks run Yasawo
for an extra point. Some of them just
want to kind of play all the way to six
and go from there. And for now, troops
happy going to get his point, retreat
the deck hand, and play the Aurelia.
>> Yeah, and we already two and now while
Draven hasn't even moved into one of
these battlefields, we don't have any
runes up to mention, so it's not like
we'll be able to stop him from moving in
this turn. It'll be interesting to see
how these follow-ups do uh do resolve.
>> Yeah, I actually guess I missed the pass
back after the deck hand happened here
cuz I was just a Draven go on Will's
side. So that is two points, one for
conquering, one for holding that Trup
manages to scoop up here in the start of
this game. And Aurelia, as we know, very
threatening whenever you try and test
the battlefield. I mean, Draven might be
uh tricky, tough to play against when
Draven's trying to force combat, but
Aurelia is really good at busting
through that.
>> Yeah, for sure. They were both kind of
play and go from their uh chosen
battlefields, but oh my god, we're going
to be playing Ferris War for Runner to
the Sunken Temple, which is threatens so
much might. And as we talked about
surprisingly in our Rumble game, uh he
threatens those two baby mechs later.
>> Yeah, this card's really high if you're
trying to hold a battlefield and make
things tough for your opponent. Ferris
for exactly the kind of thing you want
to be at. So that is 10 might as printed
on the north battlefield. Two more for
Draven if they want to recycle an angry
power on Will's side and Aurelia is
going to get one bigger. So troop is
this the turn you want to move in and
try and take out these battlefields
because again when you pick wrong
against Raven you get punished
>> that you do and it can really hurt
especially when it's to protect the
princess deck. Ireelia we were able to
win without her last game but we still
got a lot done with her beforehand. So
losing her if we do that first turn that
we play her will not go. Also like that
Will's taking sunken temple here. That's
another way for Aurelia to kind of get
through cards quickly. So uh you need to
do a little bit more work than say
something like Dreaming Tree, but in
effect the same thing once you send a
mighty unit over and Aurelia pretty
commonly mighty at different points
throughout the game. But the question
really is can we get to 10? We're
already at five. We got three more from
the two gear that are in play. Can go
again when we choose thanks to Aurelia.
I think there should be two more. So
already in my head I think we're above
10,
>> but I'm going to let Troop Duke show us
how it's done with that die.
>> 10.
>> Let's see.
>> 10. I heard him say 10. I got close.
>> And we do still have those two runes up.
If we attack by Ourel, we could use
Tuburn on guard. That' be plus two each
plus kind of plus three each with her
ability and or multiple other cards that
could really help us here. And even if
she does die, Guardian Angel is going to
protect her. Feel like we're setting up
a ready into gank angle here. So going
to go to the temple here. This is a
pretty free conquer. Going to take point
number three. And again it's 47. That is
10. There is a ride the wind available
here.
>> There is. Yeah, you are 100% correct.
And one thing to note is if we would be
able to conquer with the ride the wind,
she would be ready and protect yourself
at base.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We'd get a like one
bigger from getting chosen. just decides
to say go. Doesn't want to commit the
resources there. Again, it's it's 12
might at that battlefield. It looks like
10, but Draven can give himself plus
two. And I think in that spot with the
rune advantage that Will has and with
the the state the game is in, would
happily recycle one of his red runes to
to try and win that combat
>> 100 100%. Does we are going to get sill
of discord here, which is I mean always
nice in these miracle decks. I
>> Let's see.
>> They're going to use the power now. He
says floating one energy steal though,
but there's an Ezreal. We love Ezreal
and still of Discord. That is such a
strong combo. And if we can have
something like Scrap Heap to discard,
doesn't look like it will be, we're
still going to get to draw two here.
>> I feel like any card you discard and
drawing two feels good. You get to like
get a bonus card. It feels even better.
And again, that's the the version of
Draven that Will is presenting here in
this matchup. Lots of cards in hand
here, but the Creelia is still pretty
big and has that G hanging out on the
battlefield. So, not the easiest
princess to displace.
>> 100%. She is so strong for uh with with
Ireelia and all the gear she has
attached to her. Looks like we are
potentially thinking about retreating
potentially, but we'll have to see.
>> Yeah, behind on the race right now as
well. Aelia generally the deck that's
better at getting more points than you.
So, don't want to wait too long. Looks
like a scrappy is going to get detonated
here for three cards now.
>> Yeah,
>> that's troop says okay. Of course, this
can be defied, but can let this one go
and draw three.
>> That is so nice uh to get to draw all
these cards just from that one
>> one uh energy one rune. Um
>> this retreat
>> is that retreat back. We still do have
three runes up though. If we could find
some way to attack, but doesn't it
doesn't look like Oh, one. I'll put one
up.
>> Yeah. Again, I think happy to play the
slower game here in general. is this
Draven deck knows that the late game is
going to be pretty well in hand if you
can establish a pretty big presence. So
kind of let Aurelia do her thing for a
couple turns. You know, five points
doesn't feel so threatening. Six can be,
but Miracle Shells are the kind of decks
that will happily play from behind and
then go from there. So players looks
like they're just chatting about exactly
what resources happened, but Will knows
exactly what sequencing was made here.
Troop says, "Okay, just wanted to make
sure everything was uh was clear." And
then here's a battering ram which is uh
pretty big and pretty cheap.
>> Very cheap right now. That is for sure.
And it looks like after playing all
this, getting all this might developed
into the base, it will be time for
Ireelia. She is going to four. She could
gank to five. Uh but still just shy of
that six mark that we've been talking
about.
>> Going to draw a card of temple as well
though, which is nice. I believe temple
is when you conquer, you may pay one. If
the unit is mighty, you draw a card. So,
we're going to gank on over, get our
point number five, and draw ourselves a
card thanks to the sunken temple.
>> And I would say she's pretty mighty here
right now.
>> As you noted, it gets mighty when you
awaken her.
>> It's kind of a fun little mini game to
play. It's like what state is your
Aurelia in when you pass the turn.
>> That makes a lot of sense. And you
definitely, it seems like want to start
or end your turn with her not ready just
because of that. Looks like we are
potentially playing the discipline.
>> Want to move her back. That's the only
reason you would make this play. it. You
have a flash in your hand. That one's
pretty good at getting units back to
your base. So yeah, troop says, "You
know what? You go. I don't need to do
anything else right now. I'm currently
ahead."
>> She would feel very nice getting to
slash back later. And we are ending here
with six runes up, which is threatening
just so much mind, so many different
options to protect her.
>> A lot to think about for Will.
>> You're kind of forcing Will to make a
move first, right? Aelia is much better
when you know what is on the battlefield
you're trying to go go over and like
visit right uh you know you can do the
math you can see the might numbers and
say okay you have you know 12 there I
can make this a 15 pretty comfortably
especially when you get more resources
so just happy to hang back going to
likely flash this back when it gets to
that point cuz there's a lot of might on
side it's 10 again between the Draven
and the forerunner can be more if D
wants to recycle here thundersong going
to shutter any potential tricks here so
you have to retreat your right now
>> yeah run Here's Thunder Song is so
interesting. It is an ability that says
when you play me, your opponent cannot
play any more cards this turn, but it
does start a chain. So, you are allowed
to then
chain off of her ability. So, we could
see things like that flash that you
mentioned to bring her back to base or
if we have something else that we think
would help make her too large to be used
would also be helpful. Um but we'll have
to see what exactly happens that you
know troop expects will save this
Ireelia because that's his goal at the
end.
>> Most notably not so fast which I believe
is in troop's hand does counter
abilities but only if they choose a
friendly unit and unfortunately opponent
is not choosing it's simply saying all
of you don't get to do anything which
again relevant because Riftbound is also
a multiplayer game you can play not in
this context we currently have so
instead the flash does have to be
committed and it is free rain on the
battlefields now for Draven. Yeah,
Draven can make it a four. I mean, four
points here.
>> Maybe we don't have a huge problem with
that as we mentioned. Like, we do just
want to get to six. So, maybe we only
have to take one battle for the next
trip, though.
>> Yeah, need to at least get one, but
again, needs to continue to protect said
princess. Uh, resets the seal, by the
way, thanks to Veil Temp, which is a
pretty cute little interaction. Makes
his cold shot feel a little easier to
cast. In fact, between the Ezreal and
the seal, looks like it's not going to
cost much at all.
>> Let's see.
Looks like we have I mean a couple
option here. It looks like a Rosa versus
a fight or flight right now. I mean both
kind of different game plans. Rosa
helping us develop might fight or flight
helping us either defensively or
aggressively in some of these battles. I
didn't see which one we chose, but both
are really nice cards to draw into.
Yeah, chose a seal notably for the
second one over another Ezreal, which is
a pretty uh you would think those cards
would not be that close in power, but
seal being the more valuable one here
again, especially to get through your
deck. Being able to effectively mitigate
so many of your purple power costs uh is
a really powerful thing. It's why this
deck plays three seals cuz you have a
lot of costs you want to pay uh when you
get towards the end of your deck. And
again, probably going to take our extra
point here by rumbling on over, but just
counting the cards, making sure
everything's all right. And we will
check which card will got from the first
cold shot in just a moment. I don't
think it was the fight or flight,
>> but I don't exactly remember.
>> Another detonate. Looks like it is going
to be that tre.
>> Yeah, treasure trove.
>> So much value.
>> You get to channel the rune, you lose
from the power, you get to draw three
cards. It's great. Treasure trove does
it all.
>> That is really, really nice. That is for
sure. Yeah. Normally you see is when you
use the treasure trove like pack of
wonders, treasure trove, but detonate
kind of gives just more versatility.
>> Yeah, a lot of cards too for a very low
rate. So again, this a Draven build
that's very much focused on getting
through the deck at blinding speed. So
far so good, but will still a little bit
behind in the points race and the
Aurelia is just ever threatening. The
the hand of cards, excuse me, that Will
just fanned out is immense. There's like
12 cards in the hand or something.
>> So many cards. It's crazy. Ezra going to
take that point though and that's
probably going to pass on back to troop.
>> Yeah. So it looks like we are going to
go and tap out this entire turnover will
so there are no cards that he can play
during his turn. There's no hidden cards
as well that Ireelia is like watching
for. Uh but there is a lot of might in
the build temple. Sunken Temple though
on top it's only three right now.
>> Yeah, Ezreal looks a little easier to
take and again think getting one point
here feels pretty valuable. I don't know
how valuable getting two really feels in
this spot cuz you can hold with Aurelia,
but I just don't think it happens all
that often. So, I think you're happy to
do this, reset your Aelia back to base,
maybe leave her there if you don't think
there's going to be a whole lot of
threat, especially with the Aurelia
having a guardian angel you don't have
to worry about all that much. And then
you have to solve the puzzle of how do I
crack the 15 might or so that's on the
other side. In fact, it's 17 if Draven
chooses to get active.
>> Yeah, there is so much might over there.
It's I mean maybe there's some world
where it would be nice to remove some of
that might from the battlefield but
obviously multiple problems. Paris
Warrunner you're not really removing his
might. He's just going to get split into
two on base and also we can just wait
till next turn like you mentioned but it
does look like discipline's coming down.
I'm not sure if we're committing to
moving over or if we're you know dipping
our toe in and seeing what our next card
is that we'll draw. Yeah, you can do
kind of a fun little offensive trick
with guardian angel where you just pump
up and then send her over and then you
expect her to trade off in combo. But of
course when G's there you actually
trade. You get to replace her demise
with your gear which is a pretty good
exchange all things considered. Can't
win this turn most notably. So if troop
does want to make this play over to the
other side, it's just going to be to cut
down the battlefield to set up the next
turn. But maybe also taking this as just
an opportunity to retreat as well. But I
have to think if you're committing a
discipline and your legend ability,
you're probably going over there to do
some damage.
>> Yeah, for sure. And especially like this
turn, there are no runes up on Will's
side, so he can more reliably take out
some of these units just in case.
There's something he doesn't expect next
turn or if Will's able to leave up
enough runes to threaten.
>> Great point. No hidden card either, so
no fight or fight to potentially ruin
your day. So it is 4 10 12 + 3 15 might.
That is exactly the might total left
over on that battlefield. Of course,
Draven is going to get a trigger here.
Uh the champion, not the legend, if
that's a little confusing. So, can
recycle run and go to 17? But troops got
more things to do before that happens.
And I think if we're playing a card,
we've already passed on Draven
potentially getting might from his uh
attack or defend trigger.
>> It interesting.
>> Fight or flight instead going to point
at probably the fullrunner. Yep. Get
that out of here. I do not want you to
make extra mechs.
>> Exactly. and I'll blow up your board.
Thanks very much.
>> That's so nice. And we will be going to
seven. We still have three runes up as
well. So, while maybe we don't like to
hold, it's definitely an option here.
>> Yeah, this is the nice thing about early
when you put your opponents in this
spot, you're threatening to hold. So,
they have to come in. You obviously have
spells you could potentially trade off
here to cut down their force. And then
after G pops, you go back to base and
you're still back in the same spot you
want to be in, which is ready Aelia that
already got plus one from her own
ability that's ready to dance back
through the battlefield once more for a
double conquer. So I I said Aurelia
likes to play from six, which I think is
true, but this is the kind of spot where
you're also happy to play for seven cuz
you're kind of forcing your opponent
into a choice they don't really want to
make. I can't leave you here cuz you're
going to win, but if I kick you out of
the base, I might lose as well. So it's
kind of a tough thing here for Draven,
as powerful as Draven can be.
>> Yeah, Draven's got a lot to think about
going into this next turn. We obviously
do have a good number of runes. It looks
like we are at nine right now with
obviously two seals. There's a lot of
draw power in this deck from those deck
nades and his treasure troves.
Obviously, just the normal miracle
package as well. So, we could find some
pieces, but we are digging.
>> That's a rebuke. That's a very good card
to find. But I was going to say one of
the problems here is that with all this
card draw, you kind of have some dead
draws in a sense. Yes, the card draw
typically gets you more cards, which is
good cuz again, you're trying to get
through your deck, but I worry that
there's just maybe too many bricks,
right? Like there's only so many
treasure tes you control that don't do
anything when you're trying to kick your
off the battlefield that she's otherwise
going to win the game from. So we was
going to have to set this up here. Still
plenty of resources left. We're going to
send in a bunch of might first 11 over
here to this who is only currently a
seven eight.
>> Yeah, I think this is going to be so
interesting cuz to some extent here
we're saying try to make it bigger. Try
to do it and then the moment you do you
burn through those cards that rebuke
comes down and it nullifies it. Uh, and
we'll have to start from the beginning
and then those cards aren't in troops
hand anymore.
>> Yeah, again this G I think a worthy
sacrifice here just to pick off one of
the units.
>> Fullerrunner's trigger doesn't matter if
uh if you win. So maybe just killing off
the rune here and saying okay to the G
trigger just letting Aelia go back to
base seems okay.
>> Might be worried about a follow-up
spell, but Ride the Win is going to
happen instead.
>> I would like to go over here please.
Yeah, and Ride the Wind is such an
interesting card because normally in
Riftbound you you're only able to
conquer once well once for Battlefield
during your turn,
>> but actually the wording is during a
turn. So because we're moving over,
you're able to kind of,
>> you know, circumvent that to some
extent. It's not the same turn, so you
can kind of move a point. That being
said, we're at seven. So I'm not sure if
we'd be going to eight here or if we'd
be drawing a card. So, it's still the
same rules to the winning point where
you have to hold or conquer both
battlefields, which is technically
possible with a ride of the wind if you
get really spicy with it. You can draw a
card though uh once you do hit that
conquer. But the problem is this rebuke
is going to open up a window that's
still here and not so fast got tapped
out of here to play this right to wind.
I think troopers playing for the hold
and instead gets maximum punished as
Aelia gets returned to the hand.
>> Ouch.
>> So, five to seven.
>> So, no card draw. Still at seven, but no
hold win here. are really going to have
to find another window to try and win
this game. And there is now 11. I lied.
There is 17 might parked at the Veil
Temple thanks to Rasa coming down.
>> Yeah, that is a lot of might here in the
Veil Temple. That means sneaky deck
hands could take sunken temple. It won't
put us to eight points cuz just as you
mentioned, you have to hold or uh
conquer both sides at some point during
your turn to be able to win, but we
could get a card draw off of it. Uh
which would be really nice.
>> Yeah. Sorry, I should clarify. is hold
for a point or conquer all battlefields
for the winning point. You can hold uh
you can hold and conquer to win. That
was something that I remember messing up
a bunch when I was learning the game.
And you have to do something quickly too
though cuz the might totals are getting
astronomically high on the Draven side.
There's another rasa and a Vi just
hanging out. And that trash is full if
Vi wants to get real big
>> 100%.
>> Can only do it on Draven's turn. Can't
do it as a as a reaction or anything. So
if I mostly good on offense, which I
think is in the spirit of the character
from the game,
>> but I feel like Troop wants to try and
score the seventh point right now. And
again, you have to break through seven.
Is it really 17? It is 17 points of
might just at one battlefield. And
there's a bunch in base as well.
>> There is so much there. That being said,
Ireelia is in hand. She's not in the
trash pile, so we could see her come
back, but it will be a lot that she has
to get through. And but William is only
going to six six if he's able to hold
here. Meaning we do have additional turn
if D is
>> I see Draven Audacious in the hand.
>> Yeah, he's got two in the deck I
believe.
>> So that one can score the winning point
if you score the bonus point. The issue
is that Draven Audacious has to win a
combat much like Draven that combat has
to move. So you can't conquer and get an
extra point. But if that Draven is big
enough to take out that battlefield and
there's only two runes over on Will's
side, that extra point from the Draven
will be enough to win because all the
bonus point effects do count as the
winning point. That is one way to
circumvent the other the regular rules
of winning.
>> That' be really interesting. We'll have
to see if Troop is able to pull it off.
Um
I see a bunch of permission spells in
Troop's hand. See Defy, not so fast. See
a defiant dance. A lot of math is being
done here. How big is Draven? Audacious
production. Let's have a look at this
card because it may be the card that's
coming up because it is fan to the front
of the hand here for troop. Six energy,
one power, six might deflect. That's
fun. The first time I win a combat each
turn, you score one point. We're not
going to read the rest of the card right
now. Even though it does do some funny
things. If it dies, your opponent gets a
point as well. But if Draven can win
this 17 might combat over on the other
side.
Draven's going to win this game. And G
kind of gives you a second shot at
combat here,
>> but you do have to ready. And you can't
rerelia without conquering. So, how are
we going to rer the Draven
>> if you get kicked back to back to base
cuz right now 6 plus 3, that's nine.
That's not enough might.
Sneaky Deckand also can get involved.
Can't forget about that little card that
got played on on turn one, I think.
>> Yeah, he sneaky hands has been just
hanging around here, sitting in the base
instead of going for any of these extra
points since I really started moving
around. But we'll have to see if
Draven's able to do anything here. It
looks like we are moving both in. It is
currently
>> that's 11.
>> He has 11 right now. We do have three
up.
>> Yeah, nine on the Draven and two on the
deck hand. So 11 total rumbling into
again I will repeat this 17 on the other
side
>> and two runes up as well. Like fight or
flight. There's plenty of things. Rebuke
as well would be I think an absolute
blowout here if Will had it. There is a
not too fast in hand. can troop get the
Draven back into the battlefield cuz we
were making this play. The plan is to
ready rer the Dven and go back in and
Aurelia only readies if you conquer.
Currently not conquering. So what is the
plan?
>> It does look like we are going to be
hitting that spinning axes. It is a plus
three we mentioned earlier. So it's what
was what 16 might now 17 might 16 might.
>> It was 17. So 66.
>> Yeah. So we're going up to 20 might
here.
>> 618. 61 plus 6 is 17. So 20 now. A nice
even number.
>> O, that's a lot to have to deal with.
>> Ride the wind in hand. I'm so curious
what the plan is here. Defiant dance.
We don't have a way to get the Draven
back in. So, the plan was to win this
combat apparently.
>> So, what's your total win?
>> But, oh, that already seemed really
challenging.
>> 20.
>> Yeah, we're in a rough spot, it feels
like.
>> I mean, Will has used all the runes now,
so the tricks are on the table.
Looks like we do have one Defiant Dance
which will be able to bring the other
side down to 18 and us up to 13.
>> Yes, plus four on Draven cuz not like
Aurelia doesn't have extra text to get a
bit bigger. Maybe just trying to cut
down some might here and then go back in
the next turn again. Will's not going to
win on the crack back here. Only at five
points. So this could be a multi-turn
line here. You can protect the Draven
with the permission spells in hand as
well. So, this might just be like a, for
lack of a better word, a value Draven
charging on in.
>> It may be, but it seems dangerous,
especially if this Draven is gives a
point to the opponent. That would put
William or Will up to six points before
the end of his turn, which would mean
the following turn he could win with
eight points.
>> Yeah, only when you die in combat for a
Draven Audacious, not when you lose the
combat. And the replacement from G
should mean you don't actually die in
combat.
>> Oh, sure. G. Yeah, you can see the
players kind of explaining it to each
other now. So, I I believe Troop is
setting up a two-turn play here where
Odisha is going to go back in next turn
and try and make it happen. And we know
that if some sort of, you know, falling
star relates falling star shaped spell.
I don't know if Will has it exactly, but
something like that would try and take
out this Draven, there is a permission
spell not so fast to protect the Draven
from at least one of those. So, only
five points now for Will. We're going to
go to six from the first for staying at
the battlefield. But again, Draven is
really scary on the other side of the
table. Yeah, he is not nice to have to
deal with. Uh, so we are still at six. I
mean, we're at six points by holding.
So, we will not be able to win on this
turn for Will, but uh
we have a like threatening a lot of
might here.
>> You definitely have to stack one side as
well on the Draven play straven side cuz
you can't afford Draven an easy combat
to win on the other side at the temple.
So, sorry, at the sunken temple. There's
two temples in play. So, Ezreal going to
reinforce and draw some cards here. And
again, Rasa and Vi on the other side.
That's nine more might that can be added
to this battlefield. So 12, 15, 18 might
potentially on the table just from the
units we can see.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And there still
are four runes up. So we could
essentially see more more units or
spells as well.
>> Now counting the deck will know I've
gotten low. I know what spells I've been
recycling here. I know what I have
access to. You definitely don't want to
make the mistake of overdrawing your
deck. That is a disaster for the miracle
decks. But Cold Shock going to find a
rebuke. That feels like a pretty tough
thing for this Draven to fight through.
And Draven already had a tough road with
how big this battlefield is.
>> Yeah. And I mean, it's interesting cuz
it looked like he was avoiding the draw
cards. I saw Scrap Heap go to the
bottom. Uh I think I saw a stack deck go
to the bottom as well. So we'll have to
I mean see exactly what Will does, but
he is definitely avoiding the draw like
you mentioned.
>> There's Rosa played for not very much.
Lots of cards in the trash at this
point. So,
>> just going to say Will at this point
just looks to be counting the numbers
and be like, I just want to make the
biggest number possible. Go ahead. See
if you can get through this.
>> I think that's a great plan for Will
just to try to make the one side as
heavy as possible. Too much hopefully
for troop to deal with, but I has a lot
of might in hand from everything that
they do. And we'll have to see if
>> there's potentially some answer here.
>> They're drawing two actually here off
the conquer from the temple and one for
being at seven points and conquering a
battlefield. cannot win by conquering a
single battlefield, but you can get some
extra cards once you are at this point.
So, if troop does find a way to conquer
the other battlefield that is laden with
units, Aurelia is going to win this
match 2, but I do not know how Aurelia
is supposed to puzzle out of this.
>> Yeah, it is definitely just that a
puzzle. I mean,
>> charm would do it.
>> I mean, charm could potentially help us
here. Yeah,
>> that would win. You could charm a unit
over, have Draven win a combat, and that
gets that gets the point. M.
>> So, I guess that's what Troop is digging
for, but I don't think he found one.
>> It doesn't look like it's in hand just
yet. Uh, I don't see I'm not sure
there's any other way to draw either
here, but it looks like we are going to
pass. Will will only go to seven points
and there are no units in the base right
now. However, if he fight or flights or
flashes in these units back, they will
maintain being ready. That being said,
if Draven, if they move up into sunken
temple, there are still five runes. That
could be any number of might additions,
fighter flight themselves, or things
like that uh that can help troops
survive it.
>> So, this is going to be the last turn of
the game cuz both players are at seven
and Draven is threatening not only a
hold, which is kind of funny, but if a
combat goes wrong on the other side,
Draven's also going to win because he's
going to win a combat and score the
point on the opponent's turn. Vi also
has ganking by the way. So Vi might just
rumble on over there with the extremely
stacked trash we saw earlier. And that's
going to be enough might to win a combat
and unless
>> troop has a rebuke
>> cuz the rules that apply to Draven
Legend also apply to Draven Audacious.
>> Very very true. I mean that would be
absolutely crazy if so. Does look like
we are
>> called. Uh, so we have called shot where
you with the sil discord
>> only 10 minutes left. Like I don't
understand if we play a game three. This
going to have to be some turbo time from
these players.
>> Let's see. So many cards in hand.
>> The rebukeing hand for Will as well. So
even the Draven isn't that much of a
problem.
>> Just recycling a bunch. You do it one at
a time as Vice. So, I believe you do get
to order these in the way that you want.
VI is one of the few ways that this
actually happens. Typically, when you
recycle, you actually recycle multiple
cards at a time. And when you do that,
you actually do have to shuffle them.
You have to randomize them. VI is one of
the few cases where you can in effect
stack your deck. And uh this number is
about to be extremely big.
>> My god. Yeah, it looks like we are
putting uh
>> uh 19
>> 19. Yeah, 19 on her. And she's already a
three. So, it is going to be 22
threatening this Draven. Uh, I do think
there maybe a rebuke in hand.
>> I can't see it just yet. Could
>> be wrong, but maybe not. It looks like
we're resetting and going.
>> That's it. That's game.
>> We're going to play a third game here.
>> Let's see what happens. It's going to be
a huge question of who can get those
early points. Uh, cuz it will probably
go down to We'll see what happens. We
are going into ZH Warren and Dreaming
Tree. So, those scrap peeps could now be
discarded on Zon Warren. Yeah,
definitely one of the things with these
these decks that want to churn through
the whole deck and set up really big
turns in the late game is they can take
a while to get through the game. The
miracle shells can be a bit
timeconuming. You have to play very
rapidly. So, we'll see how rapidly the
players play cuz there was not a lot of
time left in the round. 7 minutes as we
move on into game number three. The fact
that there were even ways for troop to
win that game in the position he was in
is wild to me. But Will did navigate it
and we'll see which player is able to
take this final game. Guardian Angel,
the first play of the turn for Aurelia.
Yeah, it was interesting. Maybe I was I
don't think they molded anything. Maybe
I'm wrong on that. But we
>> might have just moved through it.
>> We might just jump through it really
quickly. But uh we do get the guardian
angel down, which is a nice early
protection for Ireelia when we get
Ireelia out. But we'll still need
another turn before Ireelia is possible.
It doesn't look like there's any units
in hand, which is going to be a problem
because Ezra can get early points with
this Ezreal. Yeah, always going to feel
nice especially again when there's
limited time in the round. So Ezreal on
board drew three cards by the way after
discarding a scrappy which is the
maximum value out of your Ezreal.
There's another scrappy to the zone wars
this time drawing yet another two. Going
to play this Draven go. We are playing
as fast as we can because we have to we
getting late in this round.
>> Yep, it's time to move. That is for
sure. With only 6 minutes on the clock,
>> uh we finally do hand but yeah I mean
that would be interesting to see played.
Looks like it's going to be Aelia though
for that five and we will be spending
one on guardian angel. It does give it
plus one might
see if you
Yeah, I think the protection is a bit
more valuable here as you noted like you
don't really want to play Aurelia
without being able to protect it unless
you're pretty confident your opponent
can't take it out. Maybe I think
considering Oh yeah, considering
readying now consideration.
>> Yeah, I was wondering if he was going to
ready it or not. He could. It looks like
>> um killed the Ezreal. We are at enough
by doing. There are no runes up on the
on the Draven side. So, it is possible.
>> I will say this play looks very safe for
Troop. The one way it's going to go
wrong is if there's a detonate on Will's
side cuz that guardian angel is
basically the only thing holding this
Aelia together.
>> It is right now. Uh I we are now we
discarded the deck uh sneaky deck hands
>> but oh my god we charmed up the Draven
and it's dead.
>> Very nicely done. Basically looks like a
removal spell and it's effectively that
in this spot. Troop passing back. Should
have two points I believe now as well.
Has hit uh sorry that's only one.
Charmed it over. I my mistake. So it's
one a piece but no units important here
for Will and Troop has kind of got to go
you know again both players have to go
as quickly as possible but Aurelia if
there's a deck that can win try and win
quickly it's probably this deck.
>> Yeah. And both players are trying to
move quick. We do see Ferris Warrunner
big might, but he's not able to move
into the battlefield.
>> I did see a rebuke in Will's hand as
well. So that really does not get
bounced, which I wonder if it's going to
be the difference here. But deciding to
commit the might to the board again
needs to have bodies on the table ASAP
because not only do you have to find a
way to
uh overpower your Aelia opponent, you
also have to just get points on the
board cuz if this goes to time, that's
going to be important as well. So we're
going to take a point for holding. G is
going to get equipped. Are we going to
ready once again with the legend
ability?
>> Yeah, we'll have to see. It would be
nice to get that extra point. It would
to officially put us two ahead of Will.
Uh, which is really important here, but
it looks and it looks like ong guard is
what we're going to do or use to do
that.
>> We're recycling our calm power there.
>> Yeah,
>> that's interesting cuz you can't bluff
not so fast or defy now.
A really is any Yeah, it really has is
it's any power, right? It's not it
doesn't have to be a specific color.
>> So maybe just a slight slip of of the
mind there for troop. I mean, if if he's
playing honestly with his hand face up,
he's just saying I don't have a counter
spell, which if you're will looking at
this board, you're like, great, that's
exactly the information I needed.
>> Yeah, that is for sure.
>> It still ahead though. So again, don't
have to worry too much as this forun is
going to go on into those wars. Yeah,
we've started our battering ram counter
as well. So, it is it is a threat uh
coming into the base or potentially it
holds on wards as well. I guess
>> again going to turn through even more
cards.
>> We'll actually have to pay the power
since we don't have a silver discord.
This game doesn't feel great, but I mean
this game we just got to move fast.
>> Yeah, again players have to be quickly.
And there's that seal you asking for.
>> Good enough, we'll say. Yeah,
>> do have to recycle for that one though.
But the next one you may be able to pay
for with your seal.
>> Exactly. Uh and so it does look like
we're going to be using the discord for
shot. More cards for the battering ram
and we'll be able to look at multiple
cards here. Hopefully draw two.
>> Ram is dangerously close to costing one.
>> It's four cards played on the turn.
Actually, that's it. It is costing. It's
been reduced for four.
>> Can't play for free by getting a five,
but getting a four is good enough. And
there's Ram number one. And here's ram
number two.
>> That is crazy. And the second battering
ramp.
>> Ram number three.
>> Oh my gosh. All three battering rams
down. I mean base completely developed.
And that battlefield threatening 11
might on Z warren.
And I mean the Aurelia I think has like
the options to get that big but the
problem is is there's a hidden card in
the dreaming tree now which does mean
like we can't move as freely as we'd
like.
>> We might be. That's so interesting here
cuz I think we're moving back to our own
base to draw a card of Dreaming Tree and
just get the Aurelia where she needs to
be which is on the other battlefield to
try and kill some of these units. That
is exactly the play that Troop wants to
make.
>> We hit discipline as well which could be
essentially a plus three for this
Ireelia.
>> See define dance as well. This turn's
going to get pretty sick I have to
think.
>> This is really nice. We are going to
move up into Zan Warren. We are
currently a seven going up to Yeah,
going up to 10. You're right. I almost
said two.
>> It is two. It's just one more after
that.
>> Yeah.
>> 9
commentate. He does it really great.
He's been counting like really uh really
clearly.
>> Yeah, he has been counting. So, making
my life easier just by copying the
homework
>> for sure. And then on guard comes down.
It does look like we're going to be
taking ZH Warren, but two more baby
mechs here. Both three might into this
Draven's base. There is so much might in
this base threatening just so much. And
here's another hidden card, which could
once again be anything. And this time,
Troops deciding, you know what? I want
to hold here. Come at me. I will happily
challenge you on this battlefield again.
Feels pretty safe with the G. Has a ride
the wind, a defy, and a defy dance. That
hand is stacked.
>> Yeah, and we do have two runes up. One
of those looks like it's going to be
Defy, but we still have that threat of
defiance.
>> Yeah, had to actually discard it to the
Zorn runs. The conquer trigger is not
optional.
>> So, that's going to be draw discard.
Decides it wants to keep the protection
instead of the permission spell. And
here we go. Might rumbling back on into
the Warren. It is 4 to2 right now in
points
>> as the players race to eight. And I do
mean race this time around.
>> Yeah. And we are moving up here with 13
might. There is currently only uh
>> five.
>> Yep.
>> Five on this Ireelia. Uh let's see what
it is. It looks like it is going to be a
fight or flight.
>> Back to base again.
>> Back to base we go. just like you said
draw a card from Draven
>> and then discard
>> Draven though is going to draw a card
and discard draw once again. So plenty
of cards being looked at here by Willard
>> and we are going to time.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Go to three. Yeah, I'm at three.
>> Let's see here. There's so much might
here in Zon Warren. It is the one bad
thing about moving back fight or flight
is that a lot of times you are just
going to have leave so much might there.
There's 13 to have to deal with and the
the second baby mech is able just to
move into Dreaming Tree. Rosa coming
down to fortify that side as well.
>> Yeah, trying to get a little bit of
clarity on what the uh rules at the end
of the round actually when time is
called. I believe the players are going
to place some additional turns.
>> It's I think plus three turns and then
you also have to win by two now.
>> Okay,
>> two points.
>> So, it is most points but you have to
win by a couple otherwise you're going
to get a draw which is maybe this early
of the tournament not something you want
to grab. Yeah, this early is not great I
would say, but that's why having these
like point differences is so important
for those Ireelia. Uh, and
it looks like Ferris 4Erunner also
coming down for that dreaming tree. We
are getting stacked on both sides of
these battlefields.
>> So, I believe if it's three additional
turns, I believe this is it's this is
turn zero. So, there's in a way going to
be I believe two turns each for the
players and Will's going to be the one
starting this here. So, Four to five
right now in points but Aelia ready to
go on the other side.
>> Four to five, right? Yes.
>> Let's see here. We are it looks like
ending our turn with six runes up. So we
do have to keep an eye on that as troop.
Um but we do have six as well. So let's
see.
>> And you can see that die will this time
not a battle room count. This is the
turn count. So it is three additional
turns and this is now turn one. So it
sounds a bit silly cuz it's an odd
number but an even number of turns.
Understandably, players each get an even
number of turns to try and round out the
game. And uh if I believe what you're
saying is correct, which I have to
imagine it is. Someone please correct me
if not, win by two or get to eight.
>> Yeah. Or get to eight. I mean, it's
possible. We're at five.
>> Uh and we are currently at six might
here for this. One from Ready and one
from that guardian angel. We have some
options not only to buff our might but
also to decrease the might of our
opponents. Zona is also going to be
helping to protect this Ireelia if she
dies.
>> Notably, I think with the way the turns
currently go, I think Will can win by
getting to eight points cuz not going to
have enough turns to do so at four. So
holding to six for your last turn is not
going to not going to get it done. But
we'll see. getting to six still feel
good as far as keeping the score even if
you again you certainly don't want to
get a loss. You don't love a draw
either, but want to at least kind of
keep yourself in the technically
undefeated bracket as it were. Defiant
dance coming through going to shrink
some of these. Aelia currently up to
nine it looks like and minus two is an
effective 11 we can call it. So between
the 12 and the 13 that's 15. It's going
to be 12 vers 11 if my math is sorry I
did that wrong.
>> Minus 2 is 13. Aelia is currently a nine
I believe. So defant dance number two is
going to have to happen here.
>> Yeah, we do have second one come down
now as well. Uh we got the draw on
dreaming tree from the first one, but
it's only once per turn. So we will not
see that from the second def definant
dance.
>> Interestingly shrinking someone
something on the other side. Now his
troop
>> 71 12 so far
>> we are down to
>> Ross has been shrunk once I believe has
a four on it. So maybe it's a little bit
more than I think that is 15 m.
>> No, you're not. I'm not bigger. You're
11. 11.
>> So yeah, was
>> Yeah, I think Troop realized that it
wasn't actually enough.
>> 11.
>> Yeah, Trip realiz. I think he made a
little bit of a math math mistake. 4 10
13. No, 4 10 13. So I'm 11 12 or 12.
>> Yeah, that's not enough. Shrinking the
other thing was not what you needed to
do. You needed to shrink something at
this battlefield.
>> I'm going to on the dance cuz I thought
you I'm going to dance. This is an ouch
for sure.
>> Okay. Um I'm going to
>> Okay, so trying to activate Aurelia now.
>> We are going to have those spinning
blades come down bringing up a plus
three. We do still have two runes up on
uh the Ireelia, but it's we're
definitely I think outiting here on Will
side.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> No, I'm up three. I was up one and then
you went one.
>> Is there anything I could bring out? I
mean on guard I guess would put us to
third. No, it would bring us to 14. I
don't think we have it in hand.
>> No, it would ride the wind and a charm
in hand right now for troop.
>> Yeah,
>> your charm needs you to really be on a
battlefield to get the most effect out
of it.
>> And I not going to currently be able to
make it.
>> So, looks like we are going to end the
game six points to five if this holds
and the point totals are correct.
Although I guess Triple got one more
turn, but not going to kill going to
kill a little bit here. So, I guess
there is still something to play for
here. But getting to eight is going to
look real challenging at this juncture.
Yeah, this was
>> Yeah, we could potentially bring
>> We still can like No, we can't ride her
again. Never mind.
>> 12.
>> Oh, in combat.
>> Oh, she Oh, okay. So, Wood would would
have read it, I believe. Got chosen
again by the legend ability, I think,
just to get just to get ready to get
Yeah, just to get ready to get an
additional point of might, but because
of the text on G, you do get exhausted
when you move back to a
>> That makes sense.
>> You're not able to be ready. Aurelia
can't be rated again. So, this equip is
not going to do it. Right. The wind
though
>> and that will be able to bring us back
into one of these bases. It looks like
we're going into uh the bigger base.
Ouch. Shuke is going to come down.
>> This is going to be I mean if it goes
through and I believe it should it
Aurelia is going to be going to hand the
combat win goes to Draven will be
passing to Will holding both of these
battlefields.
>> Yeah. And so again, if I'm correct on
how the rules are cuz it looks like the
players are talking about it now from
this point, Draven's not really going to
get any more points, right? Going to
hold for two, go to six, and then say
go, cuz there's nothing else I can do.
That's my last turn of this game. Aelia
has one room. Not really going to be
able to deploy much else on the back
swing. So I believe what's going to
happen is we will end this game with
Draven at six points and Aelia at five.
So then the question becomes, are the
rules in extra turns that you have to
win by two? Cuz if that is true, this
game is a draw.
>> Yeah. Hard to see.
But they're going to play it out. Seal
of discord going down.
>> We are turning three as well. It could
be another Ezreal. It is going to be
second Ezreal going to Dreaming Tree.
>> Yeah, just again discard some cards,
move some objects around. Have some fun
with it.
>> Always love that.
>> Just again the way this game looks like
to me is that troops going to be able to
not do too much. Will's going to
reinforce the battlefields just kind of
as a formality just in case there is
something that AI can pull out with only
three rooms. And I did get confirmation
this game is likely
>> Oh, it's five turns per player.
>> Oh, I thought it decreased. My bad.
>> Ah, okay. Now it's getting spicy.
>> All right. So, I think I think at one
point you were right. I think that was
the rule. But certainly as we are
currently in this RQ because we of
course getting the freshest information,
five additional turns. So, we've had
turn zero, turn one, turn two, turn
three, which is kind of going to be much
of a mness. And then we're going to pass
back. And Draven has got things at both
battlefields. And that is going to be
Draven winning, I believe.
>> Barely getting it. Oh, it is actually
three. Hang on a second.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it was a draw. Okay. So, let let me
bring it all back because
>> that was a long game. My brain is
adultled in the best way possible
because Rift is such an excellent game.
We're only two rounds in to this
qualify. I can't believe today. So, it
is only three additional turns. You do
have to win by two. And because the
points at the end of that all cuz the
turns all faded away. Draven was at six
points. Aurelia was at five and wouldn't
you believe
>> that is not that is only a draw when you
have to win by two.
>> Yeah, it is tragic that it's going to
end in a draw here, but hopefully
they'll still be able to pull it out for
the rest of the day. I think you do have
to make six and two to make day two. Uh
but we still have so many rounds left.
>> Yeah, we do certainly a lot of play for
both these players. Again, like
technically undefeated. You do get a
point for a draw. you're going to be in
maybe an interesting bracket where
potentially a lot of the other miracle
shells are. Cuz again, one of the big
challenges with playing a deck like
Miracle Draven or even these Miracle
Jinx decks is that you have to play
quickly because turning through your
entire deck and making these really
massive turns with 20 plus might just
takes a lot of physical game actions.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have to get through them in the
round time. That is something that is a
constraint put on you when you show up
to a competitive TCG event.
>> Yeah. And I think it's something a lot
of people are, you know, learning these
miracle decks. I think we're like 2 3
weeks into the set and so a lot of
players are still trying to figure out
how to play these decks in an efficient
enough time to finish in those 60
minutes plus three turns.
>> Well, we had a lot of rift man foiling
in those two rounds. So, I think the
players need a break and I think we may
do too. Don't go anywhere. There is more
RQ Vegas coming right up. We're going to
a quick break.
>> All right, I'm here with Alan ZQ, the
winner of RQ Bolognia. Allan, you toped
in Houston. You won Bolognia. Now you're
here in Vegas. Is there any pressure to
to perform to do the same that you've
done in these last two events?
>> I mean already in the Bolognia there was
a lot of people putting uh their lives
saving things on me and it doesn't get
any better after getting it down in the
Bolognia. So absolutely once you get
there uh the pressure is actually big.
Even though I have a pretty titanic
mental it can even get to me.
>> All right. That's fair enough. And
really, you've brought Ezreal to the
forefront of the meta. Now, people are
saying, "Well, maybe that's even the
best tech. Maybe that's better than
Draven." I want to talk to you a little
bit about Ezreal and how you were able
to put together such a dominant
performance cuz in TCG's dominating that
hard is very difficult.
>> I mean, since December, I was the second
I've seen Cold Shot, the second I've
seen Ezreal. I just put up the deck
together. Uh we've been play testing
over two months just tweaking sideboard
tweaking the main deck and once you
recognize the play patterns we could
lock in the list and I knew right away
it's just the best deck in the format
was surprised in the CN they didn't
manage to crack it and I was kind of
fond of it because it's just uh good for
me for the competition having a pretty
much secret deck that no one is prepared
for. So
I knew that it did heavily counters the
Draven and the version. So I was not too
worried about it and I just was just
hoping for to for people to bring it.
The only problem was Ireelia and then uh
it got solved by adding the vex which
ended up very good into everything just
running around the corner except like a
very heavy removal deck where you can
just sight it out.
>> All right. Well then I got to ask
Bolognia looked dominant. You're coming
in here again one week now. The deck's
no longer a secret. Are you still
thinking you can replicate that with
everyone knowing what's in your bag of
tricks?
>> Uh when I came for Houston, uh I posted
my list with the Kaisa because I thought
I'm not coming to Houston. Uh and
everyone knew the list and I managed to
top it. So, and I'm playing on just only
more consistent deck now. So, we've done
some uh two free changes as for surprise
factor. So, why not just run it back?
>> All right. Well, thank you so much,
Alan. Good luck. I'll see you in the top
eight. Yeah.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
on at your Nexus nights. Do you want to
get something that's a little more
competitive? Maybe get a buy for one of
these upcoming regional qualifiers.
Check out your local Summoner skirmish
at your local store. All information on
the QR code here on the screen,
ubsgames.com/riffbound-organized-play.
Welcome back folks to the regional
qualifier here in Vegas. My name is Jim
Davis Kasanova. How you doing bud?
>> Oh, I'm doing great. I'm very excited to
be jumping in the booth with you to
start covering some of these games
today. It's already been a very exciting
start. We've gotten a lot of great games
out the gates and I know there's a ton
more coming as we are in Las Vegas
playing Riftbound. This is exactly what
I want to see. Yeah, it's great great
stuff. A lot of cool matches too. We
have some cool mirror matches. Kind of
cool some cool legends, you know. But
now we're getting into the this is kind
of the meat of the tournament, right?
We're coming into round uh round four.
>> Three, sorry, round three. And uh you
know, this is where players are the rust
is off. Everyone's kind of warmed up and
they're ready to battle and kind of
getting into the middle parts of the
tournament where they want to make day
two. they want to get their best of, you
know, and this is where you kind of you
kind of feel the tingle, you know.
>> Yeah. I mean, after, you know, after
these next few rounds, you get to the
part where you uh you kind of lock that
day two, right? Like we're we're about
halfway to that lock in point, right?
You need to go 62 on the day in order to
make it into day two. And so, if you can
get that 3 0 here in round three, you're
halfway done. Halfway halfway to the job
being done.
>> Yep. It's it's tough though because you
don't want to get into that job done
mode when you're doing really well.
>> I've been that spot before. You're 3040
5. You're feeling really really good and
that one loss can crash you down. So,
lots of exciting games to play. What are
your what's your like what are you
looking forward to today? You know,
we've been watching some games so far,
but what's the kind of big overall
arcing thing that you're excited to see
in this particular tournament?
>> Look, day one for me is all about that
best of race. I want to see some of
these unique decks that people are
bringing and and you know, you get this
kind of glimpse at maybe some greatness
out of the legends that are not played
as much. And maybe if we're even lucky,
one of them will make a really deep run
and and and crack into that top eight
later on. And we'll get to see a preview
of that in some of these early rounds as
we're jumping around and seeing some of
these different legends. So, for me,
that's what day one is all about. It's
about seeing these best of choices,
seeing these legends that are less
represented, and seeing how they're
doing against the field. Yeah, my hot
take for this event was that uh a player
who thought they were in a metal card,
best of hunt, was going to have a really
good run, possibly crack top eight. that
were to happen, what legend do you think
it would be?
>> I think it's got to be something like uh
like a Lucian or it could be just one of
the purple decks that is kind of like
pseudo Dravening, you know, and then uh
kind of finding their way through. So
like a Jinx. Uh but even then, I think
uh Annie is one of those other choices,
right? So some of these purple decks I
think are the ones that really are the
ones that start to knock at the door.
But I think my maybe maybe hot take as
far as like the the the best of legends
is that maybe we get a Lucian that
actually gets to crack through. I think
that deck can be quite strong.
>> Cool. Oh yeah, it's interesting because
we're seeing with this miracle package
in purple, it's kind of a package that
transcends a legend, you know, where a
lot of things you've seen in set one
where, you know, you have your Kaisa
deck does kind of things, this deck does
that things, but having this overall
engine that can go into multiple decks
allows you to play that Jinx deck and
kind of use the engine in different
ways. So any deck that any legend that
can touch purple can touch that package
and kind of tailor it to their own
means, which is cool. You know, we see
if you're playing right, you play
battering ramp, you're playing so on and
so forth. So really, really cool stuff
and uh exciting to see for those
legends. And uh we're going to get our
match all queued up for you in a little
bit here. And um yeah, I mean you played
in Bolognia last weekend, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I absolutely did.
>> And uh no, let's go to our next segment
here. Check out we got some great merch
here on site. So if you uh you know, you
want to come down and check out these
events. There's a lot of cool things to
play, but cool things to buy, too. And
uh check it out right now.
>> If you're at the regional qualifier, you
have to make a stop over at the merch
store. They've got plushies like this
Mukau Allistar. That's my favorite.
They've got statues. I've been eyeing a
Leblanc that I want to pick up. As well
as they've got hats, playmats, card
sleeves. Make sure to pop in so you can
kit out your entire crew.
Aren't they some cool cats?
If you want to deck out your shelves and
yourself as much as you bling out your
decks, you have to make a stop here at
the merch store. Cool
stuff. Uh, the ears. That was a lot of
fun. Really, really nice. But I guess we
could play some more Riftbound, too,
right?
>> Yeah, I guess. I mean, I guess so. I We
might as well. Like, we're here. Yeah.
>> Yeah, that's fair. So, let's hop into
our next feature match here and see what
we got.
>> All right, so first up, we have Oh,
sweet.
>> Emotional. Uh, and we got a little
Lucian.
>> Yeah. So Mo a good old good old rifty
content creator also coming from Legends
of Rune Terra being a content creator
over there. He won a seasonal in Legends
of Rune Terra as well. So very
accomplished card game player and he is
going to be on that Lucian. I was
mentioning this is a deck that I think
sometimes can outperform its station as
a best of deck and it is often on the
back of this combo. The skyfall of Arion
with the Trinity Force. When you're able
to equip both of those to a unit, it
does give the hold effect of Trinity
Force onto your conqueror. So, your
conqueror is scoring two points instead
of just the general one. Uh, I did hear
a story out of Bolognia where someone uh
on Lucian won from zero points to eight
in a single turn with multiple Triforces
on board to go alongside a Skyfall.
There's a lot of combo potential with
this deck. What's really nice though is
the ability for the deck to still work
and function even when you don't find
the combo pieces together. they can
still lead to some very strong plays,
especially with you know the Skyfall
being able to give uh you know Kai'Sa
effect on hold getting you an additional
draw or the Trinity Force if you're able
to just kind of tank up maybe a Ruin
Runner so it can't be moved off a
battlefield uh and it can still get the
hold effects and score some points. So
there's a lot of ways to use the pieces
differently than just as the combo and
that can make this deck very potent.
Really cool and I I love seeing the
cards that can score points outside of
like the typical flow of the game can
really change things up. So that is our
Lucian player.
Then we're looking at Tom DTCG playing a
little earlier.
>> Yeah, this is a cool match up. So Tom
DTCG I believe is actually Thomas
Dowling who is a a flesh and blood
player who has made some very deep runs
in some callings essentially Grand Prix
equivalent or equivalent to this type of
event, right? This is this, you know, uh
thousand plus kind of player event where
you're playing 13 rounds of Swiss and
trying to fight your way through. And so
Thomas is no stranger to this kind of
event and playing Aurelia, which has
been, you know, one of the top decks in
the meta right now. Really, we're
thinking Draven, Kais, Aurelia, Ezreal
as kind of that top four. And uh this
deck is looking pretty standard when it
comes to the Aurelia builds. What I will
note is it is Sans's sneaky deck hand.
This has been a very popular deck that
we've had in these decks to try and get
you ahead on points early. and instead
we're getting the treasure hunters to
try and smooth out the rune curve
instead for Thomas with getting those
extra gold tokens. So, just kind of look
for that. If he can stabilize the early
game, uh he'll be able to try and come
back, but he's not always going to have
a point lead that the sneaky deck hand
affords and instead is going to rely on
the two drops for the early stage of the
game.
>> Awesome stuff. So, I love seeing the
melting pot of players from all
different games kind of coming in, see
her style shown here in Riftbound. So,
we got uh we see if we can get down to
our feature match area and see what our
players are up to.
All right, so we got uh Emotional on the
left, Lucian Purifier. Tom on the right,
we got Reaver's Row for Tom and Zan
Warren for Is it saying it?
>> Yeah, emotional.
>> Emotional emotional mo is fine. We'll go
with Mo.
>> Oh, Mo. All right, I see it now. It's a
few extra letters in there. So, um
>> yeah, so we got Zong Warren versus
Reavers Row. Uh pretty standard stuff,
right? Yeah, I think uh Zon Warren is
actually a little bit interesting for
the Lucian side of things just cuz like
that is the the discard and draw is not
exactly something you need. There's no
discard synergy in the deck, right?
There's no uh trash synergy in the deck
really. So, at the end of the day, all
this is getting you is filter. And that
is good when you're playing a combo
deck, right? You like to be able to
rumage. You like to be able to throw
something away, pick something up as
you're going through. And also, Red
Orange historically kind of rough on the
card draw. So sometimes you actually
will have just the empty hand and you
can get the the draw effect from the zon
warren when you have nothing to discard.
You still do the rest of the card and
you draw a card.
>> Yeah, these non-p purple decks looking
for ways to draw cards. They want part
be part of the game too. So couple
mullans here from both players going
down to get two cards going down each
and looks like we got Mo on the play.
>> Let's see if he finds a two. Doran's
blade's kind of the best one.
>> Okay, so the blade comes down. You
played in your pre-repped events. Uh,
Doran's Blade was that was a good one.
>> Yeah, great. You know, Doran's Blade
into Lucian Merciles, the exact combo
you wanted every single game, right? Is
very, very strong and we'll likely see
Mode just kind of following suit with
that exact combination of uh two cards
to start his game. I there are potential
fours that you would play instead of
your Lucian here uh cuz you can find
maybe opportunities to play him later,
but generally there's not much better
than just weapon mastering the Storms
Blade onto your Lucian.
>> Cool. So, Tom going to battle back with
a gear of his own. We got guardian angel
and now we see evolution weapon master
and an equip
>> and looks like a pass.
>> Yeah, lot of start for both players.
>> Taking a quick look at uh Mo's hand. I
did see he does have the Trinity Force.
No spear yet. Uh and he does have the
Brin here. Thundersong very important
for the matchup against Aurelia. She
wants to be able to play defensive. Look
for that hold, especially if she ends up
behind in points she needs to hold at
some point. And that's where the Brin
can really punish. So, we'll be looking
for that later on in this game if that
can come up for Mo and start to pay some
dividends.
>> All right, so seeing an Aelia over here
for Tom. We see an equip and then just a
pass.
>> Yeah, I like the equip. You need to play
around challenge in this spot. Uh if you
don't equip and Mo just is able to push
in challenge, kill Aurelia, the game's
over. Uh which is, you know, that's not
that's not ideal. You don't want the
game to end on turn two. And Aurelia has
to be very careful uh when she wants to
develop the Fervent early on, not to
just allow the game to just immediately
devolve.
>> Cool. going over uh Moe's way. Mo's
going to look at a pretty solid group of
cards here. Trying to get a little liloo
also.
>> Yeah, looks like a long sword. Maybe
that's a gem jammer. And then I'm also
seeing what I believe was a Yona. That
was some of the tech that I think is
kind of interesting. A lot of people
have felt this Yona card is not very
good in like constructed play. You might
think if you played your pre-ift event,
it's like, "Wow, this Yona card is
insane." It's amazing in limited. It
absolutely insane card in limited, but
in uh in constructed, it's not really
found a great home. I actually feel that
the Lucian deck is the best home for
Yona. You have all these extra weapons
to buff him up and create this kind of
no- win opportunity for your opponent
where you have a Yona with a bunch of
might that they can't hold against, but
if they leave the battlefield, then he
just gets to have the Yona effect. And
uh if you don't know what it does, he
when he conquers, he's able to deal he
conquers an open battlefield. He's able
to deal his might to an enemy at their
uh base. So very very powerful at kind
of creating these forks where your
opponent can't win by holding or by
retreating. get to have your cake and
eat it too. So Lucian's going to come
in, conquer Zan Warren. We see a hex
blade hexrier go to the bin and then
Lucian gets to to ready and pop right
back up. Little hit and run.
>> Yeah, exactly. And you know that's
that's exactly the kind of thing that
you're not allowed to do when your
opponent actually slams the Yona. So
Lucian gets to, you know, Exactly. have
both things. He gets to be the one who
gets to hit and run and then also is
having this, you know, uh, threat that
doesn't allow you to do the same. And
Aurelia is a deck that really likes to
do that same tactic of pushing in hit
and run, right? We're going to see
Trinity Force hit the board.
>> So, Trinity Force comes down and we're
going to see an equip. So, hit and run.
Of course, the Trinity Force wants you
to hold, but hit and run does not really
play with that yet. Setting up for the
combo a little bit later
and passing back to Tom. We're see that
first might off of the ready.
>> And now both players kind of like you're
saying in that kind of hitandun sort of
scenario.
Now,
>> Mo is up a point.
Okay.
A little bit of players checking out
here, making sure that the uh the buffs
are good.
>> Yeah, Fervent readies for start of turn,
gains one. Yep.
>> Uh we'll see as that continues forward
on the rest of this turn. I mean, really
charm is going to be the big thing that
maybe Thomas is looking for to deal with
this Lucian. It's really difficult to
deal with Mercless. Uh it just kind of
keeps run back and forth, but also even
a charm here. You need some backup with
it. Uh because of purifiers plus one
assault effect. Right now, if this
Lucian runs in on offense, it is like
plus 36. It it's a nine as an attacker
which is is not a small number.
>> It's cool seeing too decks that are
focusing on one single unit kind of
making it big. Both the champion units
kind of cool champion battles. So Tom's
think it through. We see a hand. We see
got some fighter flight and guard defy.
A lot of tricks in this Aurelia deck.
>> Yeah, you're all about the tricks in the
Aurelia deck. Uh this is not quite a
full protect the queen Aurelia that
we've seen in the past. Uh because we
did see, you know, the tide turners and
the uh the treasure hunters. So there's
a little bit more units than like a full
protect the queen, but it's not an
immense amount of units, right? It's
like three tie turners, three treasure
hunters, uh I think it was some amount
of the Stellicorns, so it was two or
three. Uh and then the Draven. So
there's still like a decent chunk of
units in this deck. So it does mean it
it can have this like draw the wrong
half of the deck and you end up breaking
on too many units. But as we see the
hand now, plenty of tricks flush with
the exactly what he wants to be playing
around this event.
>> Spells everywhere for sure. So Z warren
for Tom discards a fighter flight except
not so fast. adding that suite of
possible tricks, counter spells, and
interaction.
You think this game is gonna come down
to like one key combat?
>> Yeah. So, there's like two big things
that come down here, right? It's either
the one key combat or if Mo is able to
find the the spear and combine that with
the Trinity Force, he starts to just
completely outpace scoring uh and and at
that point, you know, it forces uh Tom
to go for a hold and that's where that
Brin here gets to punish, right? So you
kind of have that you you create this
position that Aurelia almost cannot win
uh if you're able to get the combo
online. Now the balance mechanic behind
that is now we have a you know red
orange which cannot draw in the same way
that purple does to find this combo
every game. So you you do have to kind
of lock into it if you want that part of
your deck. But it's one of the nice
things about Lucian is it plays well
without the combo. But if you find it
you often just get to steal some games.
>> That's great. So we see tide turner come
down do a little swap action with
Aurelia back to base and we see the
legend readying and really goes into
reaver's row. So a little bit of that
in-n-out action
and looks like that's going to be cool.
>> There's a charm. I was saying charm is
kind of one of the big things that Tom
would need to look for.
>> All right, so charm now really is
bigger. Thanks for moving around. This
doesn't work at all by the way.
>> Uh Reaver's Rose is going to trigger
here and uh Lucian is going to run home.
>> A little bit of a mistake from Tom.
Okay.
>> Or actually, sorry, no,
>> defender is going to be the Aurelia.
Apologies. I'm my mistake. Let me
clarify this. Let me clarify this.
Defender is Aurelia. Reaver's Row says
that it's going to target who is going
to run away. You choose this as the
Aurelia player. So, you choose Aurelia.
She gets a plus one.
>> Then, when you actually go to resolve
Reaver's Row, you decline the move back.
All right. So Reaver's Row is actually
just giving a plus one to Aurelia
Fervent here. Apologies for the
confusion earlier. So that is what we're
seeing from Tom. So he's actually using
the charm to the Reaver's Row in order
to buff the Urelia Fervent an additional
one to try and be able to push over this
since he's the defender after charming.
But that is meaning that purifier is
online for all this equipment. Meaning
this is 369 12 on this Lucian. That's a
long sword is the battle back and of
course some of these counter spells that
work there. Defiant Dance works pretty
good.
>> Yeah, Defiant Dance is great. You're
going to get the plus one from the
target onto Fervent, then the plus two
from the Defiant Dance, then the minus
two over to Lucian. So, this is a
fivepoint swing that we're getting from
a single energy and power and a single
card. Two more energy left for Tom.
>> This is big cuz this is a big combat.
Whoever loses this is losing a large
amount of resources and board presence.
>> Yeah. And at this point, you know, Mo
having nothing left, no energy to
continue to respond here. And Tom able
to get it done by pumping this over all
the offense that was there. It's a huge
turn. All the gear falls helplessly to
the ground. And we're going back Mo's
way and Mo's got to rebuild.
>> Yeah, very big to have to rebuild.
Fortunately, Yona has weapon master, so
that will mitigate some of the power
cost here, but he does have a power cost
natively on himself. So it it kind of
just gives that little bit of a refund
when you weapon master that in spear was
in hand. Ooh. So if that Merciless was
able to stick around, Mo was in a very
good position to just develop that,
attach it, and start going to town
looking for that combo to really set
things up. But now we're at the point
where it may just have to come down to a
Yona hitting the board. And then you
have to look to hold. And Purifier hates
holding. Purifier's text purely is
offense. It's gas. You get assault on
each of these equipment going onto your
unit. You get nothing when you're trying
to defend.
>> Yeah. And not lost here. Also, Tom's got
two points and also on both battlefields
potentially looking to hold as well. And
Mosa to think it through. Got to recover
from this. Uh kind of a tough combat.
Still plenty cards in hand. And there's
Leona.
He's going to hit the board. Just weapon
master. I mean, it depends whatever rune
he needs more. It seems like he's pretty
orange heavy in this deck. So, it feels
like trying to save more orange makes
sense. So, he's going to weapon master
onto the Trinity Force. Also, there's
the potential that he doesn't want to
burn runes on the rest of these equips
uh or even just some amount of these
equips going forward cuz he does still
want to establish the Skyfall of Aron,
the spear, which is going to complete
the combo. Combo not working nearly as
well on without the Lucian Merciles
though, who gets to keep kind of running
back and readying himself. It can be a
really valuable part of this combo. All
right, so back Tom's way. We got two
hold points up to four now a four to one
advantage and still plenty of cards and
hands stack deck off the top. So some
library manipulation, some uh some
tricks and of course tricks are good at
kind of keeping you in the driver's seat
when you're already in a great spot.
So got to think it through. We see Defy
not so fast.
Got the stack deck. Not a bad place to
start.
>> Let's read this card. This was the uh
the promo card at the pre-release. So
everyone had one.
>> Yeah.
>> Tom, did you play your pre-ift or not?
Surely you've seen this one usually in
the guise of being the chosen champion
for Aurelia is actually what we've seen
this a lot of. Uh but yes, it is
something you really need to understand
the text precisely, right? This is when
I conquer an open battlefield, deal
damage equal to my might to an enemy
unit in a base. This means if you are
holding at all and it conquers and even
if it kills your unit, it's not going to
get that YA effect hitting the back.
>> Correct. The the counterport here of
course is the assault. Uh, so kind of
puts a rock in a hard place. Do I try
and hold or do I try and uh
>> leave the battlefield open? So your
stack deck.
>> See boots of swiftness in the window.
>> A couple cards behind. Thinking it
through. Of course, these purple library
manipulation cards. The talk of the
tournament. This is the classic. This is
the set one one. You know,
stack deck. Very, very good.
>> Yeah. I mean, I'm looking at the shoes.
It's always really nice to be able to
put the put put some shoes on your fur.
get the Jays out and be able to run back
and forth between the two battlefields.
Uh so you don't have to expend as much
power pivoting using your your Aurelia
Legend. Uh it can just be very costly as
we see the rune count. You know, Mo has
had to spend a lot with the equipment
and you know he's played a lot of power
cost for units, but uh he's not behind
Tom at this point because we've seen
these activations of Blade Dancer and
it's just continues to kind of shred
through the runes.
>> Yep.
>> So I missed the carb was taking. Did you
catch it?
>> I missed it as well. We'll see in a
second. We'll find out. So, stock deck
will resolve.
>> And now, what is the next step for Tom?
>> It was the shoes.
>> Okay, the shoes are in. Take him out of
the box.
>> Yeah. Yeah, they're fresh.
>> They got wings on them.
>> They do. They do. Those are nice shoes.
>> Nice. Nice kicks.
All right, what is next for Tom? Ty
Turner's hanging out in Zon Warren.
Aelia is looking uh guarded up with the
guardian angel. So, some nice protection
there protecting Aurelia. Very, very
important of his deck.
>> Yeah,
it's this weird spot where it's like,
okay, you bring the TIE Turner home, uh,
Yona is just going to guaranteed to have
a target to smack, but I think keeping
the Aurelia at a base, not allowing her
to be a target for YA is uh is really
impactful. We'll see what Mo can put
together because he can catch up in
points, right? He's got the spear, he's
got the combo to combine. It means when
he conquers, he'll score two points
instead of one because he will get the
trigger from the Trinity Force as the
Skyfall of Aaron does make it so that
your hold effects are also conquer
effects and vice versa.
>> Ooh, big play here. Sabotage just
fantastic. And of course, we know
Skyfall is in hand. Of course, Tom does
not. So now Tom has to be under for the
rest of his sabotage.
>> Yeah, he has to consider this Defy.
there is a real chance that you just go
for it. That defy is actually the least
valuable card in your hand. And I think
that's probably true in this spot. The
hard thing is is there are uh very good
defy targets in the deck that Mo has.
He's got challenge. He's also got the
Relentless Pursuit. That's a very good
Defy target that you need to be looking
for, especially when we're starting to
talk about the combo. But he doesn't
know the spear's there yet. And also,
there is just kind of a point where this
sabotage makes it so that your Aurelia
can die. And that is what you have to
avoid. And that's where the Defy is
really trying to build a buffer where
you're going to have the not so fast,
you're going to have the uh on guard to
be able to just stay ahead of the curve.
>> How important is the information?
>> Incredibly important. Incredibly
important. Uh Aurelia is all an
information game. She's all playing
combat tricks. You need to know what
you're going up against. And that's half
of the card's text realistically for
Sabo. There could be a world where you
cast sabotage and they reveal all units
and you're like, "Wow, that was really
great. I'm not going to play around
anything. That's awesome."
>> All right. Well, here is a Skyfall. So,
we have this kind of Voltron all set up.
Got the Skyfall and the Trinity Force on
the Yodi.
>> It's huge.
>> Let's make it huger.
>> Yeah,
>> Blade stacking up. Sort of that Spirit
Forge theme. All about equipment. All
about stacking up. And here comes the
big boy into Zan Warren. Tom, what are
you going to do?
>> Yeah, he's just going to have to let
that happen. Get two points. We'll see
what the draw is. The discard feels like
it's going to have to be that Kai'Sa
almost. I feel like the Brin is so
necessary and then the wallup might even
just be uh deployed on this turn to
bring Yona back home. Uh I feel like
that is the major consideration here.
You don't really want to leave him
stranded. There's no tricks to protect
him and you don't know the hand cuz Tom
defied that sabotage. So you actually
don't know. So we're going we're going
to just cast this wall up and just bring
uh bring the Y back home.
>> All right. It's Ty Turner bites it for a
whole bunch of damage. Now Wallop will
look to Ready Yun.
>> He kind of once again with that hit and
run action going to get in and going to
get out
>> all readyed up and right back to base
and like you were saying. So now with
this combo in place scoring two points
in every combo other than one. Really
throws off the balance of what a normal
game of Riftbound looks like.
>> Yeah. So this should be putting Mo at
three and Tom now just going to hold the
five. uh as you know the the the two
points per turn trying to think if he
can really catch up. I mean not
completely right because Tom can
feasibly go to six here and with Tom
going to six uh that means there's just
really one more turn that Tom has to
double conquer and he wins the game. So,
while the uh the Skyfall is, you know,
accelerating the clock for Mo, it came a
little bit late because Tom was able to
kill that Lucian and just kind of buy
that extra turn where he gets ahead
while Mo has to redevelop and redeploy.
And uh because of that, the usual
advantage of actually finding the combo
is kind of taken away. And the big thing
for Mo is he got a three, not four.
Combo lets you win from four because you
just score both sides. You get two and
then two and you go up to eight. being
at three that doesn't do anything for
you as your opponent is kind of on that
quote unquote match point when you're
on, you know, or game point when you're
on six uh and you're playing a deck that
has a good time uh double conquering.
>> Yep. So, Aelia got to slide over with
the boots. A little bit of ganking
action. Going to see us on warns. Looks
like the discard was a guardian angel.
We see a ride the win in hand for Tom
passing back. Aelia kind of just running
through the whole game uncontested so
far. Has not been touched yet.
>> Yeah. And notably Mo equipping
everything except for the long sword
because he's guess what? Magic number
six runes. Breen here, thunderstorm can
be slammed onto the board. And then if
Tom decides to respond by buffing
Aurelia to try and get her above the
Yona, what can happen is at least Mo
still has this long sword to attach for
another plus three.
>> All right, so Mo going to think it
through. Pretty cool game here of two uh
just two huge units kind of slugging
back and forth.
>> It's interesting to see when you have
like the Lucian deck and these you know
red orange decks that are a little less
trick focused, a little more kind of on
the board numbers focused
>> trying to just get big.
>> We might be checking on the point totals
two. There we go. Up to three. Current
score. Mo's on three. Tom's on six.
for
>> the Britney here's not a very easy
decision here either actually the more
I'm thinking about it right cuz we're in
this spot where you deploy Brin you go
in you kill the Aurelia she has a
guardian angel yeah she's she's just
going back to base
>> and then now your yon is just there
hanging out and uh you have no runes
available so you're going into the next
turn with uh Tom fully tapping out
Aurelia at home
>> boots on she's got the Jordans
>> she just runs in you buff
get over the the Yona and then ready her
with Aurelia and move her to the other
side.
>> Yep.
>> Or even better right now with the noin.
You can just completely dodge
>> by just going ahead and slamming this
ride the wind.
>> Wow.
>> With the conquer and the hold. Tom would
be able to win here if Mo does not have
a way to repivot this Yona.
>> Wow. So yeah, no thundersong.
>> Ride the wind
the wind. see what uh Mo is doing about
this. Got to be something.
>> Yep. So Mo says ride the wind results.
>> All right. So Roy's going to pop over to
Reaper Row. We're going to see a little
buff action. We're going to see a point
up to seven.
>> Yep.
>> Now, of course, Tom's like, "All right,
yeah, it's all Warren is all yours. You
got it."
>> And first, of course, Mo's going to
finish this, right? He's going to go to
five.
>> He is going to draw it. Relentless
Pursuit lets him chase.
>> Does not look like he finds it. Now see
a wall up in there, but
uh
time to go up seven.
>> Not a bad place to be. I don't think Mo
can chase this down. He's got a wallup.
>> But the rally is going to be too big.
>> Currently.
>> All right, Mo trying to get out of this.
And is Unaw is a Kai'Sa also?
>> Yeah, it's a Kai'Sa, but all the
equipment are stuck onto Yon. So, even
with Kai'Sa plus Wallup coming down or
accelerated Kai'Sa, of course, she
doesn't need the wallup. Yep.
>> Uh there is no way to chase down the
Aurelia and that's just going to be
scooped up by Mo first game going over
to Tom.
>> Yeah, really cool stuff there. That ride
to him is huge. Uh big choice in the
thundersong, you know, obviously didn't
end up working out, but that's part of
the strength of the Aelia deck is
there's so many cool tricks, so many
hard things to play around. So, we're
player shuffled up here for game number
two. So, we're going to have Rockfall
path for Tom and the candle at Sanctum
for Mo. Rockfall Path.
>> Little spicy, huh?
>> Talk to me.
>> Yeah, I mean uh it's not one we see all
the time in Aurelia, but this is uh this
is going to be the one where you cannot
play units here. Okay,
>> so this doesn't allow a lot of these
decks that want to maybe reinforce and
look for a hold against Aurelia to
actually do so. Um it's also weirdly I
mean there's like some small niche cases
where this just prevents people from
sneaky deckhanding. So Aurelia we almost
never see playing this because they're
often playing sneaky deck hand. Why
would you put rock hole path in your
deck if you're playing sneaky deckand?
But of course we know Tom is not. So,
uh, it denies some of that like early
scoring opportunity if the, you know,
Candlelet Sanctum maybe were were to be
occupied. And then really it's just
preventing, uh, players from kind of
going for that really big hold. Uh, it
also has this like niche spot against
some of the Aurora decks where it
prevents, uh, the Dead Bloom Predator
from getting slammed there. It's not
really that relevant in the current
meta, but it can come up. It's It's not
impossible that it would, you know, have
that effect.
>> Cool. So, we got both players developing
here with a a gear. We got a little
hexrink interaction. We gota's hourglass
more protection for Aurelius. Both
players getting set up. I imagine the
candle with Sanctum's goal similar to
Zan Warren kind of kind of deck
massaging kind of looking for the right
pieces.
>> Yeah, it seems all of it actually Mo
very heavily invested in finding his
combo and he did in that first game,
right? So often times that would just
lead to the win, but you know, as we
were talking about early in that game,
if Tom gets to find the charm, that's
the opportunity and it was exactly that
that made all the difference in game
one. And I think it's about the same
when we come into this game too with Mo
getting to be on the play is does Tom
find a charm at some point before Mo is
able to kind of get everything the full
engine set up because that can just make
all the difference.
>> All right, so we got five runes for Tom.
Really is hanging out and of see look
like a Draven in there. A couple tricks.
We got Stellicorn Herder. Some nice
tools.
>> Yeah,
>> Roy looks pretty good.
>> Hourglass affords the luxury. you're
safe. If challenge or anything tries to
come through to take down your art, so
you're fine. It would have to be two
removal spells, which is, you know, I
think asking a little much of the Lucian
deck to try and make happen. All right.
Well, let's see what Lucian's coming in.
Start the turn right off the bat with a
uh trip over to the Candleit Sanctum.
Going to be a point. Going to be a
little bit of deck manipulation. Top two
cards. Take a peek.
>> Let's see what we got here as the
options.
A couple room runners in Ann, I think.
>> Yeah, I think that was a sideboard
piece. Or no, no, those were in the
main. Yeah, he had the run in the main.
>> All right, so both go to the bottom.
>> That won't be until next turn, of
course. And then six
runner. All right, so unargetable.
>> Yeah, my favorite thing with the candle
sanctum, right, when you're playing
these kind of more combo oriented decks
is you look at it and you say, are these
my combo pieces? Uh, no. Okay, does this
win me the game right now? Uh, no. All
right, bottom bottom. Nice binary
decision. Yeah. Yeah. It's it's very
quick. You know, it's it's real nice. Um
lot a lot more difficult when you're not
a combo decker. You know, the theelia I
would say like if Tom conquers handle
it, you know, maybe there's some more
thoughts that have to go through your
head at that point. But for Mo, it's
like well combo piece. No. Uh winning
the game right now. No. I already bought
him.
>> There you go.
>> Got to plot out is this counter spell
going to be relevant in the next two
turns? What kind of trick do I need?
What kind of mix do I need of spells?
>> But here comes Ale and Candle it top two
stack deck and a defiant dance. That's
pretty good. I usually never say no to a
defined dance.
>> It's quite nice.
>> I'm pretty happy about that one standing
on top. And honestly, the stacked can
kind of stay there, too, because you
know that that could be anything. Yep.
It could even be defined dance
>> or a stack deck
>> or another stack deck
>> or a boat. So, here comes the herder.
>> And looks like that's going to be a
pass. So,
>> string attack
>> like when you Sorry. Right here. Like
when you draw your card. I just want to
let you know that because they're brand
new.
>> Okay.
>> Um do you want to get a judge?
>> No, no, I don't care. I'm just letting
you know.
>> Making sure everything's good on the
table.
One
>> of the fun parts of playing a card game
is there's more to it than just the
game, you know, as far as how do you
handle your cards, where do things go,
communication.
>> It looks like Mo was just pointing out
it seems like the one of the sleeves
maybe had like a the new pack of sleeves
like had a string that ripped off it or
something. And he wanted to let let uh
let Tom know that, hey, one of these
cards might uh end up being marked. And
it looks like they're just just
adjusting with that now. It's very cool.
>> Good sportsmanship. He's like, I don't
even want I don't you don't have to
clutch. Let's just, you know, see if
they'll fix it and go. Good
communication is key, you know.
>> Okay.
>> So, we're gonna get the sleeve fixed up.
Our table dojo will help out. Make sure
everything's looking nice and we're
going back Moe's way.
>> Sorry. Yeah, I just got my
>> Going back Moe's way. There we go.
There's a drop.
>> All right. Well, there's a combo piece.
>> Okay. Little Relentless Pursuit ready to
go. Looks like we also have the Trinity
Force No Spear. So, missing a little bit
of the uh the win from four combo. May
maybe I should take a second to just
fully fully lay out that combo for me
through it for everybody. So for the the
Lucian combo, what you want to be doing
is you want to have the Trinity Force
out. Uh because that says when I hold, I
score a point. You want the Skyfall of
Arion, the spear out cuz that allows
your hold effects to happen on conquer.
And then Relentless Pursuit is going to
allow you to essentially have that ride
the wind effect, right? You get to move
to another location, but it also has the
additional text that says when you
conquer, you may return the unit back to
base. And so when it's with Lucian
Merciless, you'll get to conquer one
side. When he conquers, he's going to
ready himself. He's going to come back
to base and then you get to send him to
the other side. He conquers both. That's
four points scored between all of that.
Which, you know, you add an extra
Trinity Force, you get a couple extra
points. You know, it can start to really
stack up. But realistically, getting to
four points in a deck that's playing
Lucian Merciless on turn two, not that
difficult. And then it's looking for
that finisher when you can just end the
game, steal the game once you've reached
four, and your opponent often is not set
up to handle that.
Okay, so we can see Lucian coming in and
coming out. Mo goes to Trinity Force
also up in the back row alongside the
rune runner.
So Rununner being able to not be
targeted is great with the equipment,
but does it like slot into the combo? So
not for the combo, but it gives you that
other mode. You know, I was talking
about how this deck you you can't just
rely on the combo uh combo with this
deck. It just would not work. You can't
find it consistently enough in Orange
Red. It's just not really feasible. But
the deck can still function with just
some of the pieces, right? You can
either hold with Skyfall on Kai'Sa and
you're going to get to draw uh when that
comes through if you're able to kind of
take that opportunity or I think
establishing Ruin Runner with a Trinity
Force on a location becomes very
difficult to move sometimes, right?
That's seven might that you cannot use
spells or abilities to interact with.
You actually just need more might than
that Ruin Runner or else it's going to
hold and score an additional point. So
that's where I kind of see that making
some waves, especially into the decks
that rely on spell removal in general.
You're looking at your Ezreals and your
Kaiisus. If Lucian can just establish a
Ruin Runner with a Trinity Force, it was
very difficult for those decks to
actually handle it. Good stuff.
Stellicorn Herder coming in. We're going
to see a draw on the move.
>> A very potent draw engine for this deck.
We see a handful of cards. It was six or
seven cards. Pretty good amount.
Tom at three, Mo at two. And now we see
Moe's board is getting pretty scary. You
know, we saw last game was kind of all
about one unit that kind of got lost in
a big combat. Now we see multiple units
for Mo. Multiple gears ready to go. A
lot of runes, a lot of cards in hand.
>> We see a stack deck. It's like hard
bargain, not so fast. And Adaptatron.
Adaptatron going to be a very nice
sideboard piece for Tom here. when it
conquers, it's able to destroy a gear
and then gains a buff. Uh, you know,
these gear are core to the strategy that
Lucian is trying to to make work.
Whether that is comboing off and having
the Trinity Force and the Spear both on
board or just to leverage Purifier. I
mean, you're just getting rid of more
value than any other deck would be
getting. But when I look at the board
position, I think Adaptatron is going to
struggle to find some really good worth.
And it's possible that Tom instead is
just going to look for more spells. I
didn't see the take. Yeah, I could see
the Adaptron pick, but I'm I'm not that
excited about it when I look at the next
few turns for Tom. I think it's more
likely if I want to develop a unit, it's
going to be Draven. And from there, I
use that extra point to continue to stay
ahead from Mo if I'm able to win combats
with Draven.
>> Yeah, it was a hard bargain was was
chosen. I kind of agree. The Tron seems
like it would be just a few too many
turns down the road.
>> Yeah.
>> So, here comes Draven and we got Hard
Bargain in hand and two runes available.
Zna still in play, too. and we're going
to see it pass. So, fireworks here on
Moe's side. A lot to work with. Uh, a
lot of units, a lot of gear, a lot of
runes, decent amount of cards in hand.
We'll see what the next step is.
There's a draw. Let's take a peek.
And first draw, the spear is exactly
what he wants. We know he didn't have
one in hand, at least from the early
stages of the game.
He had a candle at trigger, but it was
bottom bottom.
>> Yep. So, this draw is going to be
completely cleared. Relentless Pursuit
still nice as a potential way to punish
if Tom tries to go too aggressively on
offense. You can also use it the same
way purple decks use the wind. Kind of
counteract someone going for a conquer.
>> If you're looking for some draw, Kais is
not a bad place to start.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we're going to see Kaiser pop over.
Kai'Sa pop over to the Candlewood
Sanctum where we can see a draw and a
few uh little searches. Search first.
Top two guards.
>> See if we get a spear. I see a long
sword.
>> Yeah, other ones.
>> Bit of a mystery to me.
>> Nice and hidden. Yeah, look. Yeah, I'm
excited. I mean,
>> baited breath.
>> Didn't just slam it. So,
>> yeah, if it was a spear, I think we
would just immediately see it just on
the top. This is going to be bottom
bottom.
>> The shuffle needs to the bottom. Mids
going to the bottom. So, Kaiser draw off
the top.
>> And that's a spear.
>> Oh, there it is.
>> Look, that's what I'm saying. Is it a
combo piece? Is it winning the game or
not? All right, bottom. So, there's four
that got sent to the bottom and he finds
a spear. Would not find the spear on any
other battlefield here. Maybe minefield,
but you know, that's a little that's a
little risky.
>> Looking great. All right, so is it combo
time?
>> Uh, yeah, I think we can actually play
it out. It will be able to go all onto
Lucian and that is going to be able to
push up to five. Still an awkward break
point, right? It's not quite where you
want to be, but realistically on a
double conquer on the next turn, you
still score three, right? go to five and
then you can go to seven.
>> We're going on the rune runner.
>> How do you feel about this?
>> Okay. Well, no, it's still fine, right?
Cuz you're going to five
>> and then the Ruin Runner uh if if it's
able to go home afterwards. Um or it
dies either way. Uh actually, no. This
makes a lot of sense. Okay, so you send
the Ruin Runner in, you make it an
annoying thing for your opponent to
remove. They're gonna have to use spells
in order to remove it on the next turn.
And Tom is not at uh in any way looking
to win the game in this spot. He's at
he's at three points. He's not winning
the game right now. So Mo gets to go to
five on his next turn. That's past four,
is it not? He gets to equip these onto
the Lucian and he has the Relentless
Pursuit to kind of make it happen. He
can, you know, run into one side,
conquer, score two up to seven and then
transition to the other side with the
Relentless Pursuit and go up to to nine
points, I suppose, and win the game,
right?
>> We have graphic for that, right? With
nine.
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that this this turn was
predicated on being on three, not on
four then, right? They're saying most
saying I'm at three. I can make this
play and set up for next turn and in a a
great spot looks like.
>> Yeah, cuz if we're at four, he just goes
for the win here. Uh and uh you know, of
course being starting the game at or
starting the turn at two, uh he has to
score first with the Kai'Sa anyway,
drawing the cards. So, he's not quite
able to get there, but the relentless
pursuit is just in hand ready to be sent
uh alongside having these equipss. He
doesn't care if if Tom can deal with the
rune, that's fine. You just unequip it.
It goes to the Lucian afterwards. But
the the big thing that I want to drive
home, Ruin Runner is a nine and cannot
be targeted with spells here. Palm has
to spend energy in order to push over
this or has to give up a unit by sending
multiple things in right now.
>> All right, so back Tom's way does have a
hand full of three defanting dances.
>> Yeah, see rebuke defiant dances
discipline. So defy in there also. So
what is the does Tom have counterplay to
this combo? If Tom has the pass here,
what's the counterplay?
>> Uh he's got an in rebuke. Okay,
>> I mean that's immediately that that
that's it. Stop it in the tracks. That's
why it could be really nice when it's on
a rune runner, of course. Uh and and if
the rune runner survives, you can
actually do everything with the rune
runner. The the fact is though is this
rune runner will not live. Uh that is
just never going to happen. Tom is never
going to let this runer live. I think
for Mo, uh you know, putting it on the
rune runner is understandable in this
sense because he wanted to be able to
like have it unequip and kind of move
around, cascade, put some pressure. I
think he may get punished here uh
because of the fact that he will not
have the rebuke uh the the answer to the
rebuke available um in it being equipped
to a ruin runner. Uh oh, he's got one at
home.
>> Mo did slide in. It's like a ruin
runner.
>> I didn't even see him play this.
>> Yep. So, just stuck that guy in there.
>> What am I talking about, Jim? He's got
another ruin runner.
>> Ruin runners for days running all over
the place.
>> So, yeah. So, he doesn't even need this
to go on Lucian. It's going to be a
readyied ruin runner. Um and since it's
readied at the start of the turn,
Relentless Pursuit uh either requires it
to be a Lucian or to be readied at the
start of the turn, right? uh or else you
can't go to both sides. And so since the
rune runner is ready, you'll just run
in. You'll conquer one side with all the
equipment. Cannot be rebuked and then
you can uh just go ahead and relentless
pursuit to the other side. So the answer
is not able to answer because it is
going to be attached to a ruin runner
instead of illusion. Now of course face
up. Tom can see the run. So knows what
it has to be prepared for. We're going
to see Defiant Dance shrinking Kaisa
down setting her in. Draw on a card and
that's a point. And that's going to be a
little candle trigger here as well.
Oh yeah yeah yeah. Sorry.
>> And uh see a discipline and a is that a
fighter flight? Unfortunately can't
target that rune runner. Yeah. I I I
want to say there's actually this really
cool idea that can exist for Mo is if he
can find a way to get his Lucian off of
the board before going on offense on the
next turn. The Diviant Dances won't have
an enemy target uh that they can
actually do to get the minus two. Uh, so
it's like very tricky, but I don't think
there's going to be a real way that he
can make that happen without Thomas
being able to just like kind of cast
those defined dances in advance and try
and protect against this combo from
winning the game. All right, so Draven
comes in. Draven's been buffed up big
time.
>> Takes out the rune runner and we're
going to see some points right here. Up
to six.
>> Draven also one of those extra point
cards. Goes cuts both ways there, right?
What's what's Draven up to?
>> Uh, Draven right now is a 10. I'm not
trying.
>> I mean, like, what's what's the hero?
>> Oh, what's the what's the
scoring points? Now, you're scoring
points.
>> All right. So, Tom, again, we're runners
there. You know, orange and red are not
the trickiest colors. A lot of times it
is kind of in play. It's kind of here's
my stuff. Can you beat it? That's a Mo's
saying right now. Tom going to hide a
card. There was the fighter flight,
right?
>> Yeah. Hidden fight orflight. This denies
the ability to just kind of kill off the
Draven to score an additional point, but
uh you know, we've got the combo on
board. Five is is not a a point total
that you're kind of beating the break
point. The Draven does not matter in
this equation.
>> Um and as we talked about that
relentless pursuit is just so massive
here. And really now the answer uh is
not rebuke because we do have the ruin
runner as you pointed out for me. Uh it
it is in fact defy is really the way
that you kind of have to look for it to
try and deal with the relentless pursuit
because you can actually stop the Lucian
from conquering one side. You just
cannot stop the ruin runner from
conquering.
>> All right. So
>> or you can't do anything.
>> You can't do anything actually. So
really the answer is you're not allowed
to do anything.
>> Uh yeah, Brin equip this both on to the
rune runner. That locks out the defy.
That locks out the rebuke. Uh what it
doesn't lock out are the defiant dances
which can be cast. However, you can't
target the ruin runner which is the
thing that is going to be equipped and
be the big might focus. So really your
best hope is you can somehow stack this
Draven to be big enough that Mo can't
outmite you. However, each of these
equipment is going to be plus three
because of purifier. So we've got 3 6 11
that is going to have to be stacked
above. And that is if Mo has no other
thing in hand to continue to pump
alongside also playing out uh the uh
Relentless Pursuit, which might not even
necessarily need to be played in this
spot because he can still conquer one
side with Lucian and then conquer uh up
to eight uh from conquering with the
Ruin Runner uh in the event that he just
needs to do it in that way. Especially
with Brin coming down, the math will
just be, you know, he'll just be doing a
math puzzle at that point. There's no
interaction available from Tom,
>> right? So Tom thinking is through.
Obviously you want a tough spot to be
when you're facing down the thundersong
and deciding what spells you want to
cast preemptively
>> before you've been silenced. So Defiant
Dance going to come in.
>> We're going to see plus two and minus
two. Where's he going to go? Still
figuring that out. Looks like plus two
to the Draven.
>> Yep. Always minus two Lucian here.
>> Yep.
And define dance number two
run it back. So Draven's uh decently
sized. Perhaps not enough. We'll see.
Two dances.
>> And that is it. The song has been sung.
There is nothing else for Tom to do here
but sit by and watch and see what Mo can
put together. Well, now it's just
deterministic, right? Cuz we said it's
11. As long as Mo can find it, right?
You know, we said we said 11 onto the
Ruin Runner. If you're able to just run
the Ruin Runner onto uh the Draven, he's
only a 10. Uh, and funny enough, that
that does score three points. Uh,
however, it will only conquer one side
cuz you'll actually get the uh the first
two points first, and then you'll get
the point for the the conquer at the
end, right? So, then you'll go to eight,
and you'll actually draw a card from
scoring from seven to eight. You still
have to conquer the other side. So, you
will have to conquer both on this turn.
You can't quite just get it from uh
running into the the rockfall path.
>> All right. So, Mo
>> going to find the path. The force is
going to go onto the Lucian.
>> Interesting. I'll go to four on attack.
>> So they will possibly maybe trade here
and they get the equipment back for the
next attack.
>> So we got
>> minus four and we have one and two with
two assaults. All right. So we've got
three, four, five, and then do you go to
the negative on the base
of a unit?
>> You can go to negative as long as the
the card does not say you may not go to
negative.
>> All right. Well, that's a conqueror.
Herder down. Motus six.
>> Force pursuit.
>> And here comes the pursuit.
>> Yeah.
>> I'll attach the Trinity Force to the
runer and move it up here.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, force goes over runer
>> coming in. D isidden.
>> Uh-oh.
>> That hidden card's going to go away,
too. Firefight not be able to cast. And
that'll do it. That's a nice setup there
from Mo.
>> Yeah. And there's the combo, the power
of it. The Ruin Runner very nicely
positioned in this game. Uh because we
know Tom had the rebukes. I mean, he had
the ways to deal with this. The Brin
able to lock everything out as well,
right? Two different kind of spell hate
uh cards being able to come out. Clutch
and often you wouldn't think of Ruin
Runner as a card that feels that
important into Aurelia, seeing as how
she's mostly focused on uh might and
just kind of buffing up her own units.
But, you know, Defiant Dance that can't
target. Fighter Flight that can't
target. The Rebuke that's not going to
be able to target. There's actually
quite a few hits that it's going to work
out for.
>> Yeah, cool way to fight back. You know,
obviously you see a lot of rebukes, a
lot of fighter fights in various decks
and finding the ways to beat them is a
really cool way to attack the metag
game. So, we're going to go to game
three. We got sunken temple for Mo and
the Dreaming Tree for Tom. Tom will be
on the play. I can only imagine.
>> Yeah, I I I have to say you can't be too
mad if you're Tom. Sunken Temple often
finds its way into Aurelia decks. Uh
really easy for her to get the draw off
that and she really likes being able to
find additional draw. Uh, you know, Mo
on the same kind of vein is is really
enjoying some contemple cuz he's always
going to be, you know, above five might
with an equip on Lucian. He gets to
draw, keep looking and digging for those
combo pieces. However, I will say the
dreaming tree not going to give him as
much love uh as he's not targeting his
units that often when he's going uh on a
battlefield. There might be the
occasional punch first, there might be
the the relentless pursuit, that kind of
thing, but not often that you're going
to get the draws. He's going to just
start the game with a Lucian Merciless.
>> All right, so Merciless down. We saw no
play for Tom on turn one and just going
to be a herder on turn two. So Lucian's
down. This has got to be a great start
for Mo, right? Yeah, it's generally nice
to to start out with just, you know,
going second, Lucian doesn't hate
anything. You know, you kind of just get
to play out the the Merciless, get in
there, try and score some points, get
the ball rolling. But I think for Mo
when you look on the other side and
while Tom skip turn one, that's kind of
normal for Aureliaex often. And seeing
turn two herder is not your favorite
thing in the world. Like you do not want
to see the early decks hitting her right
out the gates, getting probably one
maybe two uh card draw uh from it and
just continuing to dig deeper, having a
lot of you know tools to deal with you
going forward as we do have Mo getting
to equip ready. He is going to get to
draw off of sunken temple if he wanted
to as well. Uh and it looks like he did.
Yeah, he did in fact draw.
>> Yeah, these battlefields doing a lot of
work for Mo. I mean, again, it's a color
combo, not known for its card draw, but
Battlefield to kind of shore up those
weaknesses. And uh Luchi comes in, gets
the point, gets the card. Going back
Tom's way. Now it's Tom's turn to get
some cards.
>> The herders going to move into dreaming
tree. Taunt's hand is a bit disgusting.
Uh he's got this herder going into
Dreaming Tree. He has two flashes. Um so
when Mo tries to stop this Herder, uh it
is going to be flash, draw one for
Dreaming Tree, draw one for Stellorn.
Stellicorn already drew running in. Then
on your next turn, Tom's going to be
able to run back into Dreaming Tree,
draw again with Stellicorn, and then
have Flash back up to continue to draw
more. So, we're going to see the whole
library, the whole uh deck in Tom's hand
in the next uh few turns here, it feels
like.
>> So, I have seen earlier before lose the
game with so many cards in hand. Is that
is that going to matter as much as far
as what Mo's doing getting on the board,
you know, as far as stopping Mo? We saw
Mo able to kind of circumvent a lot of
the cards that were in Tom's hand with
various effects. So, are the cards that
important in his matchup?
>> I think so because the might values are
so high. So, you actually do need as the
Aurelia the ability to kind of like hand
dump a good amount of these reactions
into your fervent to make sure that you
can ever look for a hold. Uh cuz
conquers are usually going to be fine.
Like you you can just outstat the
illusion on conquers, but on defense is
a lot harder. So, being able to have
kind of all these options in your hand
are big. Now, what I will say is is to
your point about, you know, seeing the
Aelius lose with a a big hand of cards.
You know, Britain here is still a card
that exists and that is still a way that
this Lucian is looking forward into the
game going to find an answer, find a way
to actually deal with this. Uh, but Tom
able to even develop fervent and hide a
fighter flight. So, instead of the
flash, it's, you know, flash at home, he
had to pay a power and you just do the
same thing.
>> Sure. But was able to develop the early,
which is great. So, fighter flight on
the Herder
>> and Herter's coming home, drawing a
card.
>> Then we'll get Mo the point. Uh but hey,
that's uh that's two cards there with
Dreaming Tree and the Herder. So, as you
said, those cards are piling up.
Pressure on Mo to kind of get things
going then, huh? Yeah, it really is up
to Mo, you know, find the combo, get
ahead. He's currently ahead on points,
right? He's first to two. Uh he's not
going to go to three, but that's that's
fine, right? You know, uh we're just
looking to go that 2 4 68. Both of these
decks are very much 2 468 decks, right?
They're not looking to kind of
incrementally gain points. They're
trying to beat you over the course of
four strong double conquer turns.
>> Um, and so in that vein, Mo kind of has
the the lead in a sense, right? He he's
at two first and he's going to be able
to start doing that. So Tom at some
point is going to have to look for a
hold and that's where Mo looks to kind
of win the game is force Tom into a spot
where he has to look for a hold and you
get to slam the brain and you get to try
and run away with it.
>> Okay, so Herder comes in for some more
cards and there's more cards than I can
count in. It is it's off the screen. I
don't even have to like look at the
hand. I we'll just assume whatever card
we think he might need, he probably has.
>> That's a really coming in also coming up
temple. It does have the uh the one plus
plus from the being ready. So, it is a
mighty unit. Can draw a card up at two.
>> Tom said he doesn't have enough cards.
>> It's Tom wants some more cards. You
know, hey, I mean that is a thing that
can be done here. And uh it is going to
be done. So, what's better than having
nine cards in hand, 10 cards in hand?
>> Oh, well, he didn't have a guardian
angel yet. So, you know, I guess he
needs that. You know, I guess that's one
He's going to hide his hourglass though.
>> All right. So, hourglass important and
going to pass back with a bunch of runes
up here. Now, it's it's too early for a
thunders song, right? Like even though
it all the runes up, it could stop
interaction this turn. You want to kind
of save it for the key turn, right?
>> Yeah. I think that would be big,
especially if uh you know, as if Mo can
start finding his way towards uh the
combo. uh if you're able to kind of set
up the equipment on the board and then
get to four points, then on your your
you know combo turn, all you do is just
jam the thundersong and then what does
your opponent do? They they actually
can't do anything and that's just going
to be the game. But I think the struggle
for Mo here is he really wants to get
four. And as I mentioned, Tom needs to
set up one hole. He's behind on the
tempo, right? Mo's at two, he can go to
four here, Tom at three. Uh but he's
behind. If if they go back and forth
trading two points per turn, Mo wins.
Um, and so holding up all these runes,
forcing Mo to now be in an uncomfortable
situation if he doesn't have in his hand
good answers to try and break through an
Aurelia. It's going to be difficult. And
realistically, I don't know that there's
a a combination of cards for a Lucian
hand that is letting you break this
Aurelia Fervent that is standing on a
sunken temple with six runes up and 400
cards in hand.
>> There are a lot of pump spells in Tom's
hand. So Mo says, "You know what? We'll
uh forget the early for now. I'm going
to hop on over tree where the Stella
Corner herders hanging out and see
what's going on there." Lucian's total
power we got. We have three, four, five,
six, and assault. Seven, eight. We had
nine total power. Is that correct?
>> Yeah.
>> No, we believe the combo's there. We
There's a spear in hand. Uh, and there
was enough runes to actually play spear
and equip it on this turn to go to four
theoretically. But the problem is is
Stellicorn can outbuff the Lucian
potentially.
>> Mhm. Here's Defant Dance. We're going to
see a plus two and a minus two.
>> 72. Is it 7 to five? 177.
>> Was I miss what they were saying there?
But there's an Unguard also to go up a
little bit bigger. Unsurprisingly,
>> now it's seven to seven.
>> Okay. Unsurprisingly, uh Tom has a lot
of action.
>> Oh, I got so many cards. Discipline on
guard.
>> Bigger and bigger.
Now it's Mo's turn. Mo's got a long
sword.
>> All right, not bad. That's a plus three.
>> Yep. So, we have two on the base, then
one on the assault from the purifier
legend. And stack it up.
All right, what's next for Tom? Again,
if you're Mo, you can't feel great here.
Tom says so many cards. It's just hard
to not have the uh keep the chain going.
There's discipline.
That
>> means that here's another one. Have fun.
Catch.
>> Draw another card. And now we need two.
We're in double dice territory, folks.
That's a big herder.
>> Yeah. I wonder if there's consideration
to try and pivot this over with the
Relentless Pursuit, but even then it's
like there's a hidden card, so you can
kind of just get pushed if you do that
and it's not going to be incredible.
>> It's a way out or at least burns the
hidden card, too. You know, it does feel
like the when you have a big combat like
this, the person who loses that combat
is in big trouble. So many resources
were spent on the Lucian, equipping it,
playing this long sword,
>> but all right, so Lucian goes to the bin
and uh rune runner is here. Can pick up
some of these uh these gear and get
quite big and be difficult to assail.
But man, the runes are are flying right
now
>> for uh for Mo.
>> Down to three.
>> Hold on. Just launch. Okay. make it
four.
>> Okay.
>> Just got to just got to prove me wrong
in the booth here, you know.
>> Yeah. Just deciding whether or not to do
the long sword was in the middle of it
there. And now just going to relentless
pursuit because I guess the idea is Mo
does not want to leave this uh stranded
at a battlefield. So
>> yeah, okay. You don't have to announce
targets, right?
>> Okay. So
>> like you have to announce, but you don't
have to.
>> Now, how does targeting work for this as
far as the choices being made by?
>> So you do have to pick an equipment, a
friendly unit. Uh and then uh I believe
uh you have to just pick the location,
right? So those are the three things
that are in targeting. And in fact uh to
to the chagrin of many Lucian players,
you do in fact have to have an equipment
uh to target to cast your relentless
pursuit. Uh so here Mo is is selecting
Ruin Runner, long sword. And I have to
imagine we're still going to the
dreaming tree would be the idea, but the
defy is just going to come down and deal
with this.
>> That her still massive, right?
>> Yeah. Oh, that's true. Yeah, the herder
is still massive, so it would have to be
to some.
>> The dice were removed, but those buffs
are still there. Uh, that thing is a a
very, very mean herder. So, we're going
to see a defy countering that. And then
we're just going to see an equip. And
kind of a sad pass here. Um, a lot of
things went wrong there for Mo. Not not
pass. I'm sorry.
>> Passing into combat at the sunken
temple.
>> So, Hourglass Aelli will back out and Mo
gets a point as a consolation prize, but
that was a pretty devastating turn.
Yeah, and now Tom just gets to have full
runes into shields down Mo. Uh, with
just this one unit on board and Tom with
infinity cards in his hand still, I
think the odds of Fervent being able to
deal with a Ruin Runner is going to be
pretty high at this at this stage of the
game.
>> Yeah, really does stack up pretty well.
Uh, so let's see if uh Tom's able to
pull this one off with this multitude of
cards in hand. And unfortunately for Mo,
you can kind of see on the face cam,
arms crossed, you know, kind of all
right, what do you got? Except my fade
here. Stellicorn can also draw more by
just backing out.
Tom's on four. Mo's on three. Again, on
those odd numbers are tough.
>> So, Herder backs up, draws a card as if
Tom didn't need any more cards.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, was it Defiant Dance, too? Oh, boy.
See, I I I'm thinking I'm wondering if
there's a world, you know, considering
Tom keeping so many runes open on that
last turn and only going to to four
points um you know, four maybe five
here. I wonder if there's ever a world
with the combo in Mo's hand that he
could have waited one more turn. It's
really tough. It's really really tough
to be able to wait a turn against the
Aurelia. You fall further behind in
points. Um, but basically you'd then
hopefully go to four on the next turn
because you've got the combo online. Uh,
you know, Tom would go up to seven and
then you just combo off and try and win.
>> And it it's, you know, it's possible
that just the full development turn can
get there, but it was not the choice
made and it's a reasonable choice to try
and go in there. Mo had a lot of tricks.
He had the long sword. He had pressure.
He had the relentless to still kind of
move back in, try and re-engage that
fight, but it feels like everything went
wrong. And as we were saying, Tom drew
so many cards. We're just going to
assume whatever card he needs, he's got
it in that hand. And he did.
>> Yeah, hard for things to go wrong there.
But we see guardian angel. Aelia is
getting bigger and bigger.
>> Sack deck.
Doing all the things. Angel goes on.
Aelia now at five. So we got 5 9 10.
>> What's our current count on the run on
defense? We got 2 4 6 uh 11.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So
>> 11.
>> Now Defiant Dance. How does the
targeting work on Defiant Dance though?
So there is no targetable unit on Mo's
side.
>> Yeah, I think it just says unit though,
not enemy unit with the second choose.
>> That's my question. So So we can see
here that Tom targets uh the herder with
the minus and the with the plus,
allowing it to be just a little buff
effect.
two from the spell, one from the
trigger. And uh that is a lot
>> and uh
>> it's enough. And Mo on two runes. I
mean, realistically, you don't like to
call him early, but it's there's really
not a lot you can do going into four
runes here for Mo. Uh the deck is not
known to be that uh accelerated, right?
It runs the Kai'Sa, but that's five
runes. It's got the wallops in. That's
what's kind of helping it do that. But
that requires plus two runes to any unit
you play uh in order to actually have
that wall up happen. So there's the
Kai'Sa, but that's just going to come in
real slow. Tom's going to go to seven
and be able to leave every single rune
he has
>> uh available if he wants.
>> I think it all came down down to that
one big turn for Mo. Really tough spot
to be in. You know you where if you
don't go for it here, you're in trouble.
If you do go for it, a lot of cards
probably in trouble too, but obviously
not work out too well. So Tom in the
driver's seat. Herder coming in drawing
another card. Really holding. Tom is at
say not wasn't five. It's seven. All
right. So at seven
>> and Oh boy.
>> Yeah. I think I think we can pack up the
cards. Thanks Mo. Good job. Still a a
great series between these two.
>> I've heard your eyes folks. Tom takes it
down 3 0 even. Or it's now three. Three.
Not three in the matches. So uh great
match from Tom and uh really really good
stuff for for Mo. Still uh still looking
good. Yeah. I actually like the the
ideas behind the battlefields for this
Lucian build. This is not what I I see
all the time with Lucian. I think
they're not strange. It's just not what
we see out of every Lucian, right?
They're not always going Warren's uh
candle it. You know, just Mo's very
invested in digging for the combo. And
three games he found the combo three
times. I I don't often see the Lucian
like always finding the combo, right?
They're they're finding wins in other
ways. is when they find the combo, they
often are pretty locked for the win. But
he's more invested in making sure he
actually hits it. And I think he he made
a lot of very wise decisions throughout
this series. I think in that last game,
he made a decision and he stuck with it,
right? He was he's like, I think I have
enough that I can kind of push for this.
Waiting a turn is very risky. It opens
up a lot of ways that you can still
lose, especially around Draven
Audacious, which we' seen in previous
games. And so I think averting that risk
and instead trying to take the risk of
pushing when Tom has less runes because
on the following turn when he tries to
make the push, Tom feasibly can just be
on plus two runes and the same amount of
cards, right? So it's not doesn't help
you that much to develop,
>> right? The question is, you know, is it
going to get better? Yeah.
>> And the answer is maybe it could have,
but probably not. We don't know.
>> All right. So we're going to pop down
for a little winners interview with Tom
and uh I'm I'm going to get down there
real real fast and see what's up.
All right, Tom, took down Lucian. You're
playing Aurelia. How'd the match go?
>> Uh, to be honest, I wasn't really
expecting uh someone experienced like Mo
and Lucian this weekend, so it was
pretty tough at first, me trying to like
navigate, figure out the matchup. I had
a few things go my way, and you know,
the rest is history. I felt like uh uh
his plan of playing the creature that
can't be targeted by spells
>> and then trying to cap points with
Trinity Force and Skyfall was really
interesting and I felt like uh yeah, the
games are close overall.
>> Cool. What's up? So, why early this
weekend?
>> Uh I just felt like uh the um the deck
has a bunch of favored matchups. Uh it
does have a few unfavored ones. I feel
like I've kind of like got the nuts and
bolts down for trying to work out what's
happening with those. But overall, I
feel like it's just a really solid deck
and it consistently uh uh is favored
into the wider meta. So,
>> cool. Good stuff. And then overall
thoughts on the events. Awesome here.
>> Oh, the event's awesome. Like there's
like 4,000 people here. Uh I mean like I
haven't seen a single person having a
bad time to be honest. So it's it's just
been a bunch of fun so far. I'm actually
from Sydney, Australia. So I'm I'm over
here. I'm having a blast.
>> That's a long way. All right. Well, good
luck. Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
All right, great stuff. So, that was a
nice long round. So, we're going to take
a a very short break here, come back for
round number four, and bring you more
action from Las Vegas in the Real
Championship of Rickbound.
>> Hey guys, I'm here with some awesome
cosplayers at Riftbound Las Vegas. Would
you guys like to introduce yourselves?
>> Hi guys, I'm Plum Soju.
>> Hi, I'm Black Ace Cosplay.
Toxic Bunny, Tox IC Bunny,
>> and I'm Foxford.
>> Uh, all of the costumes look so awesome.
Can you tell me a little bit about the
pieces you made?
>> Yeah. Um, so this gauntlet, Ezra's
gauntlet, this entire piece is mostly
actually 99% 3D printed. Um, I paint
prime and this was a gold top coat. This
is with um some like metallic coat. This
is actually a glass copper shade with um
a blue mirror sheet under it. And I
super glued it over so give a gym like
and there's a normal glove and super
glue these up together. Um 3D print
glass comproach. Yeah,
>> that is so cool. What about your
cosplay?
>> I'm cosplaying Cassante. I am praying he
comes out soon and and broken as ever.
But um the hardest part about this
costume was the top and I got the files
commissioned but I had to sew everything
on and all that. Made the pattern. The
rope is all sewed onto it too. and I
would have his weapons, but uh the giant
props are not allowed here today.
>> That's too bad. Hopefully, we'll see the
props in the future. What about yours?
>> Uh I made all of most of this from
scratch. I tried to save some time by
getting pants and boots instead of
making those from scratch, but uh it was
very hard to make Lucian. I don't know
if people are kind of familiar with
Lucian's look, but he has like two
collars. These shoulder pieces are
crazy, and I kind of just was winging
it. I don't really use foam, so I was
like, let's try it. But I'm pretty happy
with how things turned out. So the
jacket for the first time.
>> Well, hopefully Lucian does well this
weekend as well. What about the Ari
cosplay?
>> The ball in the ears. It's like motion
and sound sensor, but it's kind of
janky. But tomorrow is mostly handmade.
>> Well, I am I love all the costumes.
Thank you guys so much for talking to me
about them.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Well folks, you want to start your found
journey the way the place to do it is
your local Nexus Knights at your local
game store. It's a a nice kind of
casual, relaxed night you can play. Uh
whether you're playing competitively or
you're just learning the game, it's a
great place to to start. Check out and
find your local store at
locator.riffbound.uvsgames.com/events
or scan the QR code and uh check it out.
>> Yeah, Nexus Night's awesome.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Uh you know, I really enjoy playing my
Nexus nights. I have a great local
store. Shout out Genesis on Long Island.
And uh it's just fun being able to show
up and you kind of just I usually show
up, build a deck like as I'm there, you
know, and I'm going to play Rumble
tonight or I'm going to play, you know,
whatever else. And uh it's really really
good stuff.
>> Oh yeah, it's it's my favorite. I get to
go play my pet decks and uh at least,
you know, attempt to win games instead
of uh just sitting in my room and trying
to build them online and see see if
they're going to work. I absolutely love
just being able to bring it there. I
play so much Leona at my next night's uh
in Origins and going into Spirit Forge.
I haven't had a lot of time to go play
yet cuz I've been traveling around
Bolognia and now coming here. But I'm
looking forward to, you know, bringing
out the Rex EI for the Nexus nights
coming up.
>> Me too. I'm dying to play Rexai and I
haven't gotten to yet. So that's good
stuff. We get to our next match though.
We got a little some hot takes you check
out and see what's going on.
>> We got to get predictions. What legend
do you think is going to win the event?
Why?
>> So I feel like saying Draven is kind of
boring. Uh but I think there's a lot of
space for Draven still to innovate. you
know, we have the miracle version, the
mid-range version, but like people have
kind of just locked in on those and kind
of not tried to expand further. And I
think that as the metag game develops,
like you can just find different ways to
do it. We're still pretty early in the
whole set cycle in general. So, I think
some sort of innovative Draven list is
going to kind of sneak up and be like,
"Yeah, Draven's here, but even more
teched out or whatever else is going to
be."
>> I think that Ari is going to win because
my partner is playing Ari and he really
wants a medal.
>> So, I'm going to go really wild with
I'll say Victor. Oh, it's going to be
Garen because it'll be me.
>> Yeah.
>> Aurelia. Best deck, bro. I'm I'm repping
it. I'm taking I'm taking first place,
bro.
>> Okay, there we go. Yeah, that's No,
that's what I want to hear.
>> In all of my testing, it's Ruin Runner
and Fluanc paired together has just been
an absolute house. So, that's that's
where it's coming from.
>> From my heart, I would say Azir. I
really want Azir to do well, and I want
him to take home the gold. Uh, no pun
intended since he is gold. But um I
think realistically I'm looking I'm
going for Annie too.
>> Yeah, I think uh Miracle Silver the
specifically the the list that Randy had
back in the one of the China regionals
at top four. I think somebody has been
grinding that list for for weeks on end
and will end up taking it. I think
that's actually secretly the best deck
in the format. Even though the Allen S
deck is just is quite good obviously cuz
Allen's you know the best player in the
game right now.
>> Is that Civer player you?
>> I hope it is. I hope it is. I am playing
it. I I am playing it this weekend. I
hope it is. Uh so it should be good. It
should be good.
>> I actually I I don't like the deck, but
I think Kai'Sa is actually a good choice
this week after uh Allen's like crazy
run with um uh uh Ezreal at Bolognia. I
do think a lot of people are going to go
into heavy removal and I think Kais is
going to do a very good job of dealing
with the Vex uh with the Ezreal in the
backline and then just overwhelmingly
right.
>> I love a good hot take. Yeah.
>> You know, that's the most exciting part
about card games is the kind of the the
volatility. You know, you never really
know what's going to happen next. You
can never really predict from event to
event. So, so cool to see great stuff
and you find out by watching really cool
matches.
>> I know what's going to happen. Oh, you
know what's going to happen.
>> Allan's Q is going back to back.
>> I didn't get to ask myself my hot
outtake. Oh, that's
>> or my or my prediction.
>> Yeah, that's We got to talk somebody
about that. You got to get your own
prediction. There you go.
>> Maybe I should have interviewed myself.
We like splice it with me on the other
side of the mic and I do it. Yeah, I
would have just said that Allan Ziki is
going to win again. I don't know. That's
my boy.
>> Not a bad prediction. Allan, you almost
mentioned of course and is just
fantastic. Of course, our winner last
weekend in Bolognia and uh but we got
more matches for you. We're coming to
round number four here. We're gonna have
HD 300 on Aurelia versus Codeman Jack on
Azir. I haven't seen Azir yet.
>> Yeah, and it's uh it's Codeman Jack Cody
playing it. This is another uh Legends
of Run Terra guy. I see all these names
popping up and it's like memories to
Legends of Rune Terra days. And he he's
also uh made a very deep run at Fab
Nationals last year, which was uh really
really great to see. And so playing the
Azir, we heard Ersie talking about this
is the deck that she loves to rep right
now. She's absolutely loving. I'm sure
she's backstage stoked to be seeing an
Azir undefeated right now coming in.
>> Yeah, that's really really cool. Azir
very unique game plan as we'll see in
the deck we'll come up a little bit here
and uh you know kind of playing a very
different strategy and kind of different
overall it's very very very very linear
where some decks kind of you know you
kind of season the taste you have some
spells here and there is like I'm going
to do this thing and I'm going to do it
all the way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I think one of the big
things that you look at for Azir is the
consistency, right? It says, as you
said, it's going to do the thing, right?
Every single time it's going to do the
thing. And that thing is create very
large might numbers on these sand
soldiers cuz it's going to summon the
sand soldiers have a pile of gear and
then it can equip all that gear onto a
single unit and push it forward. And
often times it's very difficult to
actually contend with the might totals
that Azir presents. And they do it so
quickly. So they'll start scoring a lot
of points really early. The problem is
they run out of cards. And once they're
out of the cards, that's where you can
start to retake control of the game. And
so Azir hinges on Arise, his signature
spell to finish the game as soon as he
gets to six points. Summon that army of
sand soldiers and push in for those
final points. And we're going to see how
Aurelia can try and contend with that
with HD 300 playing around the sneaky
deck hand. We mentioned that Tom was off
of in that last game, not playing around
those sneakys to try and get those early
point leads. and we saw him find the
point leads later via holds. The idea
with this is that you can still look to
keep double conquering because you're
the one on point tempo and force your
opponent to try and hold into Aurelia
which is very difficult. It's really
hard to hold against Aurelia.
>> So more stockless you would say here
then I would say based on yeah what
we've been seeing over the last few
weeks this has become the stock standard
is playing around the sneakys. Earlier
on though this was not the version. This
is a little bit newer to what is
considered stock, but at this point
after the last few weeks, I would
consider this stock.
>> Awesome stuff. So, check out code man
Jack's Azir list. If you can see those
arises and all those equipments and uh
what's going on here?
>> Yeah, I wanted to see if there's
anything immediately spicy and I would
say that two main deck salvages I would
consider quite spicy and going to be
quite effective in this matchup. One of
the big things that Aurelia can do to
leverage breaking big boards and big
holds is by buffing up an Aurelia that
has a guardian angel, pushing it in,
letting it die, buffing it, and
reringing it with the Blade Dancer
Legend and sending it back in. In
combat, if you decide to send in, hoping
that that guardian angel is going to
protect you and it gets salvaged,
suddenly you're in for a bad time as the
Aurelia player. So, two of these in the
main. Something that is I would say is a
very key card to look out for as well as
the call the weeks. You know, not a lot
of units in this Aelia deck. It has the
sneaky deck hands, but outside of that,
it's really looking at the Aurelia at
the Draven. That's another big card
we're going to be looking for. Other
than that, I would say pretty stock as
far as Zir. I think the salvage is a bit
spicy as a main deck uh choice. And then
two shears being gone for to try and
mitigate that card draw issue. Ursy was
saying she was having success when she
finds the early Sears uh the early
shears in not actually running out of
cards with this deck. You can get a lot
of value uh continually recurring the
draw, especially when paired with
something like an eye of the Herald
generating a bunch of recruits.
>> Really cool. So, it's cool to see there
isn't that much interaction, but uh some
very key interaction for Code Man. So,
Catman Jack on the right here. Azir
Emperor of Sands going to be starting on
Vile Maw layer against HG300 on the
left. Obelisk of Power. Vile Maw's gonna
look pretty nice here.
>> Yeah, Vile is really great. The thing
with Azir is often you just conquer with
the soldier and then you just don't
really care what happens. It's like,
okay, spend some resources to kill my
soldier and then I'm going to play a
gear, summon it, and re-equip whatever I
need and send it back in afterwards,
right? So, you don't mind uh leaving
your units out there. Uh, but meanwhile,
your opponent really does not want to be
stuck at a battlefield when Azir gets to
essentially have a lot of kind of sneaky
ways to accelerate his units with a lot
of might. As we look at this opening
hands and shears salvage immediately for
Cody, code man Jack on that side. The
salvage, I think, is something you
absolutely want if you're going to main
deck it for this event.
>> Yeah. And tricky, too. You know, we are
of course,
>> you know, this is a little bit of an
off-kilter card to have in the main
deck. So, H needs to be watching out for
that. Both players in their mulligans.
Looks like one card each.
>> It looks like good considering sending
that salvage back. That would surprise
me cuz I I would feel of any matchup
that you want to see these,
you know, from your main early in the
game. Aelia is the one that comes to my
mind as trying to kill that guardian
angel, try and kill that zoning
hourglass.
>> All right, so two reactive cards go to
the bottom for Code Man Jack. Maybe
looking for some more threats. We saw
two cards for HD also. We are off to the
races. Three runes to start thanks to
obelisk of power and going to open up on
the old sneaky deck hand.
>> Yeah, taking down the obelisk point
number one right on turn one.
>> And this is exactly why you play the
sneaky. You play the obelisk on game
one. If you're going uh second sometimes
you just get to play out a Stellicorn
for free. Uh if you're going first, you
just get to sneaky on turn one and you
get two points. And Azerellia having
that big of a point lead is really
annoying for anyone having to play
against you. It's it's awful. I will say
it's really tough to play against it. as
we are going to have a desert call
double sand soldier play here without
any equipment played yet. So not getting
the value of the weapon master. However,
Codeman Jack is valuing saying, "Okay,
if you want to go to two, I am going to
immediately try and put pressure back on
the points." Yeah, kind of cool to see
what Oblo does to a game where you know,
usually you don't have a player scoring
on the first turn or playing two units
on the first turn. And here we see both
happen at once. So going back HD's way,
five runes available. Sneaky deck hands
job is done. going to sneak back out.
So, two points, one from the hold and
one from the the sneak now at a nice 20
lead. And then what is the next step?
>> Yeah, I mean, you don't have to be
afraid of a single cull. So, it's
possible you can deploy the uh Aurelia
and just say, you know what, if you have
double cull and you kill your board and
kill my board, I guess that is life. Uh,
and that is going to be the decision
from HD300. I think playing around
single call, good. You should always uh
playing around double, I think, is like,
you know, a little bit too much. And I
totally feel good about this play of
developing the Aurelia since that is
generally your backline threat at taking
down Fervent.
>> Yeah. And Dehan kind of secret value
here like you're saying that extra coal
sacrifice little little insulation. So
not quite a guardian angel but sort of
acting like like
>> it is a guardian sense. Yeah. In this
sense it is. That's a great great way to
put it. Um as we are going to have the
shears get slammed down by uh code man
Jack here. You know, you lose a little
bit of value from these because you had
to play that desert call on the previous
turn uh to not be able to get a weapon
master on this, but you're still going
to weapon master it to the sand soldier
you play on this turn off of your
Emperor of the Sands.
>> Yeah. So, sand soldiers everywhere. We
see two points scored right back. So,
both players off to a roaring start as
Obliska Power usually uh usually does
and we're going to see a pass back over
to HD. So, it's 22 and now getting to uh
to ready up with an Aurelia is not a bad
place to be. Two more runes. Seven runes
in total.
Going to draw a card and see what the
next step is.
>> You're saying there's not a lot of
tricks in this zero deck. There's a few
and they are clutch. We see a defy in
hand. Uh what else do we see here?
Quick. What's that?
>> Uh that's guards. Uh so it's actually
that is slow speed, but it can be
hidden. So it's it's not at action
speed, but you you can hide it. Uh
that's going to summon a sand soldier,
and if you pay an order power, uh you're
going to be able to have it come in
ready. Um, which is really nice. You you
summon it, you pick up uh one of the
gear that you played earlier in the
game. Uh, and then you've got this like
accelerated uh sand soldier that can go
in and conquer. So, we had we had
options. Coan Jack had options uh on
turn with these three untapped runes.
Uh, could have been play shears already
used the Azir maybe not there. Uh, but
could have played um the Arise or hidden
it decided to kind of wait back and stay
and say at least some runes up. So, it's
time to get going. HD300 discipline on
sneaky deck hand to start.
>> Yeah, I I think this is a pretty dire
straits for Azir in this game so far.
I'm looking at this hand, I'm like
there's not a lot that we're doing to
deal with Aelli. Arise, amazing card,
really strong part of your win
condition. We only have a shears on the
board, right? We we missed a turn one
Dor and shield or or an eyeball. Uh we
we didn't have a BF sword going next,
but it's pretty tough. So that
preemptive discipline was playing around
defy, right? You don't want to get into
a combat scenario, cast your trick, and
then get counter spell. So preemptively
going to pump in. We're going to see
taking the biom layer. Sand soldier is
going down up to three for HD, but wants
to stay on those even totals, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, just looking to go
to four. You don't want to trap your
Aurelia on Bomos. The sneaky you're
willing to let die on the next turn.
That's okay. uh the the especially
because now instead of your sneaky deck
hand needing to be a guardian angel, uh
your guardian angel can be a guardian
angel, which is going to be quite nice
if you're trying to deal with the call.
That is like the biggest lose con you
have as Aurelia is getting your Aurelia
fervent called and then just like not
having a big unit to deal with the the
Azir. You start to slow down your point
collection and Azir, guess what?
Probably does not slow down his point
collection. He's he's going to be going
2 4 68. That is just how that deck kind
of functions every single game.
>> And now we're seeing that choice of
bottoming the salvage for Codeman. maybe
you know could have come up here as a
guardian angel. We see a hidden card as
well and HD300 is very well set up.
Going to pass the turn back. Now we are
in Arise territory for Code Man Jack,
but there's uh only one equipment in
play.
>> Yeah, I mean you know it it's just an
unccastable card when you've only got
the one in play, right? Like he's going
to have to wait a few turns before he
can actually get that value. Uh we see
he does pick up an eye of the Herald.
That is at least one more gear, but it's
not the most at this point. We really
want BF sword, right? Like we want the
bigger stuff to start getting to slam
down. Uh the shears can can draw some
additional cards. So he doesn't have to
go for this look yet. But the problem
with shears is the unit does have to
die. And right now you want to you want
to take out the sneaky deck hand, right?
You want to send this into the vile moss
and deal with this. And now well cheers
are stuck there and they're not drawing
a card. We're not digging a card deeper.
And uh that can just continually be a
problem as the game kind of moves on. Uh
there is still potential to get another
sand soldier out with one of these gear
and then still accelerate the uh the
Azir. Uh, and that can still bring the
sand soldier from the viol and free it
over to the obelisk, but three runes up
a hidden card for the Aurelia. It's not
an exciting prospect to push into this
obelisk,
>> right? Yeah, champs is a lot coming out
of nowhere.
>> All right, so we see the eye coming down
and sand soldier to go with it. Weapon
master coming on in. Five runes
available.
And what is the next step again? Defy
in. All right.
>> I mean, this is 10 might.
>> So,
>> if he accelerates,
>> in
>> Yeah, this makes more sense.
>> We are not going to see an accelerate.
So, just in the back row and passing
back to HD300.
>> Hang on.
>> Going to get a hold point. Really gets
that little bit of buff from the
already. Hidden card still hanging out.
Is the hidden card make things a little
awkward for as far as like leaving that
battlefield? Um uh it can, but if it is
just fighter flight or zyas, then it
doesn't really matter cuz uh fighter
flight you can just push Aelia back
home, send her into the vile moss,
conquer to six. Uh so it kind of works
offensively as well. It's got that like
double threat. Uh and then if it's I
mean yeah, just reveal it. Yeah, that's
fine. So seeing as that those are the
general hidden cards that are run in
these decks, I think you often are
really happy to hide it and your your
opponent just like not even bother with
it. You still get to play the game
afterwards. Okay, so you see a little uh
hand on table, hands in lap for uh HD,
>> thinking out what the next step is.
>> This middle turn is typically very
important. You know, Aelia especially,
you know, you you get into a spot where
you mismanage your Aelia, things unravel
quite quickly.
>> Yeah.
>> What I'll say is I think for HD, the
reason this turn isn't simple cuz you
actually look at this turn and you're at
five, you just want to score to six.
That's that seems obvious, right? You're
playing Aurelia. You score two points
per turn. You win the game. You conquer
both sides. He's thinking about this
Vile Moss. He says, "Okay, well, once I
go to this vile moss, how am I pivoting
my Aurelia again?" Mhm.
>> Because he doesn't have boots in hand,
he doesn't have a ride the wind in hand.
So, he's he's considering, okay, well,
now once I get to this Val's layer, how
do I go home? And the the big answer
would be actually is is code manager's
going to help you out,
>> right? You have this guardian angel and
once Azir kills the Aurelia, she's going
to recall to home. You can't move to
base, but you can get recalled back
home. And I think uh, you know, HD was
thinking for a little bit back and forth
on this Vom. How am I, you know, if I
get stuck here, what's going on? He
still has a unit to develop. He can
allow this Aurelia to die and then look
to push back in for for a double conquer
in the following turn.
>> Yeah, kind of cute. The the retreat is
not a move. So Ball's layer says, "Uh,
yeah, that's fine. You can get out of
here. and retreat.
>> Go home. See you. See you later.
>> So, back Jack's way and Jack Jack's
hand's getting pretty full here. So,
Vashir drew a card on that combat and uh
six cards to work with. Got another
shears. Got a discipline in there.
And now is Jack's turn to think and
figure out what's going on. We got three
runes up for HD.
Only imagine a pretty solid stack of
cards there, too.
So talk to me about the Azir chosen
champion.
>> Yeah, so really really nice Azir
sovereign. This is going to be able to
move any tokens uh with you. In fact, it
doesn't say sand soldiers. Uh so you can
move recruits with you as well when you
when you send him around. Um which is is
very valuable for this deck, especially
when you start making a bunch of those
recruits with the eye of the herald. Um,
and so it's it, you know, it's a when I
attack trigger, so it can't be to like
try and reinforce a battlefield
afterwards. Uh, however, it it allows
you to do some really great pivots. You
you stack a bunch of a gear onto a sand
soldier or onto a recruit. You push it
into one side, you get that conquer, and
then you accelerate a zir and then, you
know, do that nice little sherea shuffle
that we know and love from League of
Legends and take it to the other
battlefield so you can conquer. And this
when I say that this Azir year does that
one thing of going 2 468 so well and so
efficiently with so much might. This is
one of those key ingredients to the the
soup of uh you know scoring all of these
points uh for the Azir deck. And I think
you know man jacket in this game has has
missed a lot of the early drops that you
want. You really want to go like Doran
Shield or Eye on turn one with making
something into like BF sword with making
something into like continually having
that and then go a rise and end the
game. And we saw shears, we saw kind of
these weird fumbly turns in between and
not a lot of might generated against uh
firing on all cylinders Aurelia deck
with, you know, sneaky deck hand into
getting the Aurelia out and scoring. So
I think we haven't seen the full power
of this Azir deck just yet. And the
Arise is just going to be deployed to
try and get some more might on this
board.
>> So we see a move in here on the obelisk.
Uh the eye makes a recruit. So sand
soldier recruit hanging out. Here's a
rise. We're gonna making we got three Y
sand soldiers
>> weapon master over to the sand soldier
in base. Two of them are ready thanks to
Arise's ability which is just quite
potent.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Arise is like the biggest draw to
playing this.
>> Oh, it's insane.
>> Yeah. Oh, it's absolutely insane.
>> You're saying it's one of the best
signature cells in the entire set,
>> I'd say. So, yeah. I think the biggest
issue with it is that uh hard bargain
exists right now in the meta very
heavily
>> and uh so it can be a bit of a struggle,
right? This is this is a match up where
actually Aurelia is very commonly not on
many if any copies of hard bargain. Uh
sometimes we see one often it's like in
the board and then you know even though
the green wind wall is the only counter
that actually hits a rise and nobody's
going to play wind wall if they have
access to hard bargain realistically. So
you know you can kind of uh get away
with it in this matchup where your Arise
gets to come through which is why
sometimes the Aelli match up isn't that
horrible for you. If you get that point
lead, Aurelia often just doesn't have
the tools to answer Arise. Doesn't have
tools to answer, you know, the big
pushes that you're trying to send
through. And we're going to see one come
here.
>> Big combat coming in. So, we got two
sand soldiers and a recruit coming in to
challenge Aurelia at Viomos. The
guardian angel is there. So, if the
combat goes arai, Aurelia will just kind
of, you know, tail between the legs,
head on home.
>> But we got some action from HD. We have
an ong guard. That's going to be plus
three total. Yeah.
>> And
>> blade dancer activation to make it a
plus four.
>> Four.
>> Yeah.
>> Really getting your money's worth here
for one energy.
>> Yeah. It's a little much, isn't it?
>> Yeah. It's a lot. Fiant dance. Eat your
heart out. So, the gun ready. And now we
see that huge buff.
And now
>> this combat has uh it's not gone great.
So we see uh tokens of the bin a draw
off the shears
>> very big draw but wanted it maybe
you know a few turns earlier.
>> Yeah. So tough arise is the big rebuild
and that wasn't a very good rebuild. No,
I mean, you know, Cody, maybe just
needing to pressure a little bit more,
push a little bit more, seeing as how
Justin on guard was enough to kind of
stuff that push. Maybe you do need to
commit the Azir here, right? Uh try and
push through. Especially because, you
know, looking at the hand, he had a
charm the whole time. So, if you're able
to push in, you kind of get that first
kill, you can maybe look to kind of pull
in with the the charm afterwards. He
could have gone to Zir and brought just
everything, right? just bring the entire
board and just say, "You know what? Beat
this and then beat the charm. And if you
can, that's good. I'll scoop. We'll go
next game. If you can't, I'm back in
it." Yep.
>> Right
now left with a lonely Azir with I guess
there's a few friends still in play. You
know, we are unequipped on the uh the
recruit and the sand soldier at the
obelisk and the shears on the other sand
soldier. So, not a lot of might bonuses
on these equipment. Just a lot of
finicky effects.
But it's equip time. Here comes the eye.
Now Aurelia is still quite large. That
largest does not go away.
So Codeman Jack trying to figure out
what is the next step.
The shears are going on the recruit.
A lot of possible game actions here as
far as like all these equipments where
they can go. Lots of different tokens.
and gonna go uh gonna go big here on the
obelisk.
>> Yeah, potential look for a hold. Go
ahead and hide there.
You know, as we mentioned, it's a when I
attack trigger, so couldn't grab that uh
sand soldier with the shears. However,
the hidden guards when that pops up, you
can go ahead and weapon master those
shears back over to get another plus one
plus the draw on death uh over onto this
obelisk. However, that's not that much
might that you're adding to this if
HD300 is able to find a way to pivot the
Aurelia over. However, you know, as we
mentioned, Voss maybe an issue here. Uh,
the Stellicorn's probably not breaking
this hold. And so, it comes down to did
you find the boots to gank?
>> Yeah, I mean, even just with HD at
seven, is there value in just trying to
kind of hang out on Biles Mos? Try to go
for the
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> You know, if you if if Codeman Jack's
saying, "Hey, I'm going to go after
Obelisk, but when you're down on points,
you can't just go for that exchange, you
know, the point exchange." So,
all right. So, back on HD, we see a uh
stack deck. Taking a little peek.
Feel like most of the uh the non- chaos
decks are jealous of stack deck. You
know, just that ability to really, you
know, as we saw, you know, in the prior
match, Lucian, you know, this match
where these non-purple decks don't have
that filtering. They can't rely on
battlefields or just, you know, the
right draws at the right time where
stack deck is
>> such a potent tool. Yep.
>> Stacked and call shot just the big MVPs.
the the the name of the game at the
moment in Spirit Forge just kind of
getting that card selection through and
>> uh you know as you mentioned I think
going for the hold makes a lot of sense.
Uh I think if you're in the shoes of HD3
under you see that uh you know the Azer
players gone for this you have to assume
that they've got a way to kind of
prevent you from just holding from
seven. So you want to think with that in
mind. It doesn't mean you can't go for
it. You can still kind of look for it.
But uh you know we know that this charm
is the reason that Code Man Jack is
willing to kind of make this happen.
you're going to be ready to charm that
Aurelia over and get her out of there.
But
>> for HD300, he's like, I I've got the
boots
>> and you've got one rune, so I'm going to
go ahead and just ship it.
>> It's party time. Okay, so ganking over
Stella Cornhoer will will join. We see a
draw and then we see guards exclamation
point. That is one more sand soldier
joining the Fred.
And
this is a lot of numbers. We add all
this up here.
really currently has the four still four
runes available for HD. See define dance
in the window. So there's the equip on
weapon master and now it is uh HD's
focus to uh start pushing through. And
just for our clarity here, I believe
this four is going to be the plus from
reading for the start of turn. Uh and
then the boots and the guardian angel or
was there a spell cast on this turn as
well? Cuz I didn't see a spellcast. So
this should just be reading start of
turn. Are you saying the four is
counting the
>> Yeah, I think they're counting the
equipment right now.
>> Okay. I don't like that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I know. I know. But I
just I I want to just get clarity. I
don't I don't see how else we're getting
to four here if we're not counting
equipment right now. So,
>> just want to clarify, make sure that
we're all kind of understanding how much
might is here, but I I'm not convinced
that uh Code Man Jack's going to be able
to hold on. Defy is going to be
available for the define dance and
that's going to be your best target
generally. Yeah.
>> Then we'll see from there.
>> Yeah. I mean, if this is where uh HG
starting, code Jack's going to be a
static, right?
One rune available has the good answer.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh we do see a still a pump from the
targeting. And now we got in theory 5 9
10 11 12. And on Jack's side we got
what? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
>> less 10 11 12 this count.
>> Yeah. Game two.
>> All right. They're going game two.
>> All right. So count indeed. Aurelia. It
is just hard to hold against Aurelia.
>> Oh yeah, it is. Aurelia so big, Defiant
Dance so powerful and uh definitely kind
of an awkward draw there for Jack.
>> Yeah, I would say I would say so. I
think that's not exactly what he wanted
to see. We've got this next game he gets
to go uh you know uh starting going
first Arena's greatest. It's going to be
a lot better uh for the Azir. Definitely
just needing to find one of those uh one
gear to start the game off. And
realistically, I think that draw from
Azir can get there sometimes. I think
the might values are a little bit too
low. But one of the big problems is
obless going first for Aurelia, having
sneaky deck hand to start, go to two
points right off the bat. Now you're
forcing the Azir to try and hold against
Aurelia. There's not many decks that can
hold against Aurelia just in general. So
it's it's really really tough to make
happen and Azir thrives on getting ahead
in point tempo and not having to go for
those holds.
>> All right, so we got game two arena's
greatest. players starting at one sunken
temple. Temp sunken sunken temple,
excuse me, on the other side. And uh
mighty unit will draw for one when
conquered. We do see some of those cheap
equipment in hand for Jack. There's a
Doran shield and then we got charm.
>> What is the card under Doran Shield?
>> Uh that is another Azir Sovereign. So So
an extra copy of the chosen champion.
>> Oh, there's often play in the main deck
as well.
>> Uh not often actually. I think that's a
little bit a little bit spicier that
they, you know, won an extra one. I kind
of like an extra one. I think that it is
really good at allowing you to to make
those big pivots. I agree with him to
mull it away. I think it's like a very
late game card that you're kind of
interested in, oh, getting this
accelerate from my hand that can pivot
the big sand soldier that I maybe pushed
earlier in or the big Arise push I can
then also send to the other side. Okay,
so we got two cards going to the bottom
for both players.
>> Greatest trigger.
>> Jack will be on the plate. Make sure you
get that arena greatest trigger. Don't
want to miss that one. And is one
nothing for the time being. He won one
soon enough. And there it is. There's
that turn one play. Very important.
Doran shield coming with a sand soldier.
Not too bad.
>> Yeah, I think everything about this
start is significantly better. We see a
call, which is exactly what you want
against the Aurelia, especially if we
miss the Sneaky on this turn. You're
going to end up in a spot where the
Aurelia Fervin's going to have to come
down and that call is going to get a lot
of value. Now, of course, Sonia's
hourglass going to save it from being,
you know, just kind of game ending
having that call happen right out the
gates, but it's still valuable to get
through that first one. And the face
breaker, I think, also kind of valuable
in this matchup because you're going to
get towards those endame spots where we
see that Aurelia just swing in for like
400 might or whatever it was, right? And
>> yeah. Yeah. The stun gets to stop that
and uh just allow you to actually.
That's how Azir holds, right? you hold
with things like face breaker and uh
maybe there's like hidden blade or just
trying to find these ways to kind of
like cheat your hold where you're not
actually higher might but you have kind
of this like sneaky way to get around
it.
>> Cool. So I mean great start for Jack
here compared to last game and then also
a weaker start for HD. No turn one unit.
Jack's on the board. Two sand soldiers,
couple equipments and getting ready to
roll.
>> Yeah, cool little optimization here. You
know, you play the brutalizer. you if
you weapon master that then you kind of
lose the the benefit of the plus two and
uh often Azir doesn't really care about
his soldiers later on in the game so he
just like leaves this on Arena's
greatest take the door and shield back
home and then you have the brutalizer
ready to equip when you untap at start
of turn if your opponent tried to push
in more aggressively you end up with
this uh you know six might sand soldier
coming in for your turn three swing
before you've even played any other
cards so two setup turns for HD right
the hourglass here's the Aurelia but
coming in and uh and ready to rock and
roll, but uh not actually affecting the
board in any way just yet.
>> This is massive. We talked about the
call being in hand. Uh you know, having
those on hourglass to try and make you
safe, but also uh you know, for Jack on
the other side, he's got a charm
>> and when we I was talking about a six
attacker coming in, you can play the
call, get through the zone, his
hourglass, push in, conquer, play the
charm. Oreli is gone. there. This is
this is shields down and I think he
immediately sees this line, right? This
is exactly his win con for this game is
I deal with the Aurelia and I'm ahead in
point so I just keep scoring. He gets to
score immediately up to four on this
push in. Brutalizer is going to put this
to six. Then you get to charm this in
often. GG. Yeah, fantastic for sure. And
then kind of accomplishing that task.
We've seen a lot of games with the on
camera so far where Aelia has never left
the board. Yeah.
>> You know, and
night and day, you know, for the Aelia
to have a really in play, of course. So,
here's the setup, the call, and we got
our very large sand soldier. And I
imagine we are moving in and charming
up. Yep. Looks like he's just
calculating whether or not he can go for
the draw with the sunken temple as well
here. And I I think he has the resources
where it feels uh very reasonable to go
for the draw on this turn.
>> And we are going to see it.
>> All right. So,
>> one with the temple. Mighty unit is
conquered. We're going to see a draw. A
hidden blade.
>> It's the second one in the hand.
>> All right. And here is the charm. Huge
play.
>> So, two turns of setup going second for
HD. And all for not. The hourglass is
gone. The Aurelia is gone. And the board
looks fantastic for Code Man Jack. HD
has a lot of rebuilding to do.
>> Yeah. The big thing we'll we'll say that
the only downside that has happened here
uh for Jack is he missed maybe a one
drop gear would have been really insane
in this spot to be able to redevelop the
backline with these last two runes. And
this was a very steep power cost price.
One for the call the week, two for the
charm due to the uh deflect and uh one
for the equipping of the brutalizer. So
we're four powers spent on that turn
down to two runes. So there is this
world where Aurelia can crawl back
because of the rune advantage, but this
is 4 to one in a deck that is trying to
kind of build up and then go for that
Arise and the Arise is in hand.
>> Yeah. Kind of lost in that exchange was
that Jack's already four points.
>> Exactly.
>> And that is uh that's quite good. So
couple stack decks here and uh you know
I think when you see your opponent who
just took a pretty bad turn start out
with a couple stack decks, that's a good
sign. That's a sign of weakness where
our stock deck player is just like I I
got to get out of this. I gotta find
something. And uh that's what HD is
trying to do right now. Five runes left.
>> Did he find a unit? I think I see a
Stella. I also think I see a sneaky deck
hand in there. So there are units that
that is the big scary thing is right can
just miss on units here. And the that's
where the game is really done. But as I
was saying, because of the four recycled
runes, even with this point lead, there
is a there's a bit more game to play for
Aurelia, because of this massive rune
advantage, you can find the opportunity
to claw things back, especially because
Jack's not winning next turn. He needs
two more, right? And that's where you
get to develop this turn and then from
there, you're not allowed to let go of
the reigns for the rest of you. You have
to be able to take control and never let
go. And that's where we're going to
start to see these hidden blades and the
phase breakers maybe start to seal the
deal. But generally, I would say this
position is not all lost for Aurelia,
even though it feels horrible.
>> All right, sneaky deck hand sneaking in.
That's point number two. Back on that
even total. Back on the board
and that's going to be it. All right, so
we get a whole point for Jack going up
to five like you're saying that six
point on this turn very important if
that can be done, but not really. The
accelerated things in my deck are five
mana for zero uh six energy for uh for a
rise. So will be hard to do.
>> Yeah. No, being the the deflect being a
major player here, I think you really
wanted to be able to accelerate
Sovereign uh go to that six point and it
looks like there's actually just no way
to go to six here. And um because of
that, that's going to buy an additional
turn for Aurelia with the rune
advantage. This is this is what we're
saying, right? There there is kind of
these little edge cases that you can
start to sneak your way back into this.
Uh and by having units, you can start to
develop. Though I will say that a rise
is going to be massive. It does mean
it's a third turn. There's more life
being afforded to Aurelia, right? You
know, instead of it just being two turns
and done, it is a third. I still think
the face breaker, the hidden blades,
these are really impactful cards that
can be hidden after this next conquer.
You know, we're going to see a big
double conquer on this next turn from
Jack. Hide a face breaker, hide a hidden
blade, and say, "All right, come at me."
>> So, pushing for that hold.
>> Yeah. Which I imagine this is a spot
Azir is not often in, or maybe it's that
last point. It it I will say it it does
happen a lot for the last point and it's
often exactly like this. You kind of
equip everything. You have two pretty
large boards on each side or one really
small one big but then a hidden card on
each and you just dump all the runes and
it's like a big arise turn. You send
everything in. You equip everything in
and you're left, you know, zero runes
left on your table from all the equips
and all the hidden cards and the arise
and all that and you say, "All right,
try try me. I'm at seven. What do you
want to do?"
>> We're in Vegas. You know, the chips are
in the middle and say, "What do you got?
Can you beat me?" Stellicorn Herder is
going to be the start for HD. Of course,
a hold point from a deck hand as well
trying to sneak back into his game. And
uh Herder here has some has some work to
do.
Definitely not a lot of might in play
for HD as far as uh defending goes.
Brutalizer scary as well between
Brutalizer and Arise. There's a a lot of
potential might going to be ready next
turn.
So, what is the defense for HD going to
be?
Get through. It's tough because you
almost can't look for a hold. You you
you want to look for a hold, but there's
not going to be a good opportunity. And
you want to go to four, right? And you
want to draw a card with a Cellicorn.
You want all these things, but we can't
have everything that we want all the
time, right? And and at a certain point,
it's going to have to be a big risk.
You're too far behind to play things
safe. You really at this point I
actually think you you can't even care
about what is in Code Man Jack's hand.
You just don't even care. Like whatever
cards are there, it doesn't matter. I
just have to put myself in the best
position with the most cards, most runes
to not let you just immediately win. And
I think retreating everything saying go
to seven and I I will break that hold is
probably our best bet or the best bet
for Aurelia.
>> So her is going to move in with a ride
the wind. So we see a draw off that and
then a draw here. So again, kind of that
same thing as last turn with the stack
deck. starting a turn with the draws
saying I don't really have it yet. I got
to try and put this together. That being
said, it's a lot of cards seen between
two stack decks and these Stellicorn
draws.
You see how just how important the
Aurelia champion unit is to this deck,
you know, where once that gets broken,
it's a lot to put back together.
>> Yeah. And it can be tough when the the
zas or the guardian angel are there
because you need those two pieces of
removal or the salvage that we saw in
the main deck, right? But he did, you
know, he he mulleted it away in that
first game. It was a bit surprising to
me to see and it makes me wonder like
did did you side out salvages after
that? Because if we are bottoming them
is something I would have expected to be
to be played around for this matchup.
But, you know, call being the most
powerful tool and having that charm
followup and the heads up of, you know,
not equipping the brutalizer when you
web master, taking that thing back. It
was all very just solid practiced plays
out of Jack and you understand why he's
three 0 on Azir even if Azir isn't the
number one deck in the game right now,
right? It's one of those kind of edge
case decks where you're playing for the
best of but the deck's still pretty
strong and had a second place finish in
one of the Chinese regionals. Right.
>> That's right. Yeah. You know, so we say
any deck can win. So Sand Soldier coming
in. We see up to six. A BF sword. So
much might.
And we're going to see a pass. So, it's
Coan saying, "All right, I'm going to go
to six. I'm going to get it next turn."
All right, there he goes.
Six. Waiting for that next turn. HD300
is also going to need to go to six on
this turn. It is very important for him
to make that six. But from there, he
becomes the player who has to hold. And
that is a tall task against the might of
Arise on the side of Azir. It's been in
the hand the entire game. The question
that now Codeman Jack has to ask
>> is, is there a bargain?
>> Ooh. Yes. Well,
>> and do we want a bargain? You know, what
do we what are we what are we offering
here? Because the rest of the hand is
double hidden blade, face breaker. Those
are ways that you can try and break
through two holds. That's not, you know,
face breaker not as good. You want that
on defense, but the the double hidden
blade, it's like, okay, what's more
likely? Do you have a couple defies,
some not so fast or do you have that uh
hard bargain that was maybe lurking in
the sideboard ready to come in and deal
with a rise?
>> Question is also for HD, how much energy
can be available for code manager turn?
Things need to happen this turn too. You
know, it can't just be interacting. So
her come in going to take a point, draw
a card up five.
Herder is a a great unit, but it is a
little small.
Same with deck hand. These are not, you
know, not brute force units, definitely
finesse units. We do see uh the result
of the herder is that there are a ton of
cards in hand for HD. Like Aurelia
always has a ton of cards in hand. Just
always.
And what is the next step to get out of
this mess? If you're HD, you have to
assume an arises loom.
>> Yeah, I think so. Right. Uh, I mean,
realistically, this is the the classic
setup, right? We've gone to six. We kept
a lot of runes around to make sure that
we can kind of go into this next turn
with a lot. Uh, God Jack's going to have
a rise plus a hidden blade uh is going
to be the offensive pressure that is
allowed to be put out. And it's quite a
lot, right, that you're going to be
threatening there. One just
unconditional kill. Uh, so long as of
course there's no uh defy to deal with
it. But then on top of that, it is be a
large amount of might. I mean, we're
looking at 1 2 3 4 year a brutalizer
equip that's going to be very valuable
and you can always potentially look for
it with cascading the BF sword. However,
not a lot of equipment cascading is
going to work against Aurelia cuz it's
often one big unit instead of a lot of
small units. And if you you wonder what
I mean by cascading, it is when you are
able to run one unit in that has an
equipment on it, let it trade with one
of the units on potential hold, and then
it drops the equipment when it dies. the
equipment stays in your base and you can
equip it to another unit and then still
utilize that might. And that's what I
mean when I'm saying cascading the might
of these equipment down. And it's a a
very important tool for Azir that he
doesn't really get to access against
Aurelia.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And with huge things
like brutalizer, BF sword, it can be
quite the exchange where a few small
tokens can all of a sudden take down his
huge board. Uh but let's see what's up
here. Players are uh talking it through.
You know, we're still early in the
tournament, but you know, three and 0 at
the feature match table. The pressure's
there. You know, you definitely you
definitely feel it a little bit.
These players want to keep their good
start going, keep it undefeated going.
And uh Dean's coming in. Of course, Dan
is not very mighty, so no draw there,
but that will put HD to six.
Is it a Draven?
>> Yeah, I guess so. All right, so we have
a defensive Draven Bolt.
>> Well, I said cascading wasn't going to
really matter, and I'm just wrong.
There's two sitting at the arena's
greatest, so it actually does open up
the ability to utilize that brutalizer
and that BF sword to even greater effect
than you often would be able to. Um, and
you know, notably that uh the Draven is
not going to be able to be the winning
point from the uh the combat win on
either side. and it'll go to seven for
HD if it wins on defense. And uh for for
Code Man Jack, yes, it'll take you to
seven, but the combat will resolve first
before the conquer. So, you'll go to
seven uh and then you'll get the conquer
uh going forward. There is however kind
of an edge case here where it can matter
quite a bit and that comes down to are
there defies because instead of even
going for the arise here you can conquer
sunken temple then just send a unit into
arena's greatest and play double hidden
blade onto this uh Draven
>> and you'd be at seven and that would
just kill Draven and you would go to to
eight from that. You don't even have to
be able to win on that side and conquer.
Now, the weakness there is two to five
fives. And in fact, funny enough, this
might be the line because the top deck
for Codeman Jack was defy. So, it would
need to be three Defies or two to fies
in a not so fast from the side of HD300
in order to beat this line or else it
just kind of wins. Uh there's this other
side of it, I guess, where there's a a a
push effect here to move the Draven
home, but then I think you're still kind
of winning with the conquer by kind of
taking this line. So, I don't know. I'm
curious if this is maybe just not even
an Arise play anymore because the Draven
is at the battlefield.
>> Yeah, kind of turn the tables on Draven
here, you know, where you're going to be
using your effect to win the combat
through non-combat means and I get that
point. So, big attack on Dehan. Dehan
isn't like, "Oh, no. I'm not going to
I'm not going to take that one." So, we
see the conquer. The temple will trigger
a draw card could be drawn. I I feel
like Jack's got a lot of the tools
already in hand. It also feels like he
has spotted this line cuz I am not I
mean this could still actually to be
fairy clear this could still be in a
rise line right you you can weapon
master these all over so it kind of it
does make sense that this is still
potential for a rise but I'm wondering
if he's considering this uh this Draven
line as well if this is something that
he's interested in. I guess there's also
the thought where if you go to assign
damage you actually don't have to
outmite that entire board. You just have
to outmite Draven.
>> It doesn't matter if the the sheep the
shepherd is still better. Oh, not
entering combat before the hidden blade.
>> Okay, so hidden blade taking Draven out
will not be in a combat scenario. So it
would kill the Draven in theory but not
get the point. So just going for a
conquer win here, I suppose, but we're
going to see a defy.
>> So going to fight back. I have a defy,
too.
>> Yeah. And float an additional rune here.
>> Or sorry, no, he he he still has the
floating. Yeah,
>> another defy back. We got a little
little chain here. So we have defy on
hidden blade. We'll end up resolving.
So, hidden blade is gone. Both defies
are gone. Only two runes left for HD.
Four left for Code Manag with one
floating. Yeah. So, no more Arise.
There's two options. You either go for
the line I was talking about. Say you
don't have a third Defy or a not so fast
and you push in your sand soldier and
you hidden blade the Draven. Or the
other side of it is you play the Azir
sovereign
accelerated and you bring it all back.
But he's going for the hidden blade
without entering the combat yet. And
that's the uh that is the potential
issue. I wonder if he doesn't realize
that he needs to be in combat for this
or what he's looking for with the the
pre-combat hidden blade.
>> So looking like just going for a
conquer, but you know that I think I
think that the it's sort of outside the
box. Think about that. It's if you're a
Draven player used to playing a Draven,
you're you're so used to trying to get
in combat and killing things in combat.
But all right, so we're going to see the
the fighterly back on the Draven. So no
hidden blade. However, now the herder is
trying to hold strong by his lonesome
against this fairly large remaining sand
soldier.
>> Yeah,
>> which could take the game if they can
conquer. It would be six into three,
but that's just one define dance that's
going to turn the tables there.
There's always the option though to
still just hide this face breaker down
on the sunken temple and potentially
went on a hold because you've burned
through two defies,
>> right?
>> You basically showed there's probably
not like a fight or flight. So instead,
okay, not even going to attempt it.
Says, you know what, that's fine. I will
just go ahead and hide this face breaker
here. I'm also kind of open to the idea
of pushing in, seeing what tools HD300
had to try and deal with the that push
and then still just hiding the face
breaker. I think there's a couple
options that could have been gone for
here,
>> right? The issue is you're playing
around Defiant Dance by not making HD
use it. It's still in hand.
>> Yeah, it's still there.
>> It's still available for the next next
one. So,
>> still able to, you know, move the
Stellicorn back, ready it. I I kind of
like trying to force a little bit there
maybe, but end of the day, this just
gives you a little bit more might on
defense. And and by a little bit, I mean
six. I mean, that's not a small number.
>> Yeah, it's a huge spot here. Both
players on seven. Code man Jack's going
for the hold. We got sand hold. We got
equipment. We have a hidden face
breaker. You can see on the screen
there. Could stun one on each side. Good
against one big attacker.
And guardian angel time.
>> So, we've talked about the guardian
angel break on big holds multiple times,
right? You you guys you send this in,
you you give it some buffs, you save one
buff. So when it gets recalled and goes
back home, you play one more card,
choosing it, ready it with blade dancer,
send it back in. Face breaker is a stun
for the turn.
>> Ooh, okay.
>> So, uh, you know, that's going to be
Draven, even if it's stunned, is just
not going to have the ability to deal
damage after that.
>> How often and in what quantity is Face
Breaker seen in these Azir decks? Uh, I
really like it is the you can't play too
many copies because often you want to be
conquering and face breaker is
inherently a defensive card, right? Uh,
because it stuns your own unit. You're
not actually able to kind of kill the
things that you're running onto the
board to deal with. So, because of that,
it is often a one, sometimes a two or
it's a one with maybe two in the side
for these games where your opponent
doesn't play a lot of early units. And
so, you always get on board first and
you don't get on board with resistance.
And so then it's about hiding and going
for those endgame holds to win the game
and not letting them get on board. Um,
so it's always a hidden threat, right?
>> So is it on HG's mind right now? Is he
trying to figure out how to navigate
through this?
>> I think after two hidden blades cast
blades, I'm often thinking this is third
hidden blade, but if he's played against
Azir really at all or well, I wouldn't
say at all, but if he's played against
Azir a little bit, I think he should
have Facebreaker on his mind. Okay, well
stock deck again
and got to take a look.
Draven's hanging out decently sized.
Is it time to get frisky? It must be
seven points for Jack. Got to break this
hole to win this game. Here comes
Draven.
>> So, as it currently stands, Draven is
not big enough. Correct.
>> Yeah, we have Draven.
>> I guess the dice are the dice are
showing the equipment buff as well. So,
and there's a defiant dance. So played
around Defiant Dance on Codeman Jack's
turn. Uh didn't actually trigger it by
forcing a combat. Now seeing it here uh
on the defensive side for Jack and it's
going to be a huge swing for Might.
>> Well, it can get eaten by this uh by
this Face Breaker.
>> Yeah. So right now playing into Face
Breaker.
>> There's Face Breaker.
>> I mean he burned through a lot of
counter spells. Are there any left?
>> And no runes left. So, here it is. Going
for the big stun. Oh, we got a reader.
So, this makes me think that this was
not on HD's mind unless just looking for
a specific uh wording here. Uh, not so
fast would work on Facebreaker. Correct.
>> Correct. It would.
>> Okay. So, even though it's like a a
choosing and, you know, same
Battlefield, etc. So, I imagine that if
uh not so fast was here, it' be on the
table.
>> Oh, for sure. I saw him flick through
the cards. No more counters left. All
right.
>> He's all He's all Look, we had two of
them on the last turn. There's no more
That's all. So now they're both stunned
for the turn.
>> Sans soldier's like, I don't mind. I'm
stunned. I'll just hang out here.
>> I ain't got nowhere to be. And
>> she dropping a card. Ruin on the floor.
>> That face breaker out of nowhere.
Here's an unguard. So we still have more
readying to do. But it has to be the
herder.
>> Yeah, it has to be the herder cuz the uh
the Draven I mean you could ready the
Draven. you you're welcome to.
>> That's true.
>> However, he is stunned. And so, uh, he
won't be dealing any damage in combat.
Uh, which I think at this point you kind
of need a little bit of damage.
>> Yeah. So, now note the the top sand
soldier is stunned. It will not deal any
damage, but it's still there. It might
is still relevant. And if it cannot be
killed, it just pushes back the herder.
And there you go. An awesome hold for
Code Man Jack. And a really sweet game
two forcing a game three. Uh, that was
awesome. Yeah, you see how hard it is to
kind of deal with the relic cuz in that
last turn, you know, it was possible
that Cotto Jack actually just like had
the win by pushing into the Herder. Like
it's very possible there was no way to
answer it. We know that Divine Dance was
there, but I don't know when it was
there. It could have been draw for turn.
It could have been when the Herder ran
home. That might have been the win. But
he kind of recognizes like it's probably
higher percentage that this gets beat
because I have nothing to back it up.
And maybe just having six more might
next to the Face Breaker makes all the
difference. And and I don't mind it. I
think it's a genuinely a good idea and
it worked out for him in the end.
>> Yeah, really cool stuff. So, now we go
to game three. We're going to see
Trifarian War Camp, which is a great
battle for Code Man Jack uh against the
Dreaming Dream. Perfect curve for Azir.
You've got the turn one uh this is going
second. So, turn one, you have one
energy play down the Doran Shield, make
a sand soldier. Turn two, you have five
energy BF sword, make a sand soldier.
This is exactly what you want to see for
this deck. numbers and then no turn one
to play for HD. So here's the Herder
hit. Herder is great, but it is small
and now it's going Jack's way. Five
runes.
>> You'll see him play fast. This is this
is uh no think. This is conquer. This is
play BF. This is play a Sandold.
>> Okay, choice being here what to conquer.
It's the Warhammer tree.
>> And then we got the sword comes in.
Here's a sand sold weapon master. Five
might in the back row. And now we're
going back HD's way. And this is HD's
turn to uh try and get things rolling
here. Ooh, is that double Arise that I'm
seeing as well? I know there's another
Doran double arise with three of these
uh equip going to be on board
immediately, right? Cuz we're going to
have a Doran on the next turn.
>> Yep. All right, so just Aurelia pass
another setup turn here for HD. That was
kind of the death of uh of game one for
HD, having to take these setup turns and
when Codeman Jack is on the board and
rocking and rolling. So sand soldiers a
hoy hold the two0
lead now going to 32 it it's good to
score the point uh but three is a little
awkward
>> I like that he's slowed down here he's
double arise in hand this he's got 10
minutes this game will finish this is
not this is he does not have to worry
about it in that way he was playing the
first two turns fast cuz he's like okay
okay 10 minutes we got to go but now he
actually has some real questions to ask
himself I love the move of the BF sword
back home right develop the Aziz Here
you're setting up. Yes, you're only at
three. You're not at four. That's where
we can get. We run one last turn. You're
setting up to try and runner, runner,
arise, arise, push in, win the game. Do
not let HD300 ever hold. There's going
to be way too much might value. And you
have the point tempo. So, you always do
it on offense. You're just trying to
push in with as little investment as
possible. Score both sides. Let HD300
clean it up. And then you're going to
re-enter over and over and over again.
next turn may just be kind of a light
double conquer replay another Azir or
it's a light double conquer play arise
just to build backline there there's a
lot of different ways that Code Man can
continue to play this going forward and
I think often at this point he wants to
actually hold runes cuz currently seven
runes next turn nine if he only pays one
power he'll be at 10 which is a one less
than what he would want to be for Arise
plus Azir accelerated and that is a
break point that is not often found by
this deck, but it is decimating when you
are able to do it.
>> All right, so we see Herder come in and
early commit. So HD uh getting back into
it. Uh but Jax last turn was able to
score some points and also set up like
you're saying set up for these next few
turns, which is great. So hidden guard
on the dreaming tree to go along with
the Aurelia HD on two going back J's way
on three and a lot of stuff in play.
Double horizon there. the charm also
that is a big pickup. There isn't a lot
of interaction in this Azir deck. Uh but
when it's able to find the right pieces
at the right time is extremely potent.
This charm is key. I talked about how
he's wanting to curve out right now. I
don't think this charm is actually going
to be used as a kill spell. I think the
way that this charm can be used, he's
ahead in points, right? Two on the other
side, he's at three. He's going to go to
five. Uh his opponent gets to go four,
he goes to seven. You're right. When he
gets to that final turn, when HD is set
up to try and just hold because he's
going to be forced into a hold. Mhm.
>> Charm just says move an enemy unit.
>> Back it out.
>> Goodbye. See you later.
>> I'll play my arise and then I'll say see
you later.
>> And uh yes, there's things like defy.
There's ways to answer it, right? But
that's going to continue to pull
resources away. It's going to continue
to to chip at those resources, not let
things happen. Uh notably, you don't
have to play into the Aelia on this turn
and a lot of runes up for Aurelia. Going
to four is fine because this deck is
built around scoring both. However, look
who's sitting at home. Little Azir
Sovereign waiting to bring all the boys
over to the Dreaming Tree. And I think
that may still be the idea that Jack
has. He just wanted to break that zone's
hourglass.
>> Yep. Good stuff. All right, so Soldiers
in War Camp is taken. A lot of uh a lot
of might on that battlefield.
Herder back home was a return by the
hourglass. And what is the next step for
Code Man Jack?
Is it going to set up a rise?
Is it a shrine to go after Aurelia?
>> He he could just say, "I'm going to put
the most amount of might you've ever
seen on this board and I'm going to send
it at your Aurelia right now." Uh, but I
think his in his mind it has to be that
this is fight or flight and this Aelia
is not dying. So, whatever he does, he
probably wants to keep charm potentially
available as an option to kind of bring
her back. So, say, "Okay, yeah, you can
fight or flight at home, but I'm you
know, she's she's coming back here,
right?"
>> And the hourglass is now gone, so can I
protect. Arise. We've got one, two,
three sand soldiers coming in. Two will
be ready there. Weapon master, do they
want to pick up those equipments?
>> Yeah, I think you can kind of uh
separated a little bit. I think uh
trying to pick the best unit to put tank
on or units to put the tank keyword on
is going to be pretty impactful here.
You you want to lose the least amount of
material um that is going to be sticking
around. You want to have a lot of these
units still kind of hanging out, able to
be equipped to uh as you can going
forward. So, we aren't going to see a
ton of movement. We are going to see,
you know, two of of the three equipment
weapon master. I guess the third one
doesn't really matter because it would
just be kind of deuces, right? Moving uh
the Dorne's blade to another sand
soldier. Um especially if you are going
to move them into this battlefield
against Aurelia with your Azir
sovereign.
>> So, now it's the big question. Is Azir
going to come in, bring all the boys to
the yard?
Jack ain't done yet. More spells to
cast. This looks like it might be the
charm.
>> No, hidden card. Okay. Okay. I
>> was going to say charm would feel a
little weird there. So, should hide a
card over at the war camp.
>> Yes, this is the only
>> All right.
>> And uh you players are we're at 5
minutes left here. So, this game looks
like it's going to conclude in a number
of turns. Uh but got to be aware clock's
always uh looming.
Hide a card pass very good for Jack.
Just enough might that Stella can't just
like offer to trade in. Kind of force
the Stella to spend uh spend some kind
of resource first, right? Nothing for
free here. That hidden card is almost
the same color as our battlefield. It is
there. Very hidden.
>> It's really hiding,
>> right? It's really lit up to the name.
You know, want us to know,
>> right? Super secret. So, we're going to
see the herder just go over to join
Aurelia and draw a card. So again, kind
of the setup. I need to find some cards.
Kind of figure out what's going on here.
HG still at three. Coen Jack at four.
Coen Jack really well set up in the back
line. Ton of might second rise in hand
and the charm.
>> It's time to ride the wind.
>> We get to see a dreaming tree draw and
then Aurelia getting a little bigger and
going to challenge the war camp. Yeah,
funny spot where the ride the wind, you
actually are because it readies, you're
actually losing a little value because
Zerellia was already ready. Uh, however,
it's the payoff for getting to draw on
Dreaming Tree cuz you have the option to
to run her home and then write the win.
So, you get the one for target, one for
readying, but then you wouldn't draw
from the Dreaming Tree. So, just
deciding the card draw was more
important. I think that's generally
correct, especially since we look at
what this whole value is, and it's quite
small.
>> Yep. So, is in fairly large. Uh, we're
looking at
>> Flip the hidden guards. Guards.
>> Yeah, guards. Guards get to be really
scary, right? Cuz this is this is uh Oh,
wait. No, here's a BF sword. Here's
another plus three.
>> So, using the airf weapon master on
defense, and that is a lot
>> of might just said 13. I'm going to
trust his math. He knows.
>> Yeah, I believe him.
>> He knows what he's doing.
>> And now, now has some work to do. Uh, is
not currently winning this fight. So,
spells need to be cast. Like you're
saying, resources need to be exhausted.
You can see a defiant dance in the
window for HD.
>> Yeah. And there's a really big part of
the Azir side of the the game plan here
where you actually kind of don't care if
Aurelia beats you like on the on the
mic.
>> You just want to get a bunch of
resources out
>> and then you do still have this charm.
You have another Arise. You have these
kind of ways to rebuild and and the Azer
is often about building an army and then
rebuilding an army. And that's the the
big thing that it likes to do
>> as long as his equipment stay around.
And so we see define dance bringing Elli
up, bringing the soldiers down. And it
looks like we're going to see a victory
for Aurelia. But like you said, that's
fine. Equipment's here. Arises in hand.
You can have your point. HD goes to
four. Aelia now has the war camp. But
resources have been exhausted. And just
a pass back for HD. So five runes up, a
lot of cards in hand. Now it's Code Man
Jack's turn to try and get things going.
It is four to four.
And again, now there's two minutes left.
So
to be aware,
>> yeah, likely a two-turn game, but it's
possible there's a little bit more. I
mean, a lot of cards in the hand for
Aurelia. And I'm seeing a lot of tricks.
What was feeling like something that was
getting simplified for, you know, such a
great hand and curve for the Azir goes
to show that what Azir does is it asks
you a question.
>> It says, "Look at all this money. Look
at all these soldiers. Look at all this
stuff that I'm sending in against you.
Beat it. And well, when I'm looking at
this hand, I think there's a real world
that Aurelia can beat it. And that's
just going to have to be what Codeman
Jack does at this point, though, is
present the question. Say, what can you
do about it? And he has to present it in
a way, you know, the skill expression
here is, "How do I present this combat?"
Because if you screw up, yeah, you're
definitely losing. If you don't put the
right number, if you could have put the
right number and you don't, that's where
the problem comes in. fortunate thing
with sovereign is it bails you out a
little bit. You can full pile in and
say, "Well, if this was an overcommit, I
can still pull it over to the other side
right afterwards."
>> Yeah. The problem here for Jack is that
a lot of the numbers that Jack is
playing are on the board. The numbers
that HD are playing are in hand,
therefore hidden, and it's hard hard to
add up numbers you can't see.
>> Well, exactly. Yeah. You ask the
question, your opponent gives you the
answer.
>> Yeah. And you might not like the answer.
>> You might not like the answer. I agree.
>> All right. So, your soldiers are moving
in. We got to count. Is that a a
brutalizer or a door and shield of a top
one?
>> It's a door and shield.
>> Okay. So, we got one. I guess the dice
help out too. So, we got three. We got
six 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 on the camp.
Coming into six on the Aelia. And that
that first defiant dance is it's tough.
So, there's a pump. Aurelia up to seven.
Ain't done yet.
We see as far as interaction goes on
Jack's side, nothing at action speed. We
have got a charm. got a rise and a zir
which is cool but
so eight because of camp
versus 11 because you said it was 13 and
the define
>> so eight versus 11 that just needs one
on guard and that's equal but equal is
not good enough here for
>> right
>> okay
rebuke
>> I mean it is a kill spell effectively uh
you can't return a sand soldier hand it
just goes to the bin. Poof.
>> So, that's gone.
>> And now really is looking uh looking
pretty good.
>> Add it up. We got nine to what we got?
Three, four, five, six, seven. Nine to
seven. My countus.
So, this is four, six.
>> The die is uh is showing the the plus
from the equipment and the minus from
the divine dance. So, Sand Soldiers
down, BF sword back to base in that one.
>> Well, I would I would say uh
they may knock him down, but they will
rise.
>> And uh here we go once again.
>> All right, still two runes available for
HD. And Aurelia ain't get any smaller.
That's part of the problem when you try
and get these multi combats is that pump
spells happen. Uh Aelia is still huge.
And if you're uh if you're HD, the way
cards are being lined up here, it's got
to be a rise. You know, kind of fiddling
with the equipments, deciding what two
are going to go on into the ready the
race hand soldiers. So,
>> Jack's thinking it through. We are now
>> elapsed. The clock has elapsed. We are
now in turns. And uh both players are at
four. So, we're going to get three extra
turns to play. And then at the end of
that, if the player's up by two, they
win.
>> If they are not, we have a draw.
I think we're going to get a conclusion
on this game
>> realistically.
>> So,
looks like there's a quick judge call.
>> So, little judge call here. Going to
work things out and get things all set
up for this arise.
Arise.
All right. Soldier number one, soldier
number two, soldier number three.
ready to
and here comes a shield.
>> Aurelia still feels kind of incalable.
>> Yeah, she's eight. This is going to be
>> It is more, but it's risky
>> is the is the again once
>> once again not knowing how much might
Aelli is actually at. Thanks for the
cards in the end tricks,
>> but going for it.
>> We haven't been doing it so far.
Jack
camp. So, four, six, seven,
>> and uh counting up.
>> Those dice are are also tracking the
might from the equipments, which is not
a typical way to do it. Judge is noting
now, but it's not tracking the war camp.
So, just making sure players are clear.
Good communication. Very important.
>> I'm seeing eight into 11 here. I see an
on guard. So, this can at least go even.
Yep.
>> The question is, is can HD300 beat it?
You need two one cost here to actually
beat this might.
>> Yep. So Jack taking a bit of a risk but
feeling comfortable. Oo. Okay. So we're
going to see an hourglass
hourglass. Uh I mean saving Aurelia is I
think if Aurelia goes down here it is
bad news bears for HD as you saw in the
last game. Once Aurelia goes down things
start to fall apart pretty quickly. So
>> no sorry this is
>> so will get uh get one of these sand
soldiers on the way out then hourglass
will retreat and will live to fight
another day.
Yeah, and they both were given tank
here. And I I wonder if that was the
correct decision. You could have just
done all tank on the weaker one and kept
the BF sword around and that would maybe
let less might be removed. But there's
also a consideration that God man
actually wants this BF sword free,
right,
>> to re-equip. So, it's really a question
of what his strategy was going into this
turn and how he wanted to play it.
>> Um, so Jack goes to five. Now, we're
seeing the herder uh on the onto the
lonesome dreaming tree. Two runes still
up for HD. We know the Ingard is in the
hand. Of course, Jack does not know
that. And I mean, Jack has to go for the
conquer here on the trigger tree, right?
To go six. Yeah. The the question now
becomes you really don't want to lose
any more material to this herder. So,
you're going to need to probably equip I
would guess maybe just even the Doran is
enough uh to make it four with tank onto
one of the sand soldiers so that you're
not just giving this free stella trade.
Uh you could just not pull anything, but
then you're just like, okay, well, play
any pump spell and I'm immediately
losing the combat, right? So I I'm
wondering exactly how the equips are
going to go cuz the BF sword was freed
up. So that is like the biggest amount
of might that you can still go for the
equip and try and pressure through in
that way. And maybe there's even a world
still where uh the charm can still be
deployed. Like if you can if you can
push above 11 might still on a
battlefield. You can charm this in and
if there's no units left for HD300,
you're probably going to win the game at
that point.
>> Yeah, I had a chartorm actually. So
that's a big deal. So going to suit up
the uh the soldier at the war camp and
we're going to see Azir coming in.
>> Okay.
>> Says milkshake time. All the boys going
to the yard,
>> right? I think it has to be I think you
have to bring the other two.
>> All right. It's going to be just the
large sand soldier.
So that is quite big. BF sword and the
door and shield.
>> What is this?
>> And we're going to see
>> ride
>> ride the wind.
and
>> you're going to send the herder
>> over to the war camp.
>> So, that's not going to break uh point
tempo at all by reconquering the war
camp, right? That's going to go to five
can go to uh six and then seven on the
following turn,
>> right? Not not not changing the math
anywhere here. He's still going to be
ahead as far the still ahead on trying
to win the game.
>> What this does open up,
>> HT300 tapped out. Yeah, Aurelia is a
seven. Charm is getting through Aurelia
now. And I think
>> that's exactly what he's reaching. He's
like, how much is this?
>> Here's the check.
>> Please tell how much
>> you're tapped. You're tapped out, right?
>> You're have nothing.
>> Nothing at all.
>> Nothing at all. Like zero things.
>> Exhausted out. What's uh let's see
what's up here.
>> That's worth all my runes.
>> Aelia, why don't you uh come out to the
dreaming tree? You know, come hang out
here. Now he has to, you know, pay
attention to what runes he's getting rid
of because there's equips that are still
going to want to potentially happen.
>> Yes,
>> Aurelia is going to kill something off.
It's taking down this sand soldier.
>> All right, so soldier down.
>> Uh, equips
>> equip.
>> All right, so crazy turn.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Read a book about that turn. You know, a
lot of things happened there. Uh, but
the hurry is going to hold to six. So,
both players are at six. And now I
believe this is turn Is this turn one or
turn two?
>> It should be turn one. That was turn
zero, right? Yeah. I Yeah, we'll see if
we get any confirmation on that. But I
that's where I'm That's where I'm
staying.
>> So, turn two. And now, if a player were
to be winning by two, they would have
eight points in order to have won the
game. So, we'll have we'll have a
natural conclusion of this game or a
draw.
>> Players at this point, you know, you
never really want a draw. uh you know
but
of course want to end in a dub if you
can but back HD's way what is the next
step came home
>> and uh monocom for uh for HD
>> I want to draw attention to a very
important card in Codeman Jack's hand
>> guards
>> able to come in ready if you spend that
extra power
>> oh yes
>> has a sand soldier at home that He kept
I was I was not sure if you could keep
it back, but he was confident to keep it
at home. And it
>> even if this Stellicorn is able to push
over Azir sovereign, which it will be,
right,
>> you can still conquer one side with your
very weak sand soldier weapon master in
and equip whatever color you don't have
of runes.
>> Yep.
>> Use the other to full equip onto that
sand soldier that you bring out from the
guards and go for that conquer to end
the game. We'll see if that can happen
as there's still three runes remaining
for HD300. But he's going to have to
expend some amount here to ensure this.
It is going to be an on guard. Two runes
left though to try and play defense on
this next turn. The big question is will
Code Man Jack have enough from all the
equips onto the accelerated pseudo
accelerated sand soldier from the
guards.
>> This is great. This has been an awesome
game. So tight,
guys. HD kind of counting things up.
There's a lot of numbers on Jack's board
despite there not being many actual
units. So we're going Jack's way. This
is the turn. Four runes available. We
got guards.
>> There's no other options. You look at
the hand.
>> That is it. Yes. Okay.
>> Azir sovereign. You don't have the five
energy.
>> Is that a face breaker behind it?
>> Face breaker not going to help you on
offense. HD300 on seven. You have to
break.
>> All right. Got to break through two
runes,
Jack. What's it going to be? Got to
count a little bit.
>> Seven might is what the guards will be
with every single thing equipped.
Two energy up, four might already there.
Defiant dance blows you out immediately.
Yep.
>> I will float three.
>> All right,
here we go. Floating three. Oh, we're
piling up. All right, pancing up the
sand soldier. That's a shield. That's a
shield. That's a big sword.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Not Note the one order rune remaining.
That's for the guards. Three energy
float.
>> Yep. All right,
>> here comes the sand soldier. Oh, I do
see defiant dance in the window.
And really, that just got a lot of
tricks. So many tricks. So, we got
soldier is we got three, four, five,
six, seven. Soldier, like you said, the
defiant dance is uh that's a four-point
swing that will have the the herder
winning the combat. That's really kind
of it, right? I mean, as far as combat
goes,
>> he's playing directly around this
because now when the guards come down
and they pick up all the other equips,
actually, they can't pick up all of
them.
>> They can't quite break over. They'd have
to. He can still Can he beat six? He can
tie six.
Okay. So, up and down. That is
Troph. I'm sorry. Believe we're we're
eight to uh three or five, six, seven,
eight to five now.
Three, four, six to five. Sorry. My bad.
>> Yeah, it should be six to five.
>> Right.
>> And
Jack. Now, what is the next step?
tough spot.
>> The pressure of the feature match area
and a big tor wasn't enough. Now you got
the the weight of a clock. The clock is
over. You made extra turns.
>> No, it's too much. He needed one more
rune.
>> I was thinking he could still get to the
>> the same amount, but
>> going to go for going to go for a face
breaker. Deciding to say, "All right,
this combat is null and void or should
stun both."
>> Oh, what could he have drawn? Hidden
blade.
>> That's not it. So, drawing a card for
Dreaming Tree. Can't find it. Wow. Would
have done it.
>> Yeah, that was a phenomenal game. Uh HD.
Woo.
>> That was some great stuff.
>> Yeah, what a surprise. It felt like, you
know, Codeman Jack was going to start to
run away with it. All the arises, all
the the huge might values he's able to
present. But this is how we presented
the Azir deck to everyone initially. It
does the thing.
>> Really just like, can I flip my up? I
was pretty.
>> So, there was a concession. Uh there we
were in because we weren't in actually
have a a victory piece cuz turns are
over.
>> So uh with HD being ahead winning that
combat looks like uh Coan Jack decided
to concede behind on board which is a
very noble thing to do of course
>> and uh yeah just a crazy ending to an
absolutely crazy game.
>> Yeah, I mean that's the thing with Azir,
right? You're able to present the
question if your opponent has the
answer. Sometimes that's all all all she
wrote for you. And this time around, I
would say that HD300 was able to have
the answers that he needed over the
course of that game, especially because
I think the question that Azir was
asking was pretty tough. That was like
some AP calculus that was being given to
the other side. You know, a lot of
different numbers being able to hit the
board, a lot of the sand soldiers coming
through and at the end of the day able
to get it done.
All right. Well, as that that match
wasn't enough, we got another match for
you. Right. We're going to roll right
along here into our backup match and uh
watch some Riftbound. What do we got? We
got a little Victor. Oh, well, Manten,
uh, this is Cody Williams. He won the
best of Victor in Houston. Uh, and so he
did not quite get it in Bolognia, but he
he tried to get in baloney, he didn't
quite get there, and now he's coming
back to Vegas to give it another shot.
And, uh, yeah, as we can see some of the
new additions to Spirit Forge. Sinjao
very powerful unit only being used as a
one of but this gives it some additional
you know pseudo accelerate coming in
ready for this deck paying three in a
power for four as long as you have two
units at base with the the will come in
ready and then also adding the very
powerful removal combo of Bellow's
breath to go alongside your Imperial
decree. Uh when you're able to play
these two cards together, you can
basically remove everything on the
board. As I decree just means anything
that takes damage on for the rest of the
turn will die. Bell's breath just kind
of pinging multiple targets for one.
>> Interesting one here is we see three
copies of Riptide Rex.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Three copies. Is that
>> Yeah. Oh, he was playing those in uh in
Origins. He said he still likes them. Uh
we we had an interview with him when he
won the best of at Houston and I asked
him, you know, what card maybe
overperformed for you for this deck for
you to kind of get there? And Riptide
Rex was the one at the very top of the
list as being a deck, a card that is
absolutely overperformed. And I will say
when we look at the meta right now,
there's a lot of these uh four life
units that are looking to hold Draven.
You know, you're going to have a lot of
these Noxious Hopefuls. Uh and then
Pharaoh's forrunner. You got to find
some way to deal with it. And being able
to play a six my body and then deal with
some of these big threats that like to
sit on bases. Even just threatening an
Aelia saying, "Here's six, flinch. what
do you want to do? And then from there,
you might be able to play the rest of
your offensive turn and still kind of
deal with it. So, I think Riptide Rex
actually got better position now than it
ever was in Origins. And he was loving
it in Origins.
>> That's really cool. Three Rex and three
Singularity is a big statement. Uh
really, really cool stuff. So, on the
other side, we're going to see Math
Doctor. You have to be a Math Doctor to
play Aelia, I feel like.
>> Yeah, a lot of Aelia have been very
popular so far. Third most represented
deck, I believe, at this tournament. And
we're seeing yet another flavor in a
sense, but realistically this is more
another flavor in a couple of one-ups
that are sneaking around, right?
Creeping around in this deck. Uh the
siren, which we haven't seen in some of
these lists, but it's been pretty
prevalent across all Aurelia decks. And
then having this Edge of Knight as like
another kind of hidden card to bluff
with that also, you you know, you were
mentioning the hidden card, are you ever
afraid of losing it when you try and
back away? This is yet another one where
you can kind of just flip over whenever,
equip it, and then kind of run home and
pivot around as you wish. So, uh, cool
to see, but yet yet again another sneaky
version. We'll be seeing this Obliska
power game one. Sounds great. Well,
we're going to go right into game three,
actually, as our backup match here. Hop
right into the action and we're going to
see Raven Balloon Conservatory for
Victor. Really cool new battlefield.
>> Yeah, it's uh, you know, funny enough in
this one, I think Aurelia is relatively
happy to see Raven Balloon Conservatory.
A lot of card draw can come from that
from her when she is able to hold. So
that's going to be the target to hold.
You you want to conquer the sunken
temple, keep getting your draws. But
when you actually look, you know, cards
on the table need to hold against the
Victor. Raven Bloom is going to be your
friend as Aurelia.
>> Yeah. So we have both Conservatory and
Senate Temple drawing cards, meaning a
lot of cards will be drawn in this game.
Very high resource game. Who's that
favor?
>> I think a high resource game is going to
favor Aurelia. You're going to find more
of your answers that you need to deal
with the threats that Victor can pose
towards you. You're going to find your
defies for the cult leagues, right?
You're going to find you're not so fast
for uh the singularities or the other
kill spells that you need to worry
about. So, what becomes the biggest
thing that I want to look at for man is
is actually going to be impure decree as
the way that you actually have to look
for the removal. It's the one where
there isn't really an answer for
Aurelia, right? They have the zas, they
have the guardians angel. some ways to
kind of start to respond, but there's
not a big immediate answer to counter
out Imperial Decree. You have to counter
out maybe the Bellow's Breath that gets
cast with it, but maybe they just have a
bunch of units that are going to start
pushing into you to try and deal with
you with decree. So, there's it becomes
one of the more difficult cards to
actually manage where the rest of them
you can have answers to.
>> Did you catch how many hard bargains
were in Math Doctor's main deck and
cyborg?
>> I did not and I thought it was zero, but
I'm not convinced on that. So, we'll
have to keep our eyes out on the hand if
you can find one. That is the answer
that can exist, but it's been very
unpopular in Aelia, so I'm not always
expecting it to be there.
>> Okay, well, we got a two drop battle
here. Lonely Porum versus Anst Broker.
Brokers are going to come in on the
conservatory and score the first point
of the game. And of course, if it
defends, conservatory will trigger. Look
for some spells on top of the library.
Victor got plenty of those.
We'll see what Manton's next step is.
>> Game three.
I was I was looking at this uh lecturing
Yortle and I feel like Yortle plus
recruit feels pretty reasonable to just
go for if your broker dies that's fine.
It'll get a conservatory trigger and
potentially a gold for you. So really
doing everything that you want it to do.
Looking at the hand though salvage as
well another way to continue to try and
push through whatever Aurelia tries to
set up with the zas and with that
guardian angel. So, you know, finding
the ways to break through that Mantin
needs to deal with Aurelia once she hits
the table. And for Math Doctor, there's
a lot of matchups where you just want to
try and slam her on this turn two. You
really can't against Victor because the
3x Singularity will immediately punish
you if you just try and play her out.
>> Yeah, for sure. A lot of uh lot of
things for Matog to work around. So,
we're going to see the Porro get frisky
here.
Be so nice playing Victor, too, where
you just have that wasted energy at any
point. Oh, I'll make a recruit. Oh,
singularity up the top from Raven Bloom.
>> Hello. So, defend on the broker. So, so
singularity will be drawn. Going to go
for the discipline to win the combat,
but uh that foreign knowledge of
singularity, it's a good thing to know
about.
>> Yeah, now you know to play around it.
And often singularity is kind of clunky
to play into the Aurelia anyways. Um and
with Math Doctor knowing it, that
singularity is going to often be dead.
But guess what? It's kind of a free car.
Uh it came from a battlefield that in
any other battlefield you would not have
this singularity. And it's another tool
for your toolboxes, Victor, in the world
that Math Doctor ever forgets about it
and gives you a window that Singularity
is just going to be able to win the
game. And instead, it's going to be a
dehand. Math Doctor trying to rush the
points. And turns out, I mean, even this
turn, if there's nothing else in your
hand that's better to do, Singularity
Conquer both is really not that
horrible.
>> Yeah. So, trading blows here. Math
Doctor up to two and not exactly the
most, you know, the strongest position
on these battlefields. tapped out with
the two mightite on both.
Go Manton's way and we're going to see
just wait for the pain of pain.
>> Yeah, that's nice.
>> Taking out the porro. Very lonely, very
sad. Draw a card.
>> Gold number two. Efficient. You don't
want to give conservatory trigger over
to Aurelion. Let her draw. So, you
really did want to kill that porro with
a spell regardless no matter what cuz we
do have a very clean clear available.
Yortle stupify wages get rid of both of
the little units for math doctor and
reset a board state where call the week
is backbreaking. Yeah, and great
efficiency tier too, right? You know,
every card's perfect here. One stupify,
draw a card, draw a card. So, great
progression. Uh, but also card advantage
too. And, uh, Manton looking quite nice
here at three points and on the board.
Going to look either is there a two drop
that can still be played out. And there
is blundering Porro. If not, as you
said, hey, look, we can just victory.
>> All right. So, Porro's in
back math doctor's way. And you're
right, that call week, the call of the
week insurance is gone. There are no
more stinkers floating around to eat the
call. So Aurelia is uh vulnerable to
multiple things here, possible call,
definite singularity.
That's kind of the thing, too, where if
Math Doctor wants to play around
singularity by playing and trying to
protect it with some sort of pump
action, uh call will mop up.
>> Yeah. Well, and Matton's also just
threatening to go to five now. I mean
like in and for Math Doctor to contest
that it's like
>> Aurelia plus something that targets plus
ready plus go
>> that doesn't feel very good. I don't
want to do that at all. So I think
Manton is going to five here and then
has the ability to retreat if he wants
or try and set up some kind of hold. I
it feels really difficult for Aurelia to
now impact the board. And this is where
Victor uh can really shine in this
matchup because when Call is such a high
threat, it creates these game states
where they have to respect it so much
that you just gain equity. And uh this
is one of the decks where Call can
absolutely obliterate you.
>> Oh boy. All right. So in there are two
runes up for Math Doctors, possible
defies, things like that. Going mantis
away. We got two old points going to
five more runes, runes, gold, units,
cards in hand. Things looking great for
Manton.
See, Singularity, Salvage,
Imperial Decree.
Now, what is the next step?
>> You know what's kind of funny? He
doesn't really have a ton of plays on
this turn cuz there's a lot of like uh
spells, reactor type stuff. I wonder if
he just fires a missile at Aurelia and
says, "Play a card.
>> Give me a card." You know, it's annoying
because of deflect, but you have two
gold, so it's kind of like, "Ah, you
know what? I can trade gold for you to
have to play a card." Cuz I'm looking at
the rest. I I don't really see any units
here. Is that maybe maybe a manufacturer
that can be played as well on this turn.
Uh but even then there's not a whole ton
of action speed that's available. So
there's just kind of where do you want
to acrew value? The the other option is
often times it's hard to find a spot to
actually play Victor from the champion
zone. And this feels like maybe a turn
where you actually can make that happen.
And I think we're going to see kind of
one of the two where it's like you
either just try and force a spell and
say use your energy like use a tool that
saves this right now or you just say you
know what I can just develop my base and
then we can go from there and play
manufacturer plus uh Victor from champ
and I think that might be the decision
here.
>> Yeah, it's a lot of might. I do like the
the thought of the you know I'm ahead
right now. Let's just exchange resources
with my card for your card. Let's just
exchange. I I'll see I'll keep being
ahead but this looks great too.
>> This maths out perfect as well, right?
the three, four, and then you get the
one from the last recruit.
>> So, every energy used, the recruit looks
like him at Stanley the Conservatory.
Really cool. So, you can try to get a
card off, which is cool.
>> And then a bunch of might in the back
row again. Imperial decree in hand for
Manton as well as singularity we know
about. Uh, lot going on. So, Mad Doctor
is up against it and has a lot of work
to do to try and uh start piecing this
game back together and starts with a
couple runes and a drawstep. Let's
figure it out.
>> Yeah, decree being kept in the mole. I
just I I fully agree with it. I love it
that from Manton just recognizing the
wind quant and this is the most
difficult card for my opponent to deal
with. It's not that it can't be dealt
with. It is that it is the most
difficult. And by having this tool on
the back burner, he's always going to
have this threat. When Math Doctor is
forced to hold, he has to hold through
an Imperial decree. And I don't know how
many times you've had to try and do
that. It's not fun.
>> It's not easy.
>> Yeah.
>> When you actually do, you feel so
amazing. when you're able to kind of
prevent every little thing from
happening. But look at this board and
try and imagine getting through a
decree. I just think it's it's not
feasible uh for Math Doctor outside of
uh retreating the Aurelia. And with
Manton at five, that might not be an
option very quickly.
>> Yeah, things only get worse too where
you know the Victor player is going to
play at least one unit every turn no
matter what cuz of Victor and then other
units as well and spells. So the uh the
ball is rolling down the hill for
Mansion. Can Nat Doctor stop it and turn
it around?
Gonna start math through
math doctor. Parents must be proud.
>> Oh yeah,
>> that's
>> I can't do I can't do math or be a
doctor.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm neither of these things. I'm not
math.
>> Yeah,
>> the fur of brow over. See a defiant
dance. Looks like a is a rebuke in the
window.
>> Lot of cards as always. Aelia had just a
lot of cards in hand, so therefore a lot
to work through. Well, it has to be the
most annoying thing, right? You you
you're at the point where your hand
says, "Okay, we'll go for a hold." But
if you keep up a bunch of runes and you
go for a hold and you pass it over to
Manton, he says, "All right, cool. I'll
go to six on the other battlefield."
>> Yep.
>> And then, uh, all right, go. Like, I'll
play a bunch of stuff. Go. And then, you
know, you're like, "Okay, cool." And
then you go to your next turn and
Manton's at six and he's got 400 runes
and he's got uh you know 9 million units
on this board and uh
>> you're you're really taking the math
thing to heart.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. So like I'm not you
know I'm not a math doctor. I don't know
any I'm just saying I just know I know
some numbers and I think they're really
cool numbers so I share them with
>> I like those numbers.
>> Yeah, they're great numbers. Really?
Yeah.
>> They're really they're really awesome
numbers. Uh, but then you just can go
from there and it's like, okay, if
there's a decree, like I just lose cuz
there's all these different units here
and no matter what, I'm not going to be
able to deal with it. And if there's not
a decree, there's still a lot like a big
math puzzle here and a bunch of uh, you
know, a bunch of might and like, you
know, you're going to need an ambulance.
You're going to need like a
statistician. And it's a good thing he's
a math doctor because I think nobody
else is is qualified to try and figure
out the puzzle that will be put before
him. And even then, he's got his work
cut out for him.
>> So, it's going to start with a draw. So
really will pop into a slunk temple and
draw a card as if there were enough
cards already in hand. So further
complicating the puzzle see boots of
swiftness
and really working it through. Plenty of
time here. 15 minutes is quite a bit of
a clock and uh this feels like one of
those games that's going to you know
conclude in the next decent number of
turns one way or another if uh do gonna
pull it through or the onslaught of
Victor is able to overcome
really working it through so if you're
man right now what are you thinking
about you're you're totally exhausted
you know you're looking at your opponent
really the gears are turning you know
what's your thought process
>> considering the current board state in
my hand. If I'm Manton, I'm saying,
you know, go ahead and think, make your
play, whatever. I'm thinking about where
I'm getting lunch. I'm thinking about
round four. I'm thinking about, wow,
it's round five. I'm thinking it was
great to be four.
>> I'm think
right there. Oh, man.
>> See what I'm saying, Jim? I'm saying
you're thinking, you're thinking, yeah,
do whatever you want. You've lost.
You've already lost.
>> What's for lunch?
>> Yeah. What's for lunch?
>> That's a good place to be. All right.
Great win there from Manton. Uh really
really solid draw and uh just great
stuff from our our Victor player.
Victor, you know, Victor's a deck that's
been kind of floating around. You know,
not the the highest tier, but it's been
hanging out.
>> Oh yeah. I mean, it's it's still you
look we it had that top four ghost
driver in Bolognia piloting a very
different version of Victor, I will say,
to Mant uh uh to that, but there's at
least some similarity, right? Cuz I
don't think either of them were on the
full spell Victor. I do think uh you
know, Ghost Driver was a little lower to
the ground. We have a lot more expensive
units with the 3x reptide Rex. There
were riptide rexes in Ghosters's list,
but I don't know if it was three. Still,
this is a very Manton build. This is
similar to what he played in Origins.
Really not many adjustments. It's the
same style of Victor he's been doing the
entire time, and he's had a lot of
success, and he's got to be one of the
best Victor players that we've got. And
so, you know, we're seeing it again. 40,
great start.
>> Love seeing it. Let's hear from him
right now.
>> Thank you very much. I'm here with
Manton, the best of Victor from Houston.
Unsurprisingly, back on Victor.
>> Yeah, of course. I love the deck, so I
had to bring it out. I tried to do it in
Bolognia, but someone had to go and get
top four and steal away from me. So,
we're here to try and get in.
>> So, that match up you just played was
against Aurelia. Certainly seems like a
tough match up from what you said. Uh,
is it generally going to be a problem
cuz that is a pretty big chunk of the
metag game.
>> Yeah, Aurelia has been kind of like a
nemesis for me for the last like several
events that I've been going to. Uh,
since they switched in and they started
putting the two drops in, um, they're a
lot faster, which is an issue. There's a
lot of opens they can do where they just
have like a GA on a Stellone Herder.
They go in, they draw 17 cards. There's
like no way for me to win. I lose the
game every single time on on tree. Uh so
the game is very very hard. And I mean
when I bologonia, two of my losses were
Aurelia. My loss yesterday, my only loss
yesterday was to Aurelia. So when I sat
down and I selia again, I was like, "Oh
no, not again." But luckily we we stole
a couple of wins here. So I got that one
off my back.
>> And you mentioned Bologinu, of course,
Victor making, which is an amazing
result. Did you change anything at all
coming into this event off the back of
that deck list?
>> Well, I took the that deck list. Uh, I
played it almost verbatim yesterday um
in like the the sixth round event and I
did pretty well X1. There's a bunch of
stuff I didn't like in it, so I rip all
that out. But I really liked the Zen. I
really liked the pickpocket. Um, I
really the thing that I don't think a
lot of people noticed that uh that was
really strong is when you switch the
battlefields and you take obelisk out
now when you play a two might guy going
first, you can you get to challenge your
opponent right away instead of just
using uh Victor hero ability and it
changes the complete dynamic of how that
game normally operates. And my opponents
now when I put like I have a two might
on the board, they're like, "Wait, wait.
It's supposed to be one might. I'm I'm
used to just running you over. I don't
know what to do here." So that has been
the biggest innovation from that list.
>> Well, makes a lot of sense. Hopefully
the Victoria keeps on winning. Best of
luck for the best of
>> Appreciate it. Thank you.
>> Really great stuff. I got to say, I just
love seeing a player who knows their
deck inside and out, backwards and
forwards. They've just tried every
little thing and they just know exactly
what they're doing. It's the best of
system that really starts to bring this
out for almost every deck in the game.
You know, we we had Tito getting two
garens back to back. We have a lot of
these players who have kind of turned
their best of attempts or best of wins
into the identity of them as players in
Riftbound. And we get to see a lot more
innovation in decks that maybe would
have been lesser explored. So cool. I
love seeing the mastery. But that's it
for here for round number five. Round
number four. So, we're going into round
number five. We'll see you soon.